learn how to use Python to analyze
astronomical data this is a great real
world use case to help you improve your
data analysis skills the course offers a
practical Hands-On approach to
simplifying complex Concepts in data
analysis making it great for beginners
you'll journey through modules covering
python Basics tabular and image data
visualization and advanced image
processing techniques all focused on
real world astronomical applications
yeah ash from spart official Innovations
developed this
course hi everyone I first of all like
to welcome each and every one of you to
this program on astronomy research data
analysis where you are going to learn to
create some amazing beautiful looking
visualizations that you can create from
a boring looking CSV data or a tabular
data and even from the raw data from the
astronomical surveys how you can take
that images and extract some amazing
features fees present in those images so
all of this kind of work you are going
to do in this particular program and
then whatever kind of visualizations
that you will be generating you can
extract from python into your particular
system and then later on use it for your
research work thesis work or internship
report right so that's the kind of thing
that we are going to deal with in this
program so this whole program is divided
into four different modules to make
these things very easier for you guys
okay but before I go ahead explain any
of this let me quickly introduce to you
all myself so I am Rohan and I'm
currently working at SP artificial as a
machine learning engineer and I'll be
the one who's going to guide you
throughout this whole program and I'll
promise you guys that you are just going
to simply enjoy this program and you
just need to code along with me that's
one thing that is really important if
you don't code along with me it's just
going to be boring for you okay
especially if you are new to python you
need to code along with me because each
and every code that I'll be writing in
the uh upcoming uh modules I'll be
writing from scratch so I'm 100% willing
that you all are going to code along
with me okay so now let's talk about
each and every module that we are having
over here so the first module we are
going to start from extreme scratch even
if you are very new to python it's
completely fine in the first module I
have covered each and every basics of
python that you will require to create
some amazing uh visualizations with the
help of python okay so module one is
compulsory for you guys just in case if
you are new to python if you're already
aware about the python then you are good
to go ahead and move to module two in
module two you are going to deal with a
CSV tabular data that data will be based
on some kind of real stars out there in
Universe now from that tabular data you
are going to create some beautiful
visualizations including an HR diagram
if you're not sure about what is HR
diagram it's completely fine okay we are
going to learn about that in module two
then in module three we are going to go
to the astronomical surveys where we are
having this raw images taken from
multiple different telescopes and from
that surve we are just going to fetch an
image of Andromeda galaxy and then do
some of the uh pixel scaling and all
this kind of basic visualizations with
respect to an image data and finally in
the fourth module the last Model you are
going to take that Andromeda galaxy and
do a bit advanced level of image
processing and I going to teach you that
if you want to implement any kind of
filter if you want to extract any kind
of features that how you can do it with
the help of python so that's exactly
what we are going to cover in all of
this upcoming four modules for this
particular program and I hope that you
are just going to enjoy this okay so
let's get started with the first
particular module that is basics of
python from the next
video hey guys welcome to the second
video of module one and here I'm going
to introduce you to Google collaboratory
notebooks or in short you can also call
them as Google collab notebooks okay so
for those who are not aware about it
already we use them in order to code in
Python without actually installing
anything in our system isn't it just
great so that's exactly what we'll be
doing throughout this whole particular
program so what exactly are this Google
collab notebooks how it works all of
this kind of information you'll be
getting in this particular video so
let's get into it right away
so let's understand that how we can use
this kind of python notebooks that are
available online in order to code in
Python the one that we are going to use
is specifically called as Google collab
notebooks okay so you go to Google and
search for Google
collab and now if you come on to the
second link you just click on that it
will redirect you to this page where you
are getting this option of creating a
new notebook so let's go ahead and click
on that new notebook and now I don't
need that first TP so I'll just close
that up now the whole idea about this
kind of notebooks which we also call as
interactive python notebooks in short
ipynb as you can see over here also
right these files are basically used in
order to have the mixtures of Tex cells
along with the code cells so what you
are seeing right now on my screen this
particular cell which is getting blinked
like that this is called the code cell I
can create multiple code cells by
clicking over here right and I can do my
specific task I want to do over here
here here and get my outputs done you
will be using this a lot as we go ahead
in this program but yeah this is a very
very basic introduction with respect to
this code let's say you writing some
kind of a code in Python over here if
you want to run it you simply come over
here and click on this or else you can
also see there is a shortcut that is
control enter you click on control enter
and this code is going to run okay and
let's if you want to go to the next cell
by running this cell you click on shift
enter it automatically shifts your
cursor to the next code cell or any kind
of cell let's if I want to create a text
Cell between both of this code cell i h
my mouse in between two cells and over
here I'm getting the option of text I
click on that and I get this option of
this Tex cell now the purpose of the Tex
cell over here in this kind of ipy andb
notebooks uh is to give you some kind of
description of what will be done in this
following code C that we are writing
so in this kind of interactive python
notebooks you are getting this kind of
facilities to decorate your notebook the
way you want so that if anyone who is
going to look into this notebook or for
that matter let's say even yourself who
are going to look into this notebook
after let's say some months you need to
know that if your documentation is good
and Visually appealing then it's very
easy to find out a lot of stuff and it's
going to be interesting to like you know
scroll through this whole notebook and
get to the exit point where you want
want to find out some kind of
information so it all depends on to like
you know how much decorative notebooks
you want to create how much kind of
information in text you want to add and
then how much kind of code things you
want to code over here and get your job
done now here that was a very quick
introduction about the Google collab
notebook and pretty much uh things that
you need to know about Google collab is
I guess enough over here some of the
things that we can do to start over here
before moving on to the second video
would be let's say by naming this
notebook I'll change this notebook name
to Let's the basics of
python okay any kind of name that is
going to describe what kind of content
is present within this notebook and then
I can also create a text cell and give a
heading with the help of this hash and
let's say because this kind of uh whole
program is dedicated for astronomy
visualizations and Analysis from that
visualizations what we can do is we can
give a good name like
python
basics for
astronomy something like this whatever
you you the best right and then after
this we can start coding ourself for the
first thing in Python let's say just
like everyone does in Python like or any
kind of programming language here let's
say we are going to print hello world
right so if I'm writing hello world like
this and then I'm just going to pass
this kind of hello world within
print
this is going to be our first code that
we have written in Python print hello
world and that's exactly being printed
over here so now in this video I've have
shown you how you can create this kind
of text cells give headings or not just
headings you can give images over here
you can add links to a specific word you
want to add like you know you want your
people to redirect to some stuff you can
have bold ital like and all this kind of
stuff after that I've also shown you how
you can start using this kind of code
cells in Python and obviously if you did
not understand what have I written over
here why did I specifically have this
kind of uh quotation mark everything
will be covered in the upcoming videos
so stay
tuned hello everyone welcome to the
third video of module one and here we
are going to talk about python commands
so what exactly are these python
commands why do we need them and what
are some kind of different ways to
actually create them all of these kind
of things we are going to discuss in
this video so let's get into it
all right so now that we have written a
specific code in Python now let's say I
want some kind of a way through which I
can describe what I have written over
here or what is the purpose of writing
this kind of code I can do this with the
help of python comments okay for that
again I'll have to use this kind of
hashtag and then I just give any kind of
description that describes what is the
purpose of writing this code what does
it explain so now because this was the
my first code that I have shown you in
python I can give this kind of a comment
like my first code in Python you can
also write this thing for yourself right
so what is the main purpose of writing
this kind of commments so whenever you
are writing some kind of a logic of your
code if you're are having this kind of
comments that you are writing to
describe your logic that how did you
come up to this particular logic to
solve a particular problem then what
happens that even after let's say one
year two years if you're coming onto
this notebook and now because you having
this kind of descriptions in Python that
is describing what you have done it's
giving you a hint a some kind of this
kind of a click to your brain that okay
now I remember why I had coded this
specific thing in this way maybe because
after two years of time if you're coming
onto this concept which you haven't
touched in a while let's say you're
trying to apply for an interview you
want to take a project that you have
created over here and explain it to them
so if you are trying to revise something
which you haven't used in quite a while
now so if you will be having this kind
of comments in Python that will help you
to revise this kind of things very
quickly because this kind of comments is
going to click your brain that okay now
I remember what was the reason that I
had done this kind of code in this
specific way right so that's the whole
idea with respect to python commands but
now that's not the only one way through
which you can have the comments in
Python okay because over here we are
having only one line of comment what if
I want multiple lines of comment right
for that what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create one more text cell over
here first of all and just introduce to
that my the first thing that I'm
teaching you guys is about
comments okay and I can also give this
into this way of heading okay three
hashes and now you can clearly see that
this kind of text is much more smaller
in size as compared to this so this
looks good right but yeah now what I'm
going to do is I already explained the
first thing about the comments over here
now let's if you want want to have
multiple line comments okay so what I
can do is I can use three quotation
marks I either I can use three single
quotation marks or three double
quotation marks both of them is going to
work just the same okay so I am having
my first three uh double quotations like
this and three double quotations at the
bottom now anything that I'm going to
write within this quotation marks is
going to be like a comment your python
is not going to execute as in the format
of you know some kind of a code it's
going to do something it's just some
kind of a description that you are going
to mention over here let's say some kind
of huge description you want to write
have okay as compared to just a single
line then obviously you can go ahead and
use this kind of things let's say this
is my first line of
comment this is my second line of
comment I'll be showing you this that
I'll be using this when I'm going to
teach you the concepts of functions at
that times I'll be using this kind of
multi-line comments now again let's say
that you you are having bunch of lines
that you you want to write let's again
this is my first
comment this is my second
comment now let's if you want to comment
all of this thing with the help of this
hashtag only you don't want to use this
kind of uh quotation marks then what you
can do is let's say how many lines how
however how many lines I am having it
doesn't matter the important thing is
that I'm going to select the whole text
and then press control+ forward slash
and automatically it's going to give me
this kind of
hashes by itself I didn't do anything I
just press control and the forward slash
what did I
do I selected the text below and pressed
what control plus this by doing this
together you can either comment all of
this kind of code or maybe DEC comment
it by again pressing the same thing
that's simple that it gets for the
comments so for a quick revision what we
have done over here is now you know how
to create print statements in Python
obviously not like you are not aware
about this that what why did we use this
kind of quotation marks what happens if
we don't use it I'll be explaining all
of that thing in the following videos
but yeah for now you know how this kind
of print statement Works in order to
print something and then what are the
kind of need of writing com for your
code now in the next video I'm going to
talk about what are variables and
constants that we need in
Python hey guys welcome to the fourth
video of module one and here we are
going to understand the concept of
variables and constants in Python what
is the difference between them and when
and how should we use them all of these
things you'll be getting in this
particular video now one thing that I
really want to make sure over here is
that I hope that you all are coding
along with me that's the whole fun about
this particular program that you are
going to code along with me and it's
going to give you live experience
instead of just watching the video all
right so if you haven't begun it till
now this is the right time to get
started with it okay so let's get into
the
video so now what I'll be doing is I'll
be just uh commenting this whole thing
because like you know it's looking very
ugly what is the reason behind that you
will be understanding right now in this
video so what you are studying right now
is called as variables and constants
okay so before I write any kind of code
I'll be giving a text that describes
that I'm going to explain about
variables and
constants okay now what I'm doing over
here is just remember your classes of
mathematics you know that we give this
kind of things like X is equal to 3 Y is
equal to 5 or any kind of number six
whatever it is right you know that you
do these kind of things so so what we
are doing over here is essentially we
are saying that X is a variable that is
going to take the value of three it's
just like that Y is a variable that is
going to take the value of
six now what is the whole purpose of
having these kind of variables in your
code for example let's say that I'm
writing a lot of huge code and somewhere
I want to use the idea of that data that
I assigned to that letter x
I want to use that again and again for
example I'm giving you a very short
example let's say I'm having uh value of
three that I want to add to a value of
three itself let's say 3 +
3 now if I want to write let's say 4 + 4
what I'll have to do is I'll have to
change this to 4 + 4
manually now like this let's say I'm
having a huge chain four five then again
four then again five like this okay and
now I saying that I want to change this
values of all fours to threes I'll have
to change this
manually and fives to
twos I'm doing all of this change
manually and let's say that this kind of
code is pretty much long and you are
having multiple times you have to change
these things so it does not make sense
to write these things again and again in
every kind of lines so what we do is we
try to store this kind of data in a
variable for example x equal 3 Y is
equal 2 and now I just need to type x +
x + y + x + y That's it now if I want to
see so you can see that this is 3 + 3
why because X is having the value of
three now in place of two we know we are
giving y because we know that Y is equal
to 2 and similarly again x + y now let's
if I again want to change this to 4 4
545 I just need to change x value to
four y value to five as simple as that
so that's the power of having variables
in
Python now just like that there's also a
concept of constants okay what I'm going
to do is I'm going to Simply go ahead
and first of all print this to show you
the outputs how it looks
like so you are having this kind of 22
over here directly it's the summation of
this 4 + 4 + 5 + 4 + 5 so that's how
this kind of thing is working now one
difference between this variables and
constants in Python is what you are
having if you're trying to Define a
variable you're always going to Define
it with the help of lowercase letter you
are always going to Define it in the
lowercase letter and the moment if you
want to convert this into a constant you
define it into an uppercase letter now
this uppercase letter is going to
indicate anyone who is reading your code
in Python that okay yeah now I know that
this X is never going to change
throughout your code whereas your
variables can go ahead and change any
kind of data that you want to store in
the variable because the name variable
itself means that it is varying right
it's not constant right so that's the
idea what I'm trying to say is that in
my next code over here I can change the
value of y to some other value for
example
one but because I have mentioned X in
the upper
case we are simply saying that okay yeah
this x will always be four it will never
be changed no matter how deep codes I'm
writing X will always be
four so that's a very common difference
between variables and constants in
variables you try to assign any kind of
data in form of uh small or lowercase
letters and if you want to store the
value of
constance what you do is you assign any
kind of value and uh give a uppercase
letter to that so now both of them are
now stored in in the format of what
constants all right as you can see there
are this kind of lines that are
appearing that are giving you this kind
of yellow yellow lines what it indicates
it's simply indicating that X is not
defined Y is not defined why it's not
defined because I have removed that part
of code I have removed that part of code
but at the same time it's also stored in
the memory of this notebook it is also
stored in the memory of this notebook
what I'm trying to say is if I comment
out this code and now I run this even
though I haven't defined XX YX y anymore
it's still giving me the output why
because initially while explaining you
the code over here I had started with
small X and small y so now that small X
and small Y is by default stored into
the memory of this notebook so make sure
these kind of things are not uh repeated
in your notebook or else you're going to
run into some kind of Errors okay but
here was a very quick description with
respect to what are variables and what
are constants and when you should use
what variables can change its data that
it's trying to store and constant will
try to have a very constant value it
will never change throughout the whole
code that's the whole idea now I'll see
you next with respect to what is strings
in
Python hey guys so welcome to the fifth
video of module 1 and here you are going
to understand what are some basic data
types available in Python we are not
going to talk about all of the data
types just some of them including string
integer and Float okay and also when I'm
going to start the video I'm also going
to talk about the concept of runtime in
Google collab it's really important guys
that you understand this particular
concept so I'm just going to start with
this concept in this video so let's get
into
it so now now let's look into the
strings so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create one text cell give a
heading as strings
okay and now if I press shift enter it
automatically creates a code cell for me
now one thing okay before I'm starting
the explanation of the concepts of
strings I really want to show you what
really happens if you try to click on
this runtime and let's say for example
you want to restart your notebook okay
so what you do is you click on restart
runtime it saying that whatever kind of
memory that was stored in this notebook
everything will be reset and if I let's
say click on yes and now if I try to run
this code see what's going to happen
it's going to throw an error this time
because XX YX y this small X and small y
variables are gone because I deleted all
the memory by restarting my run time so
that's one thing that you need to keep
in mind okay if you want to uh Define
this X and Y and if then removing it and
changing it to some other thing then you
should be cautious about that thing so
now moving on to the strings and uh the
concepts with respect to that so what is
the whole idea behind the strings right
so let's if you're having some kind of a
numeric data you know how you can assign
it to some kind of variable or constants
that's fine but now what you if you're
having some kind of a text data that you
want to assign to a variable for example
let's say I'm trying to create some sort
of
variables create
variables to
store the
information about a planet in our solar
system let's say the first thing that
I'm trying to store is the name of the
planet so I need to assign some kind of
variable to that particular name of the
planet that I'm going to use so for that
again I'll have to create a variable
right so let's say I'm going to call it
as a
planet
name something like this you can also
call it as a name underscore Planet
anything that you like now over here if
I want to give a name as Venus like this
it's not going to work
why because there is nothing like Venus
that we have defined anywhere just like
for this X and Y that we had seen in our
previous video and even for that matter
in the starting of this video we if we
did not defend this small X small y it's
going to give you this kind of uh yellow
kind of of line below that thing that
hey you haven't given me any kind of
value that we need to give to
Venus so it's going to run into an error
that Venus is not defined if I go ahead
and run
this it's going to say that name Venus
is not defined because we haven't given
any value to this so if you want to
assign a text data to some kind of a
variable you always do it with the help
of this kind of quotation marks now this
quotation marks is going to ensure that
okay now this is a string this is called
as a string in Python and now if you run
this it is storing this kind of Text
data in the variable called planet name
now if I want to go ahead and print this
thing let's say I'm trying to print the
name of this planet by calling the
variable in which I have stored it and
now you will be seeing that it's
printing the Venus value what happens if
I'm going to print like Venus without uh
even defining what is Venus right like
this it's again going to throw an error
that Venus is not defined because in
itself you have not defined Venus as a
variable over here planet name was a
variable which we have defined earlier
before printing it and that's why this
is running without any kind of Errors
unlike this thing that you are seeing
over here and the same kind of concept
has been used over here in order to
print hello world I need to pass it in
the format of this kind of quotation
marks so that it is converting this kind
of data into string and now python
understands automatically that go ahead
and print this string data it's not a
variable anymore if you don't give this
kind of quotation marks it expects this
hello to be a
uh some kind of a variable you can again
see there is some kind of automatic
yellow line appearing right because we
haven't defined this hello if I run this
it's going to run into an error right so
that was the reason why I was having
even the quotation mark in in the first
code that I had shown you guys to print
hello world so that's how you can define
a string uh in Python with the help of
this quotation marks now it's not that
you always use this kind of double
quotation marks you can use single
quotation mark I can do the same thing
by giving this kind of single quotation
mark this is also a string I can go
ahead and print the same thing it's
going to be Venus this time right I'm
going to Del this code and now I can
also use let's say three quotation marks
either of single type or double type
even that is fine again this is pretty
much useful when you want to create a
string which is of multiple lines so
let's say I want to give a description
line by line let's say this is Venus
right and now I want to give this
information that planet
name is
Venus okay now I want to give this kind
of information this is the second
planet in our solar system first is
mercury second is Venus right so this
kind of information if I'm giving over
here if I want to store it in multiple
lines for that I'll required to have
this kind of three quotation marks
either of single type or double type
okay I can change this to double
also three double quotations even that
will be fine okay but before I run this
code cell before I go ahead and run this
code cell I'm going to print it see this
is how you getting multiple lines of
text right now if I run this code and
again I run this you will see there is
no change because essentially it's
happening the same thing but now what
happens if you trying to have this kind
of multiple lines of code with either
single uh quotation or double quotation
like this it's not going to work it's
only capable of taking this kind of
multiple text by using using three
quotation marks of either single or
double type so yeah that's the idea with
respect to Strings now you can store as
many kind of information with respect to
this kind of planet for example name of
the planet is Venus I want to give Venus
to it then let's say uh like you know if
I want to store the age of the planet
approximately Venus is about 4.6 billion
years old so Planet age is um
4.6 B million years right I can write
this kind of information over here can
also write uh let's say what is the
index of this planet planet index what
do you mean by this planet index that on
the first index we are having Mercury on
the second index we are having Venus on
the third index we are having earth
right so Venus comes on the second index
so you can store this value is equal to
two right
now let's say uh in Python if I talk
about indexes if I be very specific with
respect to indexes in Python we start
from index zero we don't start with
index one that's one thing you need to
keep in mind I'll also give a comment
over here indicating that in
Python index starts from zero hence
Venus is on index one after
Mercury on index zero if I wanted to
store the information with respect to
Mercury I would have written the planet
index equal to zero because it's the
first planet we are having in our solar
system right so that's the reason why uh
we'll be indexing that as zero now Venus
because it's the second planet we'll be
calling it as an index one now one more
interesting thing that you can do over
here is for if if I'm just going to run
this code and now if I print this
information that is uh name of the
planet and uh Planet
age and also the planet
index okay now if I going going ahead
and running this
code it's printing me all of this
respective information now if I want to
check the type of the data if it's a
string type if it's a integer type or if
it's a float type now what is the
meaning of float if you're having a
number in decimals okay if you're having
any kind of numbers in either fractions
or decimals then you simply call call it
as a float number so if I'm trying to
check the type in Python what I need to
do is along with printing them variable
I also want to check the type of the
variable so what I do is along with
printing this variable name I'm giving
one more command in Python called type
and now what is this type going to do
it's simply going to reveal what is the
data type that has been stored in the
respective variables that's the thing
that I'm trying to look
after and now if I simply run this code
you can see that the first two things
are of class string it means that this
planet age and the planet uh name both
of them are storing a data that is in
the format of strings when I talk about
planet index now that is not a string
that that is an integer okay now just
because I also discussed about the float
let's say I'm creating one more variable
let's say any random variable for that
matter Z and I'm giving some number to
it 3.2 now I explained that any kind of
decimal number or a number that you are
able to express in fraction you can call
them as a float type so if I go ahead
and print the type of variable Zed see
what happens you'll be seeing that it's
coming out as a
float so yeah this was a very quick
introduction with respect to what are
strings and not only strings we have
also discussed about
integers and
floats so these are some basic data
types that you must know in order to go
ahead in this particular program now in
the next particular video I'll be
explaining you with respect to what are
some kind of ways through which you can
play around with this string strings and
do some more beautiful stuff when it
comes to
Strings hey guys welcome to the sixth
video of module one and here I'm going
to discuss about one of my personal
favorite Concept in Python known as F
string so we're going to talk about what
are these F strings how to use them and
when should we use them and by the end
of this video I'll also be talking about
what is the concept of string
concatenation and how you can achieve it
with the help of F string as well
so let's get into
it let's try to do something really
unique with the strings okay it's going
to be some kind of a magic let's try to
go ahead and explore what I'm uh talking
about but before that I can also call
this as like you know basic data types
this is looking a very big I'll just
change this to basic data types okay I'm
going to change this to basic data types
okay and this data types are what
strings uh float and integers these are
the data types that we have discussed
about now uh I'm going to talk
about F strings okay I'm going to talk
about F
strings okay now what does this
mean for example let's say I want to
print some kind of a statement uh which
is saying that how many moons does a
Jupiter have Okay so let's say I'm
trying to print a statement now because
I want to print a statement I'm going to
give it within a quotation
that planet
Jupiter has or not Jupiter I should say
Saturn because I'm looking forward for
Saturn not Jupiter so planet Saturn has
um 146 moons the reason I have choosen
Saturn is because I just looked onto
Google that yeah currently as of June
2023 there are 146 moons that have been
confirmed for our planet Saturn right so
I'm writing this detail as of now now as
you might be knowing that as the
astronomers are having much and much
more information about this kind of
gaseous Giants that we are having in our
solar system they are keeping on
updating the values of the moons once
they are discovering new moons right so
now what happens in future if uh we want
to update this kind of values let's say
we found out that Saturn is now not
having 146 moons instead it's having 150
moons right so I'll have to manually
change this value to 150 to print this
kind of thing right so now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to create a
variable called as Saturn
moons okay and I'm also going to change
the name of the planet I'm also going to
store that what if I want to print the
information for a different planet right
so I'm also going to store this thing as
a
name of planet and I'll change this not
certain and moons let's say moons of
Planet something like this whatever
makes sense to you give a very good name
so that if anyone is reading it uh
everyone is able to make a sense of
what's going on so name planet Moon's
Planet so I can give the name of this
planet as Saturn as of now and I can
give that currently it's having 146
moons now what I want to do is I want to
print the variable as it is if I'm
changing this variable the print
statement should Auto automatically
change okay for example if I want to
replace this set with this variable what
I need to write is I need to write name
planet similarly over here I will change
this thing to Moon's
Planet but now if you notice if I run
this it's going to print the same thing
as it is it's going to print the same
thing as it is right it's going to print
the name underscore planet and moons
underscore Planet instead of the Saturn
146 what is the reason behind that it is
because we are not giving any sort of an
information to the string that hey you
need to take the information from this
uh variable and not print literally the
string that we are giving over here so
that's the purpose of f strings you are
giving F over here and then writing this
thing within this kind of curly
braces okay I'm giving all the variables
that might change into this curly braces
and now if I run this you can see that
planet Saturn has 146 moons now let's
say in future if this changes to
150 you can see that planet Saturn has
150 moons you don't have to go to let's
say I'm having multiple print statements
with this planets uh Saturn with uh
moons of planet Saturn basically when
multiple print statements I don't need
to manually go ahead and change this 150
150 150 okay I just need to make a
change to this variable and everywhere
else in the code it will automatically
be updated to 150 because we are having
the change in the variable that's
something you need to keep in mind
that's the power of f strings that's
completely a magic okay it is also used
like you know if you want to let's say
uh concatenate two strings if you want
to join two different strings even then
you can use this kind of f strings there
are multiple methods but let's stick to
a very specific method because this is a
universal method that always works so
let's stick to this particular method I
can also give a name over here uh
describing the code
I should say comment not name and I
should describe it like uh understanding
the
power of f
strings right over here also I could
have given this kind of commment
checking the type of
variables obviously for me I already
know what kind of this kind of things is
but for someone who is a beginner who is
going to look into this kind of
notebooks for them to understand what
are the things that we are doing over
here right anytime let's say in future
they're going to get referring to this
particular notebook they want to know
what they have done over here so for
that we are giving comments that this is
uh
displaying
the data values for H
variables so this kind of comments are
always recommended you can go ahead and
give this kind of variables uh some of
commments okay all right so now let's
talk about string
concatenation what is the spelling of
concatination let me check it's um
string concatination
right I am very bad with spellings but
yeah coming back to this thing now let's
see if I'm having two strings okay that
Earth is the only planet with life let's
I'm going to store it in a string one
variable and I'm going to have this kind
of either double quotation or a single
quotation and I'm going to store
Earth is the only
planet with live okay and after this I'm
giving another statement string
two or maybe not
maybe
not right something like
this so if I want to print and attach
the strings together I want to create a
statement out this now there are again
multiple ways that you can do a very
straightforward way would be to join
them with the help of plus operator I
can have print of my string one plus
string two and now if I run this it's
going to create a error because if you
can see I have written string to without
the underscore now if I give underscore
and run this now it's saying that Earth
is the only planet with life with full
stop but now there is no space in
between so so for that you can create
one more string in between string one
and string two that
is the space
string this was a string this is also a
string and this is also a string right
and now you can see that thanks to that
space we are having the space between
this first sentence and the second
sentence you could have also achieved
this by having a manual space over here
and then write string one plus string
two even that is fine but now let's say
if I want to do it with the help of f
strings how can I do it very
simple I'm calling my string one
variable and then string two variable
with a space in
between again it's going to run into an
error because of the
underscore so yes see that's how it's
going to work how we can do it with the
help of F string right you will look
into its power as we advance our program
uh in order to go ahead and do
astronomical visualization and Analysis
but for now this is how you can play
around with the F strings and now in the
next uh particular video we'll be
discussing about A New Concept Al
together that is how you can get an
input from the user in
Python hey everyone welcome to the sth
video of module one here you are going
to understand this concept of how you
can take user inputs in your code so
let's you are writing a code and there
is some kind of a problem
where you need to take some kind of
inputs from anyone who is running your
code and save that data in some kind of
variable so for that what is the command
in Python through which you can achieve
these kind of things and by default what
is the data type of the output by using
this kind of input command we are going
to learn about these things in this
video so let's get
started now I'll just create one more
code cell I mean sorry teex cell give a
heading as uh user
inputs okay so what we are trying to do
over here we are going to run a command
in Python that is going to allow users
to give some kind of input okay so
what's going to happen I'm going to use
a command called input and now that
input if I'm going to
run see it's creating this kind of a
text box where you can give any kind of
input that you want and store it in a
particular variable if you want okay
okay for now I'm not storing it anywhere
I just trying to get an input it's not
going to do anything so I'm going to
stop this run okay I just clicked on
this it's saying keyboard interrupt
because I manually stopped it by myself
okay now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to store it uh with some kind of a
variable over here okay for example
let's say I'm trying to ask name of the
user so I can give a this kind of a
variable name username
okay now if I'm going to write this kind
of input it's going to give an empty
text box now if I want to give some kind
of description so that users are able to
understand what kind of data to give
then you can have this kind of a string
information that enter your name like
this and now if I go ahead and run this
code see how beautiful it's asking for
the name now user can simply go ahead
and give for example my name is ran I'm
going to give R and press
enter and now if I look into I'll just
give a comment over
here use input to take user inputs and
just like this I could have also come
over here and check the type of
variables by
using type Command right this kind of
descriptive uh comments are always like
you know recommended now user uh name
has been given as Rohan if I want to
check how it looks like if I'm trying to
print this
it's simply going to take this username
equal to Rohan that's what we have done
that's all about it right and now what
if I check about the data type can you
go ahead and guess what kind of type is
this kind of username going to have
because it's a text data we expect this
to be a string it's as expected that we
got a string now what
happens if I'm going to code and ask
user to input their favorite
number okay I'm again going to give a
comment to this code first of all that
is
displaying the variable and its
type given by the
user now asking user to input their
favorite number so again let's say I'm
creating some kind of a variable to
store this information User fave number
something like
this and ask asking as an input I am
asking let uh give or
enter your
favorite
number okay I run
this so again it's asking user to give
their favorite number let's say they are
giving seven because my favorite number
is seven and I assume most of your lucky
number might be seven as well right I
don't know why seven is very lucky I'll
just hit enter and now again go ahead
and
display the variable and its
type given by the
user and now if I'm printing first of
all my user Fame number it should
display
seven and after this uh if I'm going to
print the type of this user fave
number look into uh the output
it's still a
string so what is happening over here
the way that we are calling this input
command that is inbuilt in Python it
automatically converts any kind of data
that is given by the user into a string
format it automatically converts any
kind of input given by the user in that
text box into the string format even if
it's a number we just looked into that
so let's say if you want this number to
be converted into some kind of a numeric
format either let's say integer or a
float what you do is you try to convert
this kind of data type into integer
format or a float format how we can do
this I'll explain that in the next
video hey guys welcome to the eth video
of module one and here we are going to
talk about that how you can take a
particular data type and convert it to
some other data type for example if I'm
having a float how can can I convert
that into string so all these kind of
data type conversions you are going to
understand in this particular video so
let's get into
it so now let's go ahead and understand
that how we can take this particular
data type that is in the format of
string the seven how you can convert
that into a numeric data type that is
either integer or float or maybe let's
say both of them so for that what I'm
going to do is I'm going to create a
heading which says that data type
conversion you're going to learn about
how you can convert any data type into
some other data type if it's possible to
convert or else you'll be getting an
error so the commands that you need to
know commands to
convert if you want to convert any kind
of thing into a string any kind of data
it could be a integer it could be a
float it could be any kind of data type
okay we have cover only three of them
but let's say it could be any kind of
data type if you want to convert that
into a string the command in Python is
is the string any kind of input that you
give to the string that input if it's
possible to convert that into a string
it's going to convert it into the string
just like that in order to convert any
kind of input into integers you are
having this command of in integers so
any kind of input that you pass to this
int within this kind of parenthesis it's
going to convert that input in the
format of integers if it's possible to
convert that input in that integer for
example let's say if I'm having 3.5 if I
try to convert that into an integer it's
not going to it's not going to convert
that 3.5 into an integer because 3.5 is
the format of float however there is
some interesting thing that's going to
happen if I'm going to run this kind of
code you will be understanding it in a
while now just like that if you want to
convert any kind of input into the float
format you call the float that is
available in Python itself and then you
give some kind of input that's how it
works okay
and now I'm going to give one more
comment after giving one empty line that
convert a string data into integer and
Float so uh we know that this seven is
currently existing in the type of string
I can again cross check it by simply
typing this uh type and user fave number
and this time I'm not writing any kind
of print in top of that because in
Google column what happens is if I'm
going to run this the last line doesn't
require print statement to print the
output okay but if I giving let's say
I'm just copying this thing and printing
it again over here it should have been
printing twice for me right if I run
this code but it's going to print only
once why because it's going to give me
the print of the last statement
automatically I don't need to give print
command if I want to print both of them
I need to give print print for both this
lines okay that's something thing that
we need to
know okay but anyways coming back to our
discussion that is we already know that
now this user F number is in the format
of string right so now I'm doing is
converting a string to integer how I'm
passing this int and then passing in
this user fave
number and uh simply running this code
by pressing control enter and I'm also
trying to print the type of this string
to int and see if that thing has
converted and at the same time I'm also
going to print the string to int
variable that we have created as you can
see now the output is again seven see
how the seven are looking just the same
it's the change in this data type now
from the string we have converted it
officially into an integer now this
string to integer variable is having the
value of integer
7 right we how did we do it by just
using this kind of inbuilt command in
Python of integer I gave an input to it
because we know that the seven can be
written in the format of integers we are
having this kind of an data now what if
I let's say for example give a string
like
this string like this and ask to convert
this string into an it's not a number
how will this be converted into an
integer it's not possible you're are
getting this kind of a value error that
hey I'm not able to convert this string
into an integer invalid literal for this
integer it's not possible to convert
this into an integer so make sure that
you are giving these inputs that are
able to be converted into an integer now
at the same time now what happens if I'm
giving 3.5 now this time you might
expect that it can give you an error
because now it's in the format of
decimals and even 3.5 in itself is not
an integer right so what's going to
happen over here it's not going to give
you an error instead it's going to round
it down to the nearest integer so if I'm
having 3.5 it's converting to three if
I'm having 3.9 it's still going to
convert it to three so yeah that's how
this kind of integer works so make sure
if you want to have 3.9 let's say if
this was in the format of
string and now if I run this this time
it's giving me an error because string
cannot directly be converted into an
integer that is having a float data with
within itself so I need to convert that
3.9 first of all into
float so so that this 3.9 that is
existing in a string is first of all
converted into a float and now that
float will be converted into an integer
and now it should work perfectly see how
that 3.9 string got converted into a
float that is 3.9 and now that 3.9 if
I'm giving as an integer of this 3.9
it's converting into three right so
that's how it's basically uh working the
in 3.9 the integer part is that's what
essentially we are getting right so yeah
coming back to like you know going uh
breaking this whole thing into a
stepbystep format uh this was user fa
number okay and let's say I'm also
having the string to integer or let's
say yeah string to
integer now in is already done right we
about to change it to float so now we
are having float of user fave number
remember this user fave number is
already defined over here we haven't
done any kind of changes to it so it's
still in the format of and string okay
it's just that this variable is now
given this value that is integer of that
string data okay so again if I'm uh
first of all
printing what is the type of user fave
number it won't change it will just be
the same because I haven't done any kind
of changes to
that variable right that variable is
still the same okay it's giving me some
kind of an error it's giving me a name
error that S type is not defined oh yeah
because I done a type over
here see now it's still you can see it's
uh the last this is the last print
statement it's saying that it's still a
string right now let's say I'm trying to
convert that string into a float how we
can do
it right I'm going to print this thing
string to
float and also print the type of it
see that's how it's working it's
converting that 7 into 7.0 and now that
decimal indication is saying that it's
uh basically float type again I've done
some kind of a type over here I should
have not written float I should have
written string to float right string to
float like this because float is a
function right it's not some kind of a
variable so yeah as you can see now it's
giving you the output of float the type
of the string to float variable that we
have created is is a flute now let's say
if I want
to
get user
input of two different
integers and add them
together how can I do it so what I'll do
is I'll take number one as an input I'll
ask them to input their number give any
integer
number okay and then after that I'm
going to give another variable that is
input give one more
integer all right and then if I'm going
to add these numbers together and print
it N1 plus N2 or else let's say we are
having a very feny way to give this kind
of a
statement by using FST string I'm going
to say that uh the sum
of N1 variable and N2 variable is the
summation of them that is N1 +
N2 now remember I am not converting this
into integers right because we know that
by default this input is going to expect
the numbers in the format of what
strings so let's if I'm running this as
of now and giving let's say seven and
another integer is let's say my another
favorite number is nine so so 7 + 9
should be what 13 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
okay my bad again my very basic
mathematics is also very wrong but
anyway 9 + 7 whatever is the value okay
9 plus 7 you can do it in KY it it won't
be 79 right so now what's going to
happen the reason we are getting this 79
is because that this N1 and N2 is a
string and we are concatenating them
this kind of string with the help of
this plus variable I mean plus operator
and that's the reason why the seven and
N are getting concatenated we are
joining the strings together with the
help of that plus like how we did over
here while uh before this F statement I
F string I had given you a way through
which you can do it by simply converting
this into this plus and there is also no
uh quotation marks and if I print this
it was giving this right how they were
joined this two kind of strings and then
we had given this kind of space and
everything so yeah that's exactly the
same thing that I'm showing you over
here okay this is string to just
converting it back to what it
was and yeah that's uh typically uh what
we are going to do over here that
because it's in the format of string
it's concatenating them now if I want to
convert this into an integer I need to
pass this int on top of this why because
I'm converting the string into an
integer and I know user is going to give
me an input of an integer it's going to
convert it automatically into the format
of integers and let's say my mathematics
is really very big I'm giving the value
of seven and 9 and this value of 16 is
now accurate right so yeah that's how
it's going to work how you can take
inputs from the user if it's a numeric
data and if you are sure it's going to
be an integer no other data you directly
give this input of int on top of this
input that you're getting from the user
it will automatically convert it into
the integers and then you can do any
kind of sorts of things you want so yeah
that was about how you can uh do the
data type conversions convert one kind
of data into some different
type hey guys welcome back once again to
the first module and here is the ninth
video of it where I'm going to teach you
the concept of control flow in Python
now this is the heart of programming if
you don't know this concept you are not
a good programmer at all not that other
concepts are not important they are
equally important but as I mentioned
this is the heart of this programming
language so we're going to start with
the looping part specifically we're
going to look into the for Loop and
while loop once you understand what are
this kind of looping why do we use them
how to use them we are going to move on
towards the condition statements where
we're going to understand about if
statements if else statements and also
if L if L statements and again there are
a lot more things that we need to cover
in this video so let's get
started now let's go ahead and talk
about what is control flow in Python
okay let me Define this as control
flow and the whole idea that you're
going to learn over here is I'm just
going to cross check if that's the seven
yeah that's the seven okay the whole
idea we going to learn over here is with
respect
to for
Loop and
while and then you're going to learn
about some condition statement
okay and the main idea over here is that
if you are having some kind of a code
which is repeating okay and you don't
want to manually type all these kind of
things for example if I'm writing print
zero and then after that print Z I'm
also writing print
one and then print two then print
three right I'm knowing that this kind
of integers are giving like being
printed starting from zero then 1 2 3
like this let's if I want to do this for
100 times for some reason okay this is
just for an example as we'll be going in
the upcoming modules in this program you
will see the power of all of these
things okay right now I'm just trying to
teach you that these kind of things
exist okay so if I want to do this kind
of things if I want to automate this
kind of things how can I do it because I
know that there is some kind of certain
kind of things which are keep on
repeating itself in a specific way I can
transform this whole idea into for loops
or maybe while Loops I'll be first
talking about for Loop okay so what
happens is if I'm trying to initiate my
for loop I need to give the keyword
called for then for what so for some
kind of
index that is present in some Itor now
what is the meaning of it rator Itor is
nothing but some kind of a storage where
you are having multiple values that one
can take okay that index can take okay
so let's say if I'm having list of
numbers so in Python you can create a
list with the help of the square
brackets okay again this is not
important thing to discuss as of now but
let's say that you know about this kind
of list and I'm storing let's say 0 1 2
3 4 this kind of values in the list now
what's going to happen automatically
this index is going to be like acting
like a temporary variable you can call
that as a temporary variable that's
going to take one by one values that is
present inside this iterator list is an
iterator where you are storing multiple
different values and uh this index is
going to take this values one by one
starting from zero in the first loop
after the first Loop is over it's
starting the second loop it's going to
take the value of one this index will
keep on changing its value starting from
zero then the next value that is one
then next two 3 four like that until
this kind of last value is been uh taken
by this Index this kind of for Loop will
keep on running okay so what I'm going
to do is I'm simply going to print
index
as you can see the first time this code
ran the index was taking the value of
zero that's why it print the value of
zero similarly now the first Loop is
over it's entering the second Loop it
took the value of index uh as one that's
why is printing me the output of one so
that's how you can uh it rate through
this kind of it readers and list is just
one of the example let's if you want to
create a list of 100 numbers and then
you want want to iterate you cannot
manually go ahead and create this kind
of a list of 0 to 100 or 0 to 99 for
that matter right so the way through
which you can do this is something by
using
range okay now what is range the way it
works is it takes the start value it
takes the ending
value and then it takes the skip
value if I show you let's if I'm giving
first of all range of just any number
10 so it's going to give me integers
that are present in between 0 to 10
that's the purpose of range in order to
prove you that what I'm going to do is
I'm going to convert this into range of
10 and then run this so it's going to
give me the values 10 values in between
0 to 10 so starting from zero it goes
all the way up to 9 as you can see after
9 there is no output because this are
first 10 numbers starting from zero and
yeah we are ending at nine one value
that is less than this okay now let's if
I don't want to start from the index
zero I want my first integer that is
present in the range to be let's say
minus5 so I can start with minus5
because I know that I can give that kind
of a syntax start and then end if I'm
just giving one number it's just taking
the value of end at where you want to
end a value before that actually and now
if I run
this you can see that now it's starting
from minus 5 not zero it's going till 10
by default the value is set to zero for
the start if you not giving any specific
input to it now it's going to take the
value of minus5 okay so if I change this
10 to minus5 and then if I run
this okay I did a mistake I should have
written - 5 comma 10 and now if I run
this say starting from - 5 -4 -3 it's
going to go all the way up to nine until
that 10 until that 10 is achieved you
keep on going to it rate okay so it's
not like you are going to get only 10
values no anything in between minus 5 to
10 you're going to get that as an output
minus 5 is inclusive 10 is exclusive
okay just keep that in mind but
typically let's say uh we want some kind
of numbers to start with one and then go
all the way up to 10 in that case I need
to go from 1 to
11 so I hope this kind of things are
making now a good sense of how to play
around with this range to get your
things done right it's now going to
start from 1 to 10 now 11 is exclusive
remember that that's why it's getting
printed to 10 right that's the whole
idea one more thing that I can write
over here is start is ex
inclusive and end is
exclusive it simply means that the value
of end is the actual value one before
that end that we are defining that's
what range is going to take all right
and now what is the meaning of the skip
let's if I want to skip right now it's
currently by default skipping one one
numbers right after one it skipped one
value it went to two 1+ 1 is two right
then 2 + 1 is 3 if I want to have this
plus two instead of plus one I can let's
say have this comma two so now after
printing one it's going to add two
numbers to it it's going to go to three
directly without getting this two as an
output so it will be like 1 3 5 7 and N
okay why stopped at 9 because 9 + 2 is
11 the moment I reach 11 it's not going
to give that as an output right that's
not not how it works so yeah that's how
it's going to be after 9 because the
next index value is 11 it's not going to
run for that index so yeah that's about
how you can uh use for Loop to do some
kind of specific thing right now I given
a very simple logic that if you want to
print some numbers between let's say 1
to 10 and if you want to skip uh two two
values starting from one then skip two
values you get to three skip two values
from three you get to five that's how
you do it so that's the concept of for
Loop now if I want to do the same thing
with the help of while
loop how can I do
it I can do this by giving while keyword
and then a condition I need to provide
some kind of a condition and this kind
of column is again very important I did
not explain you over here but this
column is very important this column is
going to indicate that whatever you're
going to write within this kind of space
okay this space is also important which
we call as an indentation so if I'm
going to delete that space and run this
it's going to give me this indentation
error why it's giving me this
indentation error because the space is
missing the for Loop expect this kind of
space so that any kind of code that is
written within that space that's going
to be the part of the loop if I'm going
to print some value over here let's say
five and run this see it's at the end
also printing the value of five but now
that Pi is not printed for this many
times if I have this kind of space in
between so after every number five will
be printed after every number five will
be printed see after one five is printed
after three five is printed so that's
the power of this kind of indentation if
you're going to give this indentation
over here it's going to assume that
print five is to be supposed to be there
within the for Loop if you don't want to
have that indentation then now it's fine
it's not going to give an error because
it's having at least one line to run
within the for Loop and if I skip that
thing now it's going to give an error
because it needs at least something to
run right but now let's if you don't
want to get an error like that you can
simply use pass keyword okay now this
pass keyword what it does you can try to
think and uh like you know you can think
about the whole logic of the loop uh for
that time you can use this pass keyword
and if you try to run this if you're
thinking about some kind of logic this
pass keyword is a very good way to like
you know just don't write anything with
the for Loop right now just write
initiate the for Loop go and do the
second part of the code and then come
back later on over here so for that you
can use pass okay but anyways coming
back to where we were okay I'm going to
remove this thing and also remove the
whole line and come onto the while loop
okay so in while loop it expects some
kind of a condition that you need to run
this Loop until this happens until this
condition occurs okay and then over here
also automatically if I keep enter if I
press enter after the column it gives me
this kind of indentation
automatically and now over here I can
give any kind of way through which I can
Loop into this Loop any kind of thing I
want to do until a certain kind of
condition is met it's simply going to
run okay for example let's say I am
asking a user I want to create this kind
of loop where it's asking user to enter
their favorite celestial object
okay and every time they are giving the
inputs I'm going to also keep a track of
an like you know this index I I'll also
be updating the index after every
iteration so that I'm having like you
know favorite celestial object one is
this then favorite celestial object two
is that so that's kind of stuff that I
want to create and uh after that the
condition to break this for Loop is
again something that I'll be giving and
that's how this while loop will be over
for the for Loop what's happening in the
for Loop we are automatically ending it
once the iterators are over like once
you're not having anything to itate for
it will be over right so once you are
hitting that value of 11 you are not
going to have anything else to itate so
that's about the for Loop but in the
while loop it's going to run forever if
the condition is not made so it's
compulsory for us to write a condition
in a way if you want to stop your Loop
that condition should be satisfying a
certain
kind of thing through which you can stop
the loop you can break the loop okay so
what I can do is I can come up with this
kind of a logic that always run this
thing okay I'm not giving any kind of
specific logic over here I'm just saying
that go ahead run this Loop Forever at
the same time I'm also having some kind
of counter okay I'm having some kind of
index that I'm going to track that how
many times this kind of iterations are
happening and now I'm also asking user
to give some kind of input okay let's
say enter their favorite Celestial body
so let's say I'm going to store this in
the variable called object that is obj
asking for the input enter your
favorite
celestial object and then I want to ask
them that this is the first thing that
they are inputting right CT + 1 because
CT by default is zero so I'm just going
to write ct+ one over here and then have
this F string and this is also typo so
I'll convert that into input and now
what's going to happen in the for Loop
okay if I run this as of now see what's
happening it's asking that enter your
favorite celestial object one I'm going
to say
earth now again it's saying enter your
favorite celestial object one why
because we are not updating the value of
the CT and it will keep on asking me
because I'm not giving any kind of
condition to stop this while loop right
so for now I'm manually stopping this
over here so let's talk about how we can
update this counters I can once I'm done
asking this kind of input from the user
I'm going to update the value of CT and
say that CT is equal to the previous
value + one you could have also written
this uh as like you know City Plus equal
to 1 it's essentially doing the same
thing it's taking the previous value of
city and adding one to that okay so 0 +
1 is 1 okay and now uh 1 + 1 will be 2
right so that's how this is going to
become 1 + 1 2 right so it will ask
enter your favorite celestial object
when the CT value will be one this 1 +
one will be two or by default you could
have started this with one and like you
know you could have remove this one over
here because it will start with one and
then automatically it will be two in the
next iteration whatever it's up to you
right how you code your specific logic
so yeah that's what I have done and I'm
also going to give the condition that if
if user is going to input something that
is asking to stop that yeah that's it I
don't have any kind of favorite
celestial bodies apart from what I have
given as an input so if the object input
that has been given by the user is equal
to let's say something called
quit okay then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to break the for Lo there are
multiple new things that you learning
over here that is
this if statement along with the break
statement so what's
happening so until the user is going to
write quit it's going to run this F Loop
and the moment they are going to type
quit it's going to break the for Loop so
this is called as condition statement
that is if condition if this condition
happens then you're going to terminate
the for Loop by using this kind of break
keyword and then let's say if this is
not the quit you can continue the code
so you don't need to do anything if this
is the condition that is met then break
the loop okay and I can also give this
kind of a print statement over here that
type uh
quit type
quit to
exit right this kind of uh hint is
something that I'm trying to write over
here so that user knows how you can
escape this kind of loop when to St okay
right so now let's see what kind of
things uh happen if I'm running this
code so see how it's coming type quit to
exit so now let's say that favorite
Celestial body is for example Earth then
let's say black hole this kind of inputs
now I'm tired I want to give quit but
now I give it like this it's not
quitting why because I give this Q as
capital right I give this Q as capital I
need to write small q ID the lowercase Q
it only then it will stop so now to
tackle this kind of conditions what you
can do is you can take the user input
and convert it into this kind of lower
case the way you can do it by passing
this lower function that exist in Python
for string so if I want to demonstrate
that I'm going to write a
commment convert any string into lower
case how you can do it let's say I'm
having a string demo is equal to
uppercase or any kind of combination of
letters is upper case just like this
okay now if I print this string
demo it's going to be as it is upper
case now if I want to convert that into
a lower case what I'm going to do is my
string demo. lower is what I'm going to
print
now this lower is converting this any
kind of upper cases anything to a
smaller case if it's existing it will
convert into a lower case if it's
already a lower case it's not going to
do any kind of changes to that so now by
applying this even if it's writing
capital Q UI even still that is fine
okay so if I run
this and uh now if I am writing
Earth black
hole right and then UI let's say capital
T also for that matter see it's still
quitting why because the power of this
lower functionality that is implemented
to the string there are again bunch of
different methods that you can apply to
a string but because we don't have to
learn everything in Python only some
specific things that you will require in
order to do some kind of astronomical
visualizations and Analysis then this
much amount of information is quite okay
for now okay as we'll be going ahead you
will be learning a lot of different
stuff in Python over here I'm just
giving you a warmup so that you are
understanding a lot of things in Python
and you're not just getting confused of
some basic stuffs right so yeah that's
about like you know we have talked about
how you can have this kind of for Loop
you can have while loop then also talk
about some kind of conditions like this
let's say if uh if this is the condition
then do this
else if
object lower equal to some different
thing let's say um Capital quit then do
what then let's say
print
type smaller
quit smaller or lower C quit or else
it's not going to make any sense as of
now so what I'm going to do is I'm
simply going to delete this okay I'm
just going to keep it as of now over
here I'm not going to complicate the
things if there will be something where
you will be requiring to understand the
elsf condition also over that specific
time I'll be understanding you like I'll
be explaining you okay for now all of
these things are again quite a lot of
thing to understand in just video so
yeah I'm going to end this video over
here and in the next video what we are
going to learn about is functions and
I'll try to incorporate this kind of f
else block over there uh with lsf
condition also right so stay tuned for
that hey guys welcome to the final video
of module one and here I'm going to
teach you the concept of function in
programming so to start with we'll be
talking about what is the need of the
functions in programming and I'm sure by
the end of this program you will be
appreciating that you have learned this
particular concept
so we'll also learn about how you can
create your own function in Python then
in order to use it how you can call
these functions and then at the end of
this video you will also be creating a
function that's going to work like a
very simple basic calculated to perform
some kind of addition multiplication
subtraction and all that kind of stuff
so let's get started with this
video now let's understand the concept
of function in Python I'm going to
create a Texel give
heading now the whole concept of the
functions in Python is very similar to
again what we do in
mathematics if you are giving some sort
of inputs to a function now that
function can take any kind of formula
right now if you're giving some kind of
inputs to that formula let's say you're
having f ofx is equal to 3x² +
2x + two something plus three something
like this so now if you're going to give
the value of x as two or automatically
this x will be taking the value of two
and whatever is the output of 3 into 2 s
+ 2 into 2 + 3 that will be the output
of this function now the very similar
idea is what we are following in Python
also we create this kind of functions to
repeat some kind of block in Python okay
just like what we did for the for Loop
or Y Loop but over there you are
continuously iterating one by one but
now what if you want to use same block
of code in this code cell but then after
let's say two three Cod cell again you
want to use that again after one two
code cells you want to use that so for
that you create functions right now how
do we create this functions in Python
you use this kind of keyword called def
for defining the function then you give
name to the function now let's say that
I'm trying to create a function to GRE
everyone of you over here who are
watching this video So Def greet I'm
giving this random name that came to my
mind and then you need to give some kind
of input arguments to this function
right now I'm not giving any kind of
arguments and now again this kind of
column is given so that python
understands that yeah now anything that
is given below this kind of colum with
this indentation it's all going to be
the part of the
function let's say that I'm trying to
print the value or not the value but the
string called he estro
files I'm assuming most of you over here
who are watching this video are asro
file so what I'm doing is I'm going to
create this kind of function that's
going to do this particular thing okay
hey asro files I'm just trying to create
every one of you now how to call this
function once you have created a
function how you going to call them
you're creating a function to
gr
viewers of this video right and without
any input argument
uments or parameters you can call them
as input arguments input parameters
there are wonderful names given to the
same thing over here okay now I'm going
to call that function how to call that
function you call the name of the
function like GRE okay have this
parenthesis and just run this
code you're going to get an output of
hey estoiles I don't need to write this
kind of same thing again and again now
anytime I want to call this function
it's going to print a asiles for isn't
it just interesting now I'm just going
to go ahead and add one more magic to
this function that I'm going to
specifically greet some of you over here
okay let's say that uh one of your name
just for example is let's say let's just
not give any kind of random name let's
just take my name okay and let's say
some of your name is also Rohan so yeah
if Rohan if you're watching this
particular video then I'm going to greet
you specifically okay but yeah coming
back to the concept what I'm trying to
do over here here
is uh
Define a function to
GRE a person whose name will be
given whose name will be given as an
input so now what I'm going to do over
here is I'm going to first of all create
a very similar kind of function but this
time I'm going to have this kind of a
name okay
so let's say defining a function give a
name let's say
gr person something like this and now it
takes one input argument that is name
okay now this time what I'm going to
print out is this a whatever is the name
again because I'm using the F strings I
need to use f over here hey whatever is
the
name I hope you are enjoying this
session and learning
a lot of things in
Python something like this right and now
if I'm going to uh run this code to
create this function now again call that
function okay now how it's going to work
see that I'm going to call this great
person and give a name of let's say
Rohan okay so yeah hey Rohan I hope you
are enjoying this session and learning a
lot of things in Python yes I am okay
thank you but yeah anyway moving moving
on to the next part so yeah this is what
I'm trying to show you that now I can
just call this function with different
different names okay call this function
with different
name okay now I'm going to again call
this
function
person and let's say that I don't know
this name came up into my mind out out
of nowhere let's use
Curren okay I'm lying he is my best
friend so yeah anyway so hey current I
hope you it's going to print the same
thing just that wherever now there is a
name variable it's going to replace it
like this you are trying to create some
bunch of different formulas for function
not actually the formulas but specific
code that will be repeated with some
kind of different inputs that you give
to a function so yeah this is how this
kind of functions work in Python but now
that's not all do this kind of things
okay now I'm feeling a bit sad that I'm
not wishing all of you over here so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to call
this function for one more time call
this function to gr everyone
to gr every one here watching the
video I can simply call this great
person but instead of just greeting one
of you guys I'm going to greet everyone
of you so what I'm going to do is let's
just call this as everyone okay and now
I'm going to run
this it says hey everyone I hope you are
enjoying this session and learning a lot
of things in by now this is good right
so yeah that's about this thing but yeah
now moving on to some more advanced
concepts of python that you must know
because these are very essential you
will be using a lot of inbuilt
functionalities in Python and different
libraries in python in the upcoming
modules you need to know these things
that I'm going to teach you right now so
please pay attention mention very
properly over here okay now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to talk about
two things that are keyword arguments uh
and the default arguments and also the
position of the arguments okay now this
concept is really very
important a default or I should say
first of all I'm going to talk about
position
arguments and I'm going to talk about
keyword
arguments and also
about let's just talk about uh these
things right now so that I'm not
confusing you guys with a lot of stuff
so what happens over here is that if you
are giving two inputs okay you're not
giving only one input you're giving two
inputs to the function for example one
that is the name and then you can give
some kind of a greeting message okay now
you cannot just have I hope you are
enjoying the session you can have some
kind of different message also if you
want okay so I'm going to give this kind
of uh functionality to my users who is
going to use the function that I'm
creating in Python so that they can give
any kind of message they want okay this
is just some examples that comes into my
mind right now so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to again create a function
I'm first of all going to talk about
position arguments okay I'm also
deleting the keyword arguments so if I'm
greting and I'm passing let's say I'm
creating a function called greting
passing name and message and then I'm
saying that
print
name okay I'm giving this FST
string print name and then
message something like this is what I
want okay I want to print my name first
and then I want to print some message or
else I could literally play around with
these things
properly I can say hey
name and then some kind of a message
something like this right it up it's up
to you how you create your function so
let's say I'm creating it like this and
this time if I'm trying to
call this
function by placing the input
arguments in the same
order while building
it so I'm going to call my function that
is greting I'm going to give a name
again let's say I'm going to just play
around with the names I'm going to play
with let's say
l and then I'm writing a message
um are
you an
asile something like this right and now
if I run this it's giving hey Lea are
you an asile this kind of question has
been asked right and if you can see this
exclamation is also getting printed so
if I don't want that if I'm just again
calling this okay so yeah this time see
what's happening I'm not getting that
kind of exclamation mark now this time
what I have done I place this l in place
of name in place of message I put this
now what happens if I'm going to shift
call the
function by Shifting the
positions of the
arguments of the function right so I'm
going to call the same function again
but now change this kind of message with
name right and
then
like this and now if I enter this hey
are you an estoile comma lus it does not
make any kind of sense right so that's
the thing that I'm talking about the
position of the arguments whenever you
are defining a function you always look
into what kind of uh way what what is
the position of each and every arguments
if name argument is kept first you
always go ahead and give your this kind
of name is equal to uh something okay
there is L yeah you don't give this kind
of message over here whatever is the
first input argument that respective
input should what go over here okay
because now it's thinking python is
thinking that hey this is the first
argument so this should go in the place
of name so that's something that you are
learning over here with respect to the
position arguments but now what happens
if I'm again having the same kind of uh
thing but I'm specifically saying that
this is my
name argument and this is my message
argument okay now call this
function with keyword
arguments so what I am doing over here
is I'm giving some kind of argument
keyword before passing just the
arguments I'm also having its respective
keyword that I have used to define that
argument so this is called keyword
arguments okay that now even though the
position I have changed but now because
I'm giving a specific keyword now python
understands that this should go for the
message argument and this should go for
the name argument and therefore you are
getting this as an output I hope these
things are making sense to you okay now
one more thing that you can study in
functions that is very common is default
arguments that is while creating this
kind of a function okay while creating
this kind of a
function let's say
greting with
default argument something like this is
what I'm defining the name of the
function and now what I'm saying is if
someone is not giving any kind of name
or if they are not giving any kind of
message by default what kind of message
they should uh be seeing uh welcome to
this program on astronomy visualization
something like this right visualiz
a something like this is what I want to
uh give them a message and I want to
print hey name and then the message Okay
now what's going to happen always
remember your keyword arguments that you
will be giving will always come later on
first the position arguments will come
if you're having mixture of like you
know keyword arguments with the position
arguments always remember whenever you
will be calling a function you first
need to pass in the position arguments
because the order matters over there and
at the end you can change this kind of
uh keyword arguments order that's fine
at the end of the function what I'm
trying to say over here is that first of
all I'm going to call this
function call this function uh without
passing message argument and see what
happens so greeting
with default arguments and now I'm
giving the name of let's say ran I'm
coming back to because I'm not in the
mood to think about new name you can say
that and now if I'm running this see
it's it's giving me an error the reason
it's giving me an error is because I
haven't run this code right it's giving
me that this this thing is not defined
only so how can you how are you running
this and now if I'm running this you can
say that hey Rohan welcome to this
program on astronomic visualization
right it by default took this argument
whatever was written over here and it
gave me over here now what would happen
if I'm giving my message variable first
uh and then giving my name okay I'm
saying message equal to uh WhatsApp
something like that
okay and then now see what's going to
happen in the first position that should
be name okay but in place of that name
you are already giving this message
variable I mean message keyword now this
keyword is already taking this kind of
value now in the second position there
should be a message now that is already
exist over here that's why you're
getting this kind of red line and
obviously you're going to run into an
error position for arguments follows
keyword argument so always write your
position arguments first and then the
keyword arguments okay so over here I
could have written this as like you
know our name that is
Rohan and then the message this is fine
just write XL right even while defining
the functions if you are having this
message first and then the name like
this
see what happens it's going to throw an
error non-default argument follows the
default argument just like in the
keyword and the position if you are not
having any kind of default values you
always keep them first okay that's
something that you must know while
creating your own functions okay now all
of these things that you have learned
over here is going to be pretty much
very useful whenever you'll be
implementing these ideas in the uh
upcoming modules that you will be
learning okay but now one last thing
that I want to describe over here is I'm
going to create a function create a
function that will
either add
subtract
multiply or
divide two input
numbers okay so I'm going to come up
with a very basic calculator with the
help of functions okay and I'm going to
show you that how you can do all these
kind of things create a function that
will either add it's not wether it's
either add subtract multiply or divide
on any two numbers that has been given
as an input okay so let's say I'm
creating a function called basic
calculator okay and now I'm giving some
kind of inputs of two numbers that is
number one number two and then what kind
of operation I want to have for example
let's just call that as an operation add
multiply subtract or divide something
like that okay I'm trying to demonstrate
that if else if and else kind of
statements okay so now let's say uh if
if operation dot again I'm using this
kind of lower functionality so that if
if anyone is also giving capital A D
even that's going to find in order to
compare so if the user input is ADD I
want to return something now this is
again a new thing we are learning in
functions it's not always about printing
right if you want to give something as
an output just like in the mathem iCal
function if you're giving some input
it's going to give you some kind of
specific output it's going to return
some outputs so you can get something
out of this calculator or the function
that you are creating by calling a
keyword called written anything that you
write after written will be the output
of the function when you call this whole
function with some input arguments okay
you will understand this in a while so
let's say I want to written what do I
want to written I want to written N1 +
N2 whatever is the output of this N1
plus N2 is what I want to written now if
I run this code and test this basic
Keli giving my first number as two
second number as three and then
operation is ADD and then run this see
the output is five how did I get this
output five because I'm returning this
value I can store this value in a
variable now I can store this in say uh
addition something like this and then
also print this and I can use this kind
of addition somewhere else in the code
right
addition
so that's the first thing that we have
done now the second thing that we are
going to do is we going to say that if
else if
operation. lower is to
subtract okay then return what return
nerse minus N2 just like that else if
operation.
lower is to multiply multiply then what
you do return N1 s symbol is used for
multiplication and then else if
operation.
lower is to
divide then you're going to return what
N1 divide by N2 right else if anything
else is given as an input apart from add
subtract multiply or divide you're going
to say that
print I'm going to create my f state
with F
string you can
either in your operation Operation
input can either
take either
take add multiply
subtract or
divide you
give what whatever was the like you know
the operation that has been given by the
user you give this try again this kind
of message is what I'm trying to print
okay and now if I run this code see how
it's working if this is the condition
then do this else if if this is
condition then do this else if this is
the condition do that else if this is
the condition do this and if it's
nothing like that then do this that's
the proper if else if and else block
that we have created over here okay so
now if I run this it's giving me five as
an output right now let's say if I want
to do some kind of multiplication and
I'm storing it in the multi multi
multiply something like that right now
I'm going to create this kind of basic
Kelsey
function and give this kind of uh thing
that uh first number is three the second
number is three and then
multiply okay and uh print the value of
multiply also print
multiply 3 * 3 is 9 we expect the output
of N9 right you can go Ahad and test for
all these things okay what happens if
I'm trying some random input and I'm not
going to store it I'm just going to try
to see what's the output that we are
able to fetch 3 comma 3 and some
random okay and then if I run this it's
going to give operation uh input can
either take add multiply subtract or
divide you give this try again right so
this is this is the thing that is giving
output I can shift this to capital O and
I can also give some kind of uh like you
know uh information over
here with the help of
multiple strings over here I can say
that parameters I can first of all give
the kind of like you know an idea of
what this kind of function is doing this
is a really very good way of documenting
your functions okay I'm describing what
this kind of code is doing okay this
function is doing
um create creates a
basic
calculator that takes first that takes
N1 and N2 in the same
order and
performs either
of
addition
subtraction
multiplication mul
multiply and divide they can perform
either of this right and then you can
give
parameters and then you can have this
kind of
parameters that uh N1 first
number then N2 is your second number
like this you can just give all the kind
of proper information and then operation
Operation is any of the
operations mentioned above for our basic
calculator that is add subtract multiply
or divide and then it's going to also
return
what it's going to
written uh what is it going to return
it's going to WR let's check what is it
written yeah either the output of the
curency the output of the operation
done N1 and N2 so you can also give an
example over here if you want but yeah
that's pretty much about how you can
describe a function so that if someone
else is going to use your function they
already know how to like you know give
some kind of inputs while uh calling
your own function that you have created
right so yeah that's about the functions
that you should know and uh over here
these are some kind of pretty much
things that you should know if you know
about all of these things you are now
having enough idea just to advance
yourself into Python and learn a lot of
uh beautiful things in terms of how you
can create different visualizations in
astronomy by using some new things
itself but at the same time now you're
aware about a lot of things in Python
that's for sure not going to make you
think like a lot of overwhelming stuff
going on okay so yeah make sure that you
are going through all the kind of quiz
questions that we have given just to
ensure that you are now having a proper
idea about all of these Concepts that we
have taught uh before you advance to
module
two hi everyone welcome to the second
module I hope that by now from the
module one your concepts of basics of
python are clear because all of those
Concepts will be now implemented in
module 2 that will be helping us to
convert a tabular data of real stars out
there in universe and create some
amazing visualizations out of it and do
some observations get some observations
out of it do some kind of analysis and
then whatever kind of visualizations we
will be creating we'll also be saving it
into our system so all of these kind of
things we'll be doing in this particular
module and specifically what type of
graphs we are going to generate from
this tular data of stars we are going to
generate the bar graphs we're going to
generate the box plot we're going to
create the line plot also the pair plot
and finally at the end of this
particular module you will also be
creating an HR diagram now this HR
diagram if you're not aware about it
it's completely fine because by the end
of this video you will be knowing this
everything and you will also be coding
for the same thing okay it's one of the
most amazing things that you will be
seeing whenever you are dealing with the
star data okay so let's get started with
this particular module hey everyone
welcome to the second video of module 2
and here I'm going to give you a quick
sneak peek on the data set that you will
be using throughout this particular
module so this is basically about some
real stars out that in universe and yep
without spoiling any of your excitement
let's get into the
video let's go ahead and try to
understand what kind of astronomical
data that we are using in order to
create some of our first visualizations
in this program with respect to that
astronomical data and then not only that
how you can take this kind of
visualizations that you are going to
create in Google collab and save it into
your system so that later on whenever
you are doing your research work in
order to give support to whatever kind
of work that you are writing in your
research to support that work you can
always add this kind of visualizations
right so how you can extract this kind
of visualizations from Google collab
into your system and then obviously you
can uh attach this kind of
visualizations into your research paper
or maybe report or whatever kind of
research work that you might be doing so
all of these things will be covered in
this particular module and uh
specifically the data that we're going
to deal with is stored in in the format
of the CSV file in this particular
Google Drive Link so we're going to ly
export this data from the Google drive
into this Google collab and then we are
going to explore this kind of data set
step by step and then create this
visualizations that's the whole idea the
main goal is to create some kind of
different visualizations from the data
set and the data set is all about
different stars that are existing out
there in space and then all of the stars
are given with its respective properties
of absolute magnitude then surface uh
temperature spectral type and also the
luminosity
and at the end we are also going to
create this kind of a hers sprung russle
diagram or in short you can also call it
as a CHR diagram which helps astronomer
classify any kind of a star based on its
properties of this absolute magnitude
spectral type surface temperature and
the Luminosity so that's the whole kind
of idea that we are going to deal with
throughout this particular module and
I'll see you next in the upcoming video
where we are going to deal with
exploring of this data
set hello hello everyone welcome to the
third video of module
and here we are going to go ahead and
import the libraries so what kind of
libraries are we going to import or what
kind of libraries are we going to use
throughout this module two you're going
to understand each one of them as in why
are we importing them and then yes as
you can see on the screen find out what
are this kind of libraries and why are
we going to use them so let's get into
it now in order to explore this kind of
data set that we are having in the
format of Cs that is stored in the
Google Drive and also create
visualizations on top of that what we'll
be doing doing is we won't be coding
everything from scratch we going to use
some of the existing libraries that's
going to help us so that we can save our
time and at the same time use this kind
of libraries to create some kind of
beautiful visualizations after exploring
them so for that I'll have to import
these libraries which will help us
throughout in this particular module so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
ahead and import the libraries that are
going to first of all help us explore
the data set in a proper way so I can do
this with two of the libraries that is
Port OS okay how exit it will be helping
you will get to know in the upcoming
videos but yeah OS is one of the library
that is going to help us to let's say
for example create a directory where we
are going to save all of our
visualizations and also it's going to be
useful for some other purposes that will
be same apart from that if you want to
open the CSV file and explore it step by
step the main popular library that we
are going to use is pendas so I'm going
to import pendas as PD the reason I'm
calling it as p PD over here so that
because I don't want to write pandas
again and again okay I just want to use
PD in short so that I don't have to
write pandas again and again
continuously right it's up to you you
can just simply import pendas and use
all the functionality of pendas Library
by calling it completely by calling it
as pendas not PD it's your choice okay I
can have also import pendas as let's say
for example my name is Rohan so I can
have also import this thing as import
pendas as ran but now it does not make
sense right it's almost pretty much same
letters that are having so a short form
that we use in the python Community for
pandas is PD just like that you will
also maybe needing some kind of a way
through which you can create an array
from this kind of a CSV file okay so
from the CSV file you want to generate
some sort of array for that he will
require a library called as numpy so I'm
going to import numpy Library as
NP so now I have imported all of these
libraries that are going to help us
explore the data set now in order to
visualize this kind of data you will
require visualization libraries so for
that what kind of things I'll importing
I'll be importing the first thing that
is c bond again because the there are a
lot of characters in this particular
word I'm going to import it as SNS again
a short form that we use in Python
Community for cbon and then we are also
having one more one of the most popular
libraries for visualization that is met
plot Li so I'm going to import met plot
lib and specifically P plot
uh and I'm going to import it as PL
again a short form to call all of these
things together right so these are the
libraries that we are going to use
majorly to create some kind of different
visualizations after exploring it with
the help of os pendas and numai so
that's the whole idea and now from the
next video we are going to go ahead call
the data from that link and finally
start exploring
it hey everyone welcome to the fourth
video of of module 2 and now that you
are already having a quick idea of what
is the data set all about let us try to
explore this data set with the help of
python we going to convert the CSV data
into Panda's data frame with the help of
pendas library and then summarize this
whole information that we are able to
fetch from this particular data frame
about the Stars so let's get
started now what we are going to do is
we are going to take that uh CSV data
I'm going to Simply copy this link and
use this particular link or part to the
CSV file read that CSV file with the
help of pendas library and create a
pendas data frame so what does this mean
so I'm going to use pendas functionality
so I'm using PD and then dot to refer to
any kind of functionality that is
present in pendal and now because I want
to read the CSV file I'm going to write
this command rore CSV and then it
expects this path in the format of
string to that CSV file so I'm going to
Simply give this kind of a quotation
mark and paste that link now you don't
have to download this particular data
from this link and then upload it
somewhere to basically read the CSU file
this link is sharable for everyone so
you simply go ahead copy that link paste
it over here and simply press control
enter to run this code and you will be
seeing that the whole data of that CSV
file is now expressed into this kind of
a table that is your pendas data frame
now how do I know that this is a pendas
data frame so whatever code we have
written and whatever it is generating
for us I can always check its type by
simply writing the type and whatever
command that I'm getting over here if
I'm running this and you can see that we
are getting this pendas data frame right
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
store this pendas data frame into some
of the variable so that we don't have to
again and again read the CSV file so I'm
going to store it in a variable called
let's say star DF what it means it's a
data frame uh which is having the
information of stars right so you can
name it the way you want this is what I
have choosen okay now let's say if you
want to visualize top three rows of this
data how you can do it you call that
data frame that you have created and
then on top of that what kind of
functionality you can use you can use
the functionality of head this head
automatically gives you if you don't put
any kind of input over here it gives you
first five rows of data that is present
in your CSV file now let's if I want to
visualize top three I can just give this
three and yeah you can get this kind of
three first values that is present in
our CSV file as you can see there are
some different properties of the stars
and there are some different respective
stars that we are having over here so
zero is a star that is present on our
first particular row then the second
star is present on index one so on and
so forth right so that's the kind of
idea that we are having now what if I
want to visualize some 10 random samples
of the stars that are present in this
data so for that we use some different
functionality of the data frame that is
sample the sample allows you to get some
random samples from this data frame by
simply passing in the number for example
let's say I want to visualize 10
different samples from this data frame
as you can see that now on the left side
the index values are completely
different it's not starting from 0 1 2 3
like that it's some random index so it
is indicating that we are trying to
display some random 10 data points that
are present in the CSV file right and
each and every Star is having the
properties with respect to its
temperature Luminosity radius absolute
magnitude of that star what is the star
type if you can see the star type is
given in the format of some numerical
data there is some kind of a reason
behind that I'll be explaining it to you
in a while and then there's also a star
color and a spectral class this is the
kind of data that we are having right
and all of this kind of stars are having
this kind of properties and by using
these properties we are going to create
some of the visualizations that we'll be
seeing throughout this module
right now let's say this is the overall
data that we have seen right now if you
want to get let's say a generic
information from this data frame then
how you can do it you can do it with the
help of you again call the data frame
whose generic information you are trying
to look for to get it some of its
functionality you press this Dot and the
functionality that we looking forward to
is the information of that data frame
and that command is do info you don't
need to give any kind of inputs over
here you simply run this and you're
going to get an overall general
information that is stored for this
particular data frame it is giving you
that there are total of 240 different
stars that are present in your data
frame whose index are starting from zero
and goes all the way up to 239 okay and
then there are some different seven
columns for each and every row that is
present in our data and what is the name
of these columns we can also find that
over here that my first column that is
present on my index zero is temperature
as you can see over here that's my first
column on index zero this is index one
index two index three four five and six
in total there are total of seven
different columns like that and
respective uh name of the column has
been given over here and then there are
also information with respect to nonnull
count what it means if there are any
kind of data point in this whole data
frame which is missing for example if
this was missing then what would happen
in a radius there is one missing value
so over here in radius you would have
got 239 nonnull out of 240 there are 239
data points which are not missing which
are not null but there is one point
which is missing so this kind of nonnull
count column is giving you an idea with
respect to how many uh data points are
missing as you can see that out of 240
all of this 240 are nonnull it means
every data is complete now the reason
the data is complete like this in real
life you don't get this kind of complete
data you have to perform some of the
techniques called as feature engineering
handling the missing values and all
these kind of things so that you can use
this model for a proper analysis that's
the whole idea and that's again one of
the reason why we have converted the
star type into numerical type because at
the end this data was used to create
some of the machine learning models but
now because that's not part of this
particular program we are not going to
talk about that I'm simply going to tell
you that let's say uh zero means let's
say some kind of a dwarf star I mean
some kind of a super giant star all this
kind of information I'll be giving you
at the end of this particular video but
yeah just know that all of this file
that you are seeing right now it wasn't
like this from the beginning it was made
perfect so that we can perform this kind
of visualizations on top of this kind of
given data right because our aim is not
to uh handle this kind of missing values
do some kind of feature engineering and
create some kind of machine learning
models our job is to take the data set
which is complete and then create
visualization on top of that that's the
whole idea of this particular program
right so let's focus on that particular
part so now we are having 240 Nal
contents for every columns that is
existing along with that we are also
having that for each and every column
what is the data type in which this
information has been stored so overall
summary is present over here that out of
seven columns three are of Flo type
which means there are some kind of
decimals involved over here then there
are two columns with integer type and
then there are two object type object
type you can call it as like you know
some kind of a text data that is present
over there something like that is what
you can assume as of now in a very like
you know lay and language and the total
memory consumption for this kind of data
is 13.2 plus KB so yeah that's also
giving you the kind of idea with respect
to the memory that has been used to
store this particular data so as you can
notice for the temperature all of this
values are in the format of integers but
now if you talk about Luminosity it's
having this kind of decimals which are
involved right and now that's why it's
also given this luminosity in the format
of float don't worry about this kind of
numbers okay this numbers are basically
giving you the Precision of the way of
writing that particular number let's not
got let's not go into the this kind of
technical details as of now right uh
let's focus on this kind of this is a
float type this is also a float type
this is again a float type because again
some kind of numbers with this decimals
but then star type is integers and Then
star color and spectral class are both
having some kind of Text data so now
again that are appearing over here in
the format of the object data type of
this pendas data so here that's an
overall observation that we are able to
make by importing this data from this uh
particular Google drive to Google collab
looking into some of its random samples
and then also getting some kind of
generic information on top of that if
you want to look into its overall
observation here is I have written in a
complete detail okay there are 240 rows
with six independent features and one
dependent feature that is the target
column again this is mentioned with
respect to let's say a machine learning
data set that you are trying to classify
the star type based on other six
properties okay so that's that's the
kind of idea about this data set but
again we are not going to do any kind of
machine learning thing over here we are
simply going to create
visualizations okay and here are all the
kind of information about The Columns
right this is the target class the star
type right but anyways you don't need to
get into that particular information and
what is the meaning of Lo and r o that
is L and R not these are the average
values of Luminosity of the Sun and
radius of the Sun so all this
information that you are seeing with
respect to the luminosity and radius now
that is with comparison to the Sun that
compared to Sun what is the Luminosity
of this star compared to the radius of
sun what is the radius of this
particular star so it gives you some
kind of a comparison directly that okay
yeah this star is less luminous as
compared to our own sun and also its
radius is small as compared to our own
Sun so yeah that's the kind of idea that
we are
having apart from that yes there are
star color and spectral class which are
categorical features which means it's in
the format of some kind of
categories there are some kind of
different categories of of colors there
are some different categories of
spectral class right so this is the kind
of data that we are having over here and
then this is what I was trying to look
after right this is something that I was
trying to look after that this
information about the star type the
integers that were mentioned right
originally it was having some kind of a
name to it zero stands for brown dwarf
one stands for red dwar two stands for
white DWF three is standing for the main
sequence four is for super Giants and
five is for hyper Giants now we are
going to create some kind of
visualization at the end of this module
that is going to display this whole uh
information of the Stars into an HR
diagram and finally we'll be able to
classify it like this hyper Giants Super
Giants white dwarves right red bars this
kind of things is what we are going to
expect at the end of this module this is
one final visualization that we are
going to create so yeah that was the
idea with respect to exploring this kind
of data set uh uh so far after this what
we are going to do is in AUD to create a
visualization and then save it somewhere
we going to create a directory uh in the
next video so stay
tuned hey everyone welcome back once
again to the module 2 and in this video
we are going to understand that where
exactly are we going to save the
visualizations that we'll be creating in
the upcoming videos of module 2 so for
that you're going to understand that how
you can create a directory in Python and
then how you can get the path of the
directory so that we can use it in order
to save all the kind of beautiful
visualizations that we'll be creating in
some of the upcoming videos so let's
understand how we can create a directory
and get a path of it in this particular
video let's get into
it now before we go ahead and create any
kind of visualizations we need to save
it somewhere so for that I'm going to
create one directory or you can call it
as a directory or a folder whatever you
want so for that I'm going to first of
all give the name to that folder so let
me create a variable called as folder
name that I might change maybe later on
in future so yeah I'm just giving it as
a folder name over here as star plots
you can give whatever name you want over
here and then I'm also going to create a
folder now of this particular name right
now I just created a variable I haven't
created any kind of folder now how can I
create that folder over here now if I
show you over here this is what is
called as the session storage space of
the Google collab where by default this
kind of sample data exists for every
notebook okay so we haven't created
anything from our side it is already
existing if you will check it will be
existing for you as well now my job is
to create one more folder whose name is
star plots and the way that I can do
this is I just come to the next uh line
and write OS because that's the library
that we have imported in our previous
one of the previous videos and I'm going
to use a specific functionality of this
OS that's going to help me create a
directory and that is called as make
directories make de is the command and
now it expects two of this uh inputs the
first input is the name of the folder so
I'm going to give this as a folder name
at the same time it expects uh us to
give exist
okay and we are going to set this to
true what it means it means that if this
kind of folder already exist in your
space then it's not going to recreate
the folder or something like that if
it's existing it's not going to do any
kind of changes if it's not existing as
of now we don't have this kind of file
then it's automatically going to create
a directory for us now if I run this
code now the code has ran successfully
and if I refresh this part you can see
this directory has been created for us
now the main idea is to whatever kind of
visualizations that you will be creating
you need to create a path that will
store it within this particular location
so for that what I need to do is I need
to Simply get the path of this folder I
can do this by clicking on this three
dots over here and click on copy path
and I can create a base directory path
over here which simply means that any
kind of visualizations that you are
creating you will be storing in this
base directory and now I'm going to
equate this to the string of this path
and now I'll just make this path Dynamic
just in case uh we are having some
different folder name in future if I
want to change I don't have to change
this base directory path I'm going to
use F string for that that's what we had
learned in our first module right so uh
I'm going to write folder name over here
instead of star plots right so I just
can change the name of the folder if I
want and automatically this will be
changing right so that's the whole idea
and after this there is one more slash I
need to give it means that if I'm
concatenating my this particular path
with any kind of files that we are
generating of visualizations I'll be
simply concatenating it on top of this
base directory so in order to connect
them we need a slash just like how you
can see there is a slash over here right
whatever session storage you are seeing
of collab over here is referred to this
kind of content that you are seeing then
inside this space you are having this
specific folder that you are trying to
extract over here and that's why because
this folder is existing in this space
you are giving this slash over here and
now then you are giving this kind of
star plots and then to store any kind of
data within this directory right then
you are giving this kind of a slash
again and now once you will concate it
with let's say uh
example.png some file that you have
created so you just need to concatenate
this name of the file that you have
created and attach it with the base
directory that's it and your path of
that new visualizations that you will be
creating uh will be stored over here and
the image will be generated over here
right so that's the whole idea that we
are having uh as in why we are having
this base directory over here okay if
it's not making any kind of sense as of
now don't worry as you'll be going ahead
in this particular module you will be
getting a lot of ideas with respect to
what is the need of this particular base
directory all right now in the next
video we're going to go ahead and
visualize the count of stars for each
type of star like you know we are having
varieties of star so we are going to
visualize what are the different counts
in in what quantity are this kind of
stars present right so stay tuned for
that I'll see you in the next
video hey guys welcome to the sixth
video of module 2 and here you're going
to create your first visualization for
this data on Stars so you're going to
create your bar graph and it will be
very basic visualization that we'll be
having with the help of map. library and
in the upcoming videos you are also
going to customize it and look at just
amazing okay so for now let's create at
least basic version of the bar graph
that's going to give us some of the
information about the data set so let's
get into
it now let's go ahead and create our
first visualization that is in order to
see that out of 240 stars that are
available in our data set how many of
them belong to brown dwarf how many of
them belongs to redw so on and so forth
for all the kind of different categories
that are present in our star type column
okay so what you will have to do is
first of all you will will have to fetch
this kind of a account with the help of
pendas data frame and then you can on
top of that use this functionality of M
plotti in order to visualize it so what
we are doing first of all I'm just going
to copy the name of this column so that
we can extract all of this data that is
present within this column of the data
frame and how I can do it I can come
back to that particular code cell over
here and I can simply type stard DF to
access the data frame and now to access
any specific column of the data frame
you need to pass in this square brackets
and then I paste the name of that
particular column but now in the format
of strings okay and now if I just run
this over here you can see that there
are different star types of category
zero all the way up to five right as you
can see over here zero stands for br W
five stands for hyper Giants and
everything within that is going to be
stored into this particular column now
if I want to get this kind of a count
that how many zeros are present how many
ones are present so on and so forth I
have a particular command for that that
exists in the pandas data frame I need
to go and type Valore counts with this
parenthesis so what what's happening
it's giving us all these kind of counts
that there are 40 zeros that are present
or I should say 40 Brown Wes present
then 40 red veres present similarly like
that all of this are as you can see is
40 40 40 so out of 2 40 stars in total
40 of them are for each and every
category that you are seeing over here
40 main sequence stars super giant stars
all of this are having 40 40 type of
count of stars out of 240 so now if you
want to visualize this kind of a data in
let's say format of bar plot or bar
chart whatever you want to call what you
can do is you can simply come over here
and use this functionality of plot over
here on top of whatever you have got and
then give this kind of input as what
kind of plot you want do you want a bar
plot so you give this kind of input as
kind and set it to bar that hey go ahead
take this kind of data that that's what
you can see and create a bar plot out of
it and now in order to visualize this I
can simply have PLT Dosh show I'm using
the M PL Li functionality to display the
graph that I will be creating over here
okay and now if I can run this code you
can see that this is the output that we
have got okay it's a very plain output
we haven't customized it that is the
goal of the next video that is like you
know we're going to customize the above
plot and then finally save it right now
this is the very basic graph that I have
created that is indicating that okay now
for different categories here are the
respective counts that you can see it's
a perfectly balanced data for us and
yeah now in the next video you will be
seeing how we can customize this plot
and make it look very very beautiful as
compared to what you are seeing right
now
hi students welcome to the sth video of
module 2 here we going to take the graph
that we have created in our previous
video we going to customize it we are
going to make it look much more
beautiful as compared to what it was in
our previous video and then once we are
satisfied with the output we are also
going to save it in that directory that
we had created earlier in the fifth
video of this module so let's get
started all right guys so get ready to
see the whole different magic we are
going to take this kind of basic default
looking graph and beautify it by using
this kind of customizations that I have
written down I'm going to take this
basic graph and convert it into
something really very beautiful okay so
let's go ahead and try to do it together
so first of all I'll need this kind of
basic graph on top of which we are going
to build everything so I'm just going to
copy paste this code and run
this so yeah here we are having the same
kind of graph the first thing that I'm
going to do is I'm going to adjust the
size of the figure according to my
convenience okay so let's say some of
you might like a bigger size of this
figure I would personally go for a
smaller size so how can I adjust the
size of this figure I can do this with
the help of a PLT command and what kind
of command I need to use I need to use
the command called Figure now this is
going to give me the axis of this whole
figure on which we are having this AIS
on which we are having this graph okay
so we are having one whole figure in
that figure there is one AIS that this
kind of square that you are seeing and
now on that axis we are drawing this bar
graph so what I'm doing is I'm trying to
get the access to this figure and now
inside this figure there is an option
called as figure size that is fix size
fig SI i z now over here you can give
how much amount of uh width and height
you want to give to this particular uh
graph or plot whatever you want to call
let's I'm changing this to 5 comma 5 and
see how it looks
like so yeah that's the the kind of
output that I'm having I guess I would
still like to decrease some of the size
let's say I'm doing something like 4.3
4.3 hopefully this is fine this time
yeah this is looking a much more better
okay for some of you you might like uh
very huge graph you might try to
increase the figure size in that case
but I guess for me uh it's convenient
for me to use this particular figure
size so we are done with the first
customization we are trying to adjust
the figure size that's SU able to right
we are done with this part now the
second part is to add the value of the
counts on top of the bars it simply
means that for each and every category
okay at times what can happen that some
of the bar the count is less let's say
somewhere in between 20 to 25 now if I
want my readers to exactly know the
count for this particular bar so we can
add the count on top of this kind of bar
and that's exactly what I'm going to do
in this particular case it could be like
you know our users or our readers might
be confused that like you know if this
bar is exactly at 40 or 39 or 41 what
whatever it is right so this kind of
skills is necessary for you to have that
whenever you're drawing a bar chart if
you want to show this label on top of
this bar you can what you can do is
first of all see we were having this
kind of figure inside figure we are
having this AIS on which we are drawing
this bar graph right so I'm going to
label this AIS because I want to use
some of the properties of this exis
and that is I want to set bar labels I
can do it with this command ax. bar
label what I'm doing on this axis where
I'm drawing this kind of bar
gra I'm getting its property called bar
label and now there is something which
we give an input called
containers
containers con what is the spelling
containers right and now I'm going to
access the values of each and every bar
by using this zero index and now if I
run this
code see now we are having this kind of
40 40 count right it will be really very
useful the moment let's say any kind of
bar count is like you know somewh
somewhere it's at 40 somewhere it is
35ish 30ish somewhere in between it's
going to be very much useful also you'll
be seeing this in the second
visualization that we'll be creating
where the level of bar are not equal
okay but yeah that's how you basically
do this particular thing after this
let's say I also want to change the
color of this I'm not satisfied with
this kind of black color I can simply
change the color by giving the input
argument of bar label as color and set
it to let's say for example
red see now it's much more better right
we decreased the size of the figure then
we took the AIS on which we were having
the bar graph we took the labels of each
and every bar with the help of ax.
container Z Z and simply displayed it
with the help of this functionality of
this axis that is barcor
lead so that's what we have done so far
the next thing is to set the background
to dark now it's again your choice okay
if you think you like darker backgrounds
then you go for the darker backgrounds
or else you can stay with this kind of
lighter versions also whatever is
suiting you the best right I personally
like the darker background so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to use this PLT
do style.
okay this is the command through which
you can set a particular background
there are again multiple backgrounds
that you can choose the one that I'm
going to choose is called Dark
underscore
baground okay and now if I run this okay
there is some kind of an error the error
is saying that dark backgrounds is not
available I guess I've done some kind of
a typo it should be dark background and
see now this is the output now it's
looking something weird right I cannot
say the x is Mark what I can do is I can
simply run it again because that's the
like you know this kind of issue is
there with Google collab that if you are
changing the style okay then you will
have to run it twice so yeah that's how
it's looking like right now
automatically this color of this AIS has
changed from black to white that's the
property of darkcore background right
now if I want to change this to default
I can also use this kind of default
style and maybe I'll have to run it
twice to make it look better see I'll
have to run it
twice
so hopefully we're getting back from
where we started see yeah that's how
it's looking like right so what I'm
going to do is I I'm personally a fan of
dark background so I'll be changing this
to dark
background now at the same time what
I'll be doing is I'll also be changing
the color of each and every bar so right
now it's a plain Canan kind of looking
bar right I'm going to change each and
every color for this bar okay for this
what I can do is I can simply come onto
this particular graph and uh give one
more input instead of uh just having
just kind is equal to
bar I give color property and now I just
have don't have only one bar to change
the color for example if I change this
to let's say brown see what
happens it's changing all of them to
brown right I don't want this I want to
create a list for each and every color
that I'll be giving to this bars so
let's say I'm choosing let's say brown
red red white right all these kind of
colors are coming into my mind what I'm
going to do is I'm going to create a
list okay I'm going to store all of this
colors in the format of list let's say
first is
brown right then the second one is red
then I'm giving white you can choose
this colors the way you want then let's
say uh
yellow and some kind of different colors
that's that's existing in the mat. li.
PIP blot let's say there is light blue
and maybe uh the last one I would choose
as
orange okay so I guess we are done 1 2 3
4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 so I guess this should
work let's see yeah see now we are
having multiple colors in the bars right
brown red white yellow light blue and
orange so yeah that's how you can change
the colors of each and every bar right I
hope this is making sense to you now
after this let's say I want to describe
that what is this plot giving us like
you know what kind of title we want to
add to this plot so for this what I can
do is I can give this command pl. title
and set any kind of title that I want
for example I can give let's say a
visualize star count per star type right
visualize star
count per star type and also I can give
a color to it for let's say by default
what is the color that we
get so this is the kind of output that
we're getting we can also set this whole
font to let's say bold okay I can also
change the color of it let's try to do
this kind of things you can also change
the font size you can try to decrease
the size increase the size whatever
suits you the best let's say the first
input that I'm giving is the color and
I'm choosing the color as royal blue
okay how do I know this kind of things
exist how do I know this dark background
exist how do I know this kind of colors
exist right because I've gone through
the documentation of each and every
command you can simply go to its
official documentation by searching on
Google I can simply copy this command go
to Google and search for it off official
documentation and you can get all these
kind of things or nowadays you're also
having access to chat gpts right so you
go to chat GPT and ask for what kind of
different styles I can use in this pl.
style. use it's going to give you
multiple different suggestions right so
I'm going to set this color to Royal
Blue I'm also going to change the weight
of this font to
bold and I guess uh F phont size is
looking good to
me I'm going to run
this I guess this is looking pretty much
good right so we are done by setting a
title now I'm also going to add a y
label and also change the color of this
y takes this kind of things are called y
takes this is called as X takes so first
of all what I'm going to do is I'm going
to add my y
label I'm going to do this with the help
of PLT doy label and give some kind of
name like you know whatever this is
describing for example let's say number
of stars count of stars right I can give
a hashtag for that that is representing
number of something so number of
stars right and I'm also going to set a
color to this let's say I am I am
choosing a color called
pink okay let's see how the output looks
like see this is the kind of pink color
that I've got but now the font size is
pretty much small I want to increase the
font size how I can do this I can give
the input parameter called font size
itself that's the name of the parameter
and change this parameter size to let's
say 13 let's see how it looks
like I guess this is better but now it's
like you know even much more as compared
to this so maybe I would like to
decrease to 11 and see how it looks
like I guess yeah this is better this is
much more better now how I can take this
y Tak and change its color to let's say
some different kind of pink let's say
tab pink this is the color that I want
okay so let's go ahead and try to do
this I can get access to this y TI by
again using PLT and use white white TI
okay now I'm going to set color
parameter to this as let's say tabular
pink again T pink is one of the color
that is available in M.L so I guess yeah
this is looking much much more good
right obviously you can play with this
kind of colors the way you want I guess
I am comfortable with what I'm having
right now maybe I can try to change this
um color to let's say white not
pink obviously you take this thing
change it the way you want yeah I guess
yeah this is much more
great now one more thing that I would
like to do is I would like to replace
all the X sticks from 0 1 2 3 4 five to
its respective names that are shown over
here so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to Simply copy these
things and come over here and paste
it it over here and then this is in the
same order that I want to right so I'm
just going to delete this part I don't
want this kind of
part
okay and I also want to uh arrange this
into a proper kind of way through which
I can change the X scks all the 0 1 2 3
4 5 uh that we are having over here
right 0 1 2 3 4 5 I want this to be
changed to the labels that I want in
place of this 0 to 1 two 5 okay so what
I can do is because I want to change
this XT I can give this PLT do
xti and now what kind of things I want
to change so these are called the ticks
that are present inside X ticks so I can
give it as a part of list it is 0 to
five right so 0 1 2 3 four and five now
I want to get replace this t with the
labels okay the first input is Tes the
second input is labels right and now I'm
going to give again a list of all of
these things that we have written over
here okay let's say brown dwarf is the
first thing I'm going to give it in the
format of
string and then I'm going to do it for
Red
Bar r
w after that we are having white
barve and then main
sequence main
sequence after that we are having super
Giants and Hyper joints super joints and
Hyper joints
okay so I guess this is good let me just
try to run this and see okay I guess we
have to dedit this we don't need that
thing
anymore and now if I run this hopefully
it's
changing yeah see now this is what I am
getting Brown bar red bar but I don't
want this kind of things okay I want to
rotate this things let's say some some
degrees and I also want Brown to be in
the first line dwarf to be in the second
line righted to be in the first line
white I mean dwarf in the second like
that right so what I can do is I can
give a new line character between this
brown and valve similarly for red and
wve
right similarly for this main sequence
and then there is only one one word so I
don't need to convert them but now what
I can do is I can just bring this down
so that it's visible to
everyone and then I'm going to give one
more parameter called rotation I can
give let's say 10° of rotation let's see
how it looks like
it's it's a bit cluttered right so what
I can do is I can maybe try to uh rotate
it to let's say 45 deges or something
let's see how it looks like right after
changing this to 45 I guess 45 is going
to look
good yeah this is looking much better
right I guess yeah this is much more
better now let's say I want to change
the color of this as well I can again
give the property of color to this XT
and change this color to let's say
maybe
line let's see how it looks like this is
looking good
right so yeah that's what we are having
that's that's what we are going to get
by replacing the ticks of x from 0 to 5
and giving it its respective label that
is brown dwarf red DF white dwarf so on
and so forth so yeah that's what we have
done over here and after this we are
going to save this particular plot in
the base directory that we had created I
want to store it within this thing so
now how can I do this right I guess the
plot that we have created is far more
beautiful as compared to what we had
seen over here right I can maybe uh try
to again change this to Super in the
first line then Giants in the second
line I could have done that but I guess
this is fine now in order to save this
thing what I can do is I can simply come
over here here and give this command PLT
do save fig now what is this thing going
to do it's going to allow us to give the
path where I want to save this figure so
the first thing is I want to give the
base directory right the base directory
is the directory that we have created
for this starcore plots now if you
remember this base directory wherever we
have created we have given the slash so
I just need to concatenate the name that
I want to give to this plot
let's say uh we are giving this
name in order to Conca it we can use the
plus operator and then let's say give
this as barplot star count something
like that
barplot star
count. PNG you can also save it as JPEG
if you want but yeah let me just go
ahead and try to do
this and hopefully we are getting this
output over here if I yeah see that's
there if I double click on this or here
we can see that this is the kind of
output that we have got right now I'm
simply going to close it and uh close
this
also and yeah we are done with this
first plot okay this is the first plot
that we have saved after creating it
after beautifying it that's what we have
done now in the second upcoming video
what I'll be doing is I'll be creating
one more visualization it would be a bar
graph only but with the help of cbor and
now see that with the help of cbor how
we can do the same kind of
and that is much more convenient as
compared to using mat plot L all of this
reasoning will be getting clear once you
look into the second video or the
upcoming
video hey everyone welcome to the eighth
video of module 2 and here we are going
to visualize some different part of the
data set again in the format of a bar
graph but we'll be creating it with the
help of cbond library and you're going
to see that how easier it is in order to
create some amazing bar graph with the
help of c bond as compared to met plot
La so let's get
started now what we're going to do is
we're going to go to the top part to
that uh data frame that we had created
and take a look onto the star color we
are again going to create a bar graph
but now with the help of cbor you will
see the power of cbor that with just one
line of code you are able to achieve
something like this color for different
bars and all of these kind of things you
will see that so so now what I'm doing
is first of all I'm trying to visualize
the star color count that is present for
each and every color so for this what
I'll have to do I'll have to go to Star
DF inside that star DF there is a column
called a star color I should give it
with the help of strings and then I can
check the value
counts with
this so as you can see that there are
red stars the count is 116 for blue it's
56 for blue white it's 41 by default
it's coming into the descending format
starting from the highest and going to
the lowest and now if I want to get
access to this values this red blue and
all these kind of things now this is
present in the position of index so I
can take this command on top of this
command I want to grab its index so I'm
going to give this command do
index so here is the whole index red
blue blue white and all of these things
so now what I want to do is on the xaxis
I want to plot this colors that are this
index and on the y- axis I want to get
this particular uh values okay if I grab
the first value that is present over
here it will be 116 see it's 116 now if
I want to grab the value present on the
first index it will be the second value
56 right so I want to plot this data on
my y- Axis and I want to plot this
colors on the x-axis so what I can do
is I can use use uh SNS do barplot I'm
trying to create a barplot with the help
of cbond library on the x value on the x
value I am giving this whole thing with
index do index that's the color name and
on Y what I want to see I want to see
the value counts so I'm going to copy
this
part I'm going to copy this much part
and save it in y and let's just try to
run this and see how the out looks like
see this is the kind of output if I
don't want to have this kind of extra
labeling that is there on top of the
graph I'll have to use the command PLT
do show I'm trying to use both met
plotly and cbond to come up with one
final
output so by using this PLT do show this
AIS will be going away so yeah this is
the kind of graph that we are having see
now again we can have any more
customization see by default it's not
coming out as a white background right
now because we have already changed it
once you change it it will be like this
okay it will not going back to white
color you will have to go and switch
this style do Ed to default in order to
have this kind of white background but I
guess black black background is quite
comfortable but now you can see that I
don't even have to set this kind of
colors manually it's coming
automatically without myself doing
anything over here now what I can do is
I can just uh come over here and give
one more thing that is called pallet I
hope I have given the correct spelling
again there are multiple pallets that
are available this uh vies is my
favorite one so this is looking much
more beautiful right so yeah that's
that's about it now I can again go ahead
and customize it the way I want right I
can change this uh color for this Y axis
I can change this colors of the T and
everything I can do this right so what
I'll be doing is I'll simply be going
ahead and doing this kind of
visualizations okay I guess the figure
size is looking pretty much good I'll be
changing the tix of the x-axis pl. X
TI give a rotation I guess of 15° or 10°
15 I guess let's try 15 and I'll give
the color as
orange and see how it's looking like
this is good now what about star color
I'm going
to take the Y label see it's coming by
default I didn't even give this thing
it's coming by default it's all because
c bond is is built on top of met plot by
default within this bar plot they are
giving this kind of Y label that is the
title of the column that's what they're
giving by default I didn't even set it
and if I want to change its color I can
use PLT do let's say y label and give
some kind of color let's say white can
also change the font size to let's say
13 let's see how it looks like it's
giving me some kind of an error y y
label okay y label is missing some kind
of an
argument okay maybe we are trying to oh
yeah we are missing the Y label we need
to give this kind of uh command that is
star color okay we'll have to give this
if you want to change this y label you
will have to give this kind of name only
then it will be working fine see yeah
now it's working fine right so yeah I
given this kind of things I can also
change the colors of the whex if I want
PLT do
whex
this uh color is equal to tab pink this
is my favorite one for the y- axis
that's what I use frequently so yeah I
can also have the title of this plot
that we have
visualizing pl. title we try to
basically give title on the top because
we know like you know this is the kind
of order first we give first we draw the
plot after drawing the plot we give the
title this kind of order is not
something that you need to follow TI T
right now
visualizing the
count of star
colors something like this maybe color
is equal to Royal
Blue for title again I prefer this if
I'm having the dark background and font
size let's say I'm setting it to
15 two more than what I am having for
this I can also set this to
weight equal to bold I can also uh for
the X uh T I can try to change the font
size if I'm able to do this I can take
this write font
size change this to let's say 11
hopefully it
changes yeah it's changing right so I
guess this is pretty much great now I
can also add like you know this kind of
containers to this bar and the same way
I'll be doing I'll be changing this to
a because I'm trying to get AIS of the
AIS right and then I'll be doing ax. bar
label and then ax.
containers zero and then maybe I can
give a color of red and I can also maybe
change the weight of this thing to bold
and see how it's looking
like first of all the main thing I
really wanted to show you is that by
doing this just one line of code it's
giving us the Y label it's giving us
everything even different colors of the
bar with the help of pallet right so all
of these kind of things we are doing it
in just one line so that's the power of
like you know using C Bor it's built on
top of matte BL Li so it's it's just
easy to customize it the way you want as
you can see that star color was already
existing even before giving this y leg
but now if I want to change some of its
property I can do it it because cbon is
built on top of
Med so yeah that's that's about like you
know how you can visualize a different
kind of bar plots and now in the next
video let's try to visualize something
else hey everyone welcome to the ninth
video of module 2 where you will be
visualizing the outliers present in our
data set and one of the ways through
which we can do this is by creating the
box plot on all of these kind of
features that we are having in the data
set and we are going to visualize them
side by side with the help of a subplot
so what is subplot and everything will
be covered in this particular video so
let's get into
it now let's go ahead and try to create
some different type of visualization
apart from the bar plot now what we are
going to do is called box plot now it's
typically used to visualize the outliers
that might be present in any of your
numerical feature so the main idea
behind box blots is that like you know
you're are going to have this kind of
variation of numeric feature in front of
you it's going to give you the idea of
the median it's going to give you the
idea of the upper quartile lower
quartile and also the outliers right and
for the outliers visualization we
typically use the box plots and finally
just save it into this particular folder
that we have created and I guess we did
not save this particular code so let's
go ahead and try to save this figure
save fig and the name that I'm going to
give you not give you but yeah give this
particular graph is base directory plus
let's say visualize or just start
star colors star
Colors
v.png Let's go ahead and also try to
cross check if it is
done yeah it's done I'm going to see it
so yeah that's the beautiful plot that
we have created and saved right anyways
yeah we are also going to save this kind
of box plots that will be be generating
all right so that's the whole idea that
we're going to look into so now what I
have done is I already created one this
kind of get a gist of data by checking
the first five rows of the data so over
here we can see that temperature
Luminosity radius and absolute magnitude
are what are your numeric features all
of the last three features are your
categorical feature it's some kind of
categories now we use box blots to
visualize this kind of numeric features
so now what I'm going to do is with
respect to all the star typee that is 0
to five for all the star types what is
the variation of temperature what is the
median what is the interqual range what
is the outlier if at all they are
present in any of the star type category
with respect to the temperature I am
also going to do this for Luminosity
radius and absolute magnitude so I'm
going to create multiple plots for all
these numeric features with respect to
Star type you can also do this for Star
colors and also the spectral classes
it's your choice right now I'm going to
show you any one visualization and I'm
going to do it with respect to the star
type that if my let's say my star type
is um white dwarf so for with respect to
white dwarf what is the variation of
data for radius what is the variation of
data for Luminosity this is the kind of
thing that I'm going to generate so what
I'm going to do I'm going to come over
here and uh get this boxplot with the
help of SNS do
boxplot it requires what want to display
on xaxis what you want to display on y-
axis and lastly I'll be also showing
this pl. show and on X what I want to
show is the star type right and on the
y- axis let's say I'm giving for example
only one thing as of now that is
temperature so SNS dobox plot on X what
am I giving star DF star
type and on by what I want is start de
uh it is temperature right I'm just
going to copy the whole thing but a
better way would be to not copy this
instead use iog feature it's giving you
the location on the basis of index now
it takes two things in the input the
rows and the column I want to plot all
the rows and the First Column that is
present in the stard D okay all the rows
of the First Column now First Column is
present on index zero right so I can get
it use with the help of this zero okay
remember this kind of column that we
have given over here that column is
giving you this idea that everything
everything that is present in rows you
grab that part but now only for index
zero column so now if I go ahead and
visualize
this let's see what kind of output do we
get see this is the kind of output that
has been generated I have got 0 1 2 3 4
5 all the different star types which are
corresponding to this kind of names and
now if you see there are no much of
outliers except this zero right this
kind of diamond this diamond is
basically highlighting the presence of
outlier for the class zero and if we are
talking with respect to only one numeric
feature that is temperature now what I
want to do is I want to generate the
same thing now in place of zero I can
change this to one and see the output
the output this time is for Luminosity
see I don't have to change the column
Name by default for by manually I don't
have to do this thing okay it's
happening
automatically but now instead of
plotting this one by one I want to plot
it all together in one figure and then
save it and that's where this kind of
concept of box plot comes into the
picture right so what we are trying to
do over here is this is one whole
figure now from that one figure we are
creating six different axes
how we are creating the six different
AES by giving the command of PLT do
subplot providing the values of rows and
columns I'm giving two different rows
and three different
columns and then the first axis over
here is starting from position one the
second axis is on position two the third
axis is on position three so on and so
forth so that's how you can create the
subplot and try to visualize this thing
over here so what I can do over here is
I can do PLT do
subplot and give one let's say I want to
create four different graphs in one row
so 1 comma 4 and I want to first of all
look into my position one and then I
want to see how the output looks like
let's see how it's looking like see this
is on the first position now if I'm uh
just trying to change this to zero and
copy this whole
code come down over here and just change
this to
one and but at the same time I'll also
have have to change the position of this
to
two see now I'm having this kind of prop
but it's very much cluttered right so to
I'll have to manage the figure size
accordingly and I'll also do some kind
of uh one more command that you will see
of M plot lip to adjust the layout that
we are seeing right now if it's getting
cluttered like this then we know how to
do this I'll be showing you that okay
but the whole idea is I want to create
this kind of subplots but now just
imagine if there are multiple subplots
that I want to create it's not a very
good thing to like manually change this
kind of indexes so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create a for Loop over
here so what I'm going to
do I'm going to create for Loop but how
am I going to create the for Loop right
that's something important that you want
to understand so in this for loop I am
going to create four different x's on
index 1 2 3 and four or I should say on
position 1 2 3 and four so for I in
range of four so it's going to go from 0
1 2 and 3 right and now I want to also
give indentation indentation over here
okay I'll remove this PLT do show
command as of now okay and now I want to
change the position with respect to I
because I is starting from index 0er
I'll add one to it so that we get 0 + 1
is 1 because we know that subplot always
starts from position one not from
position zero so that's the reason I've
done this kind of thing and now at the
same time I'll also change this to I
it's going to take the zeroth column
first then the First Column then the
second index column and then the third
index column so that's how I'm going to
create my uh subplots let's see how it's
going to look
like see that's how it's going to look
like as of now
right I also like to change the
background it's not black is not looking
good for this one so what I'll do is
I'll first of all change this
style to default and you know you must
do it twice to get a proper output okay
this is for the first time that we have
got
this this is for the second time and I
guess this will be this time it's good
it's still cluttered because we did not
change the figure size so PLT do figure
what kind of command we give we give fig
size right fig size and let's say I'm
choosing 20 by 8 20 by 8 so I'm going to
get 20 spread and eight in terms of
height so I guess now this is better
right this is much more better so we are
getting this for temperature over here
we getting for Luminosity but still
there are some kind of cluttering that
that's what I can see so to adjust this
cluttering what I can do is I can maybe
see first of all uh
get rid of this y label completely and
instead of that I can have a title for
each and every plot okay I'll be
removing this kind of things and have a
title on top of that that's the kind of
thing I want to do so what I will do is
I'll say PLT doy label and convert it to
nothing and at the same time I'm going
to set
title and what is the title title is the
column name so how do I get access to
the column name
so for this there is one simple code
that is stdf do
columns that's
it if I run this see I'm getting access
to each and every columns right so now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
and call these columns one by one with
the help of itation index I so PLT do
title star DF do columns and then I'm
going to give an index I'm also going to
set a color to red and now see how it
looks
like see now it's it's better right I
cannot see any kind of cluttering
anymore if you want you can also expand
this by let's say changing this 20 to 25
right even that's fine but I guess this
is much more better right but now what
is this indicating if I want to give a
title on top of this whole subplot that
I have done I have created I can use
something called as
subtitle see Su I can again get its
access with the help of PLT see this is
what is called subtitle now what kind of
title am I giving I'm going to say that
visualizing outliers in numeric features
of star
data so
visualizing the
outliers that's what I'm doing in what
in
numeric features of star type now after
this what I want to
do um I want to give color to this I
want to give weight to this and also
font size to it so I'll be giving color
equals to let's say a black color let's
say a black color is going to work well
if not I'll be changing this I'll also
try to change the font
size not the phont wa to
bold and lastly I'll be uh
also playing with the font size is 15
hopefully it works perfectly
fine
yeah this is good right maybe I can
change this to some different color but
I guess this white and black combination
looks good it's pretty much simple and
straightforward I guess I'll be going
with this right again if you want to add
any kind of different kind of
visualizations according to you you can
surely go ahead and try to change
anything you want okay but I guess this
is fine for me so I'll be simply going
ahead and save this figure pl. saave fig
and say that this is boxplot dop PNG and
also give this box plot with respect to
start
time and now run this and hopefully
we'll be getting this saved over here
I'll refresh this okay yeah I'll refresh
this okay see it's coming out of this
particular directory why because I did
not give the base directory right it's
going by default on the session storage
I don't want to do that so I'll delete
this
file come back over here and give base
directory
and then concatenate it with this thing
and I I guess now it will be working
fine so this kind of things will happen
with you also if you're coding it's just
that you need to minimize any kind of
error that you might be seeing and get
the things done the way you want right
and now let's go ahead and visualize the
box plots that we have created just in
order to check everything is fine see
yeah that's the kind of output that we
are getting
right so that's what we have got for the
box plots
and uh yeah that's pretty much about
this particular video now in the next
video what we are going to do is we're
going to look into one more type of
graph called as line graph or line chart
so I'll see you in that particular
video so far we have seen how we can
create a bar graph and also the box plot
now let's look into some different type
of visualization which is called as line
plot so it basically takes some of the
data points in your data and simply
connects them with a line okay so it's
going to be helpful for Us in order to
visualize some of the patterns that are
present in all the kind of numeric
features that we are having in our data
set so let's get into the video and
understand how we can get these things
done all right so now let's assume that
we want to create the line plots for
each and every numeric feature so what
we are trying to do is uh in the outlier
what we did with respect to Star type
what's the distribution of the
temperature Luminosity radius and
absolute magnitude we got this kind of
median values for each and every classes
and also the interqual range and all of
this kind of outliers that we wanted to
spot right you can surely now go ahead
and remove this kind of outliers if you
want but our purpose is just to create
some visualizations and find some
observations on top of that so from this
box blot we can say that in the
Luminosity we are having most of the
outliers so you need to uh try to like
you know remove this outliers or try to
do something through which you can
minimize the effects of outliers right
but now what I'm trying to do with the
help of my line plot
is to connect let's say for temperature
only okay we are not talking about
anything else let's just focus on
temperature I want to connect my this
point with this point then this point
with this point with a line and then see
try to observe if any kind of pattern is
being formed or not that's the kind of
logic that I want to build now again I
want to do this for all the kind of uh
data that we are having that is a
numeric type so for this numeric
features I want to create this line
plots again I'll be using a for loop
with the help of of subplot but now at
the same time I'll also be showing you
that how you can use function in order
for anyone who is reading your code or
even for that matter if you are reading
your code after some time it's much more
readable and more convenient to your
eyes okay it's better that we use a
function all of this you'll be
understanding over
here so let's get started with this so
what I'm trying to do over here is I'm
trying to create a simple line plot I
can do this with respect to PLT do plot
okay next thing is spare plot we are
going to do that in the next video but
right now let's focus on this PLT do
plot now what do I want to plot let's
say for example I want to plot the
temperature so star
DF and now I can give the dot iog I want
all the rows that is present in the
First Column that is my temperature
column and simply plot it let's see what
kind of output do we get also I can do
pl. show so that we are not getting this
kind of output
I can hide those outputs by using pl.
show all right so yeah let's just wait
for a while this is the kind of output
see this is the kind of pattern that
we're getting okay now it depends on
some kind of task our job is to create
visualizations and give some
observations then how let's say in data
science in machine learning how can
people use this kind of uh observations
and create something out of it create
some kind of automation stuff with
respect to machine learning deep
learning any kind of data science
project for that matter right so this is
the kind of pattern that we want to get
for each and every numeric column
temperature radius and all of those
right so what I'm going to do is I'm
again going to take the help of
subplot and now this time what I'll be
doing I'll be having four different rows
and one column so four comma 1 and I'll
also be changing the index with the help
of I I'll be again having this kind of
for Loop for I in range of four so it's
going to go from 0 to three I'll also
select this thing and press tab to give
this kind of indentation over there and
uh yeah we have given an indent we are
having the space everything looks good I
need to change this zero to
I I guess everything is going to be fine
I need to remove this BL do show I'll
bring out of this for Loop and see how
it looks
like okay this is the kind of thing it's
looking like as of now uh I can also
change this kind of colors for every
graph I can give a title to this and I
can customize it the way I want but a
very basic graph I have in front of me
right so I can give this kind of PLT do
title the same way that we had done in
our previous code that is stard DF do
columns and then uh
I and I can also give a color to this
kind of title let's say red
and at the same time I can also adjust
the figure size PLT do figure what kind
of figure size do I want let's try fix
size is equal
to 15 comma 8 let's say what what
happens so I guess this is good right in
terms of visualization this is looking
good but now if I want to do one more
magic over here with the help of subplot
what I can do is I want to adjust the
layout that I'm having I can use PLT do
tight
layout and then if I try to look it
hopefully it's going to give us a better
layout as compared to what we are having
currently okay it's automatically see
going to adjust the spaces between this
kind of AIS that we have drawn and
that's how it's looking now at the same
time I also want to change the colors of
each and every plot that we are seeing
so for that what I can do is I can
create a list of colors over here okay
let's say color
equals to now let's say because I'm
having four different plots to uh draw I
want to understand that what kind of
colors I can use now again you need to
have this kind of idea with respect to
what kind of colors that mat plot lab is
giving you I'll be using again some of
my favorite colors like royal blue gold
San green something like that okay you
can choose your own colors royal blue
let's say
gold then again green is not something
that I like I like lme okay so lime
andan is something that I'll be having
lme
andan I could have also drawn
magenda
Nan anything that you like I'm just
trying to give you some different kind
of colors that are available now in
place of this plot I'm going to give
this kind of parameter of color is equal
to colors of I so what it's going to do
in every time in every iteration the
value of I is going to start from zero
and all the way up to three so when
there is a okay there is some kind of an
error automatic saving fail don't worry
click on this show diff and click on
Save changes and it's going to
automatically save everything for you
the weight should be all right yeah
great so now what this is doing it's
trying to get access of the royal blue
when the value of I is zero is going to
get the excess of gold when the value of
I is one similarly lime when I is 2 and
three when uh sorry and magenta when the
I is value three okay so that's the kind
of thing that I want and now if I try to
see how it works let's see hopefully
everything is good okay it's giving me
an error what's the error
menta okay there is a wrong
spelling hopefully this is the correct
spelling yeah see now how beautiful this
plot is looking like right I can also
give a subtitle if I want I can give it
anywhere okay it's not compulsory I give
it on the top I could give it anywhere
pl. subtitle
visualizing the
distribution of numeric
features something like this let's say
I'm giving a color of
black the same thing that we did above
okay I like this kind of black and white
combination if I'm choosing that then
font size is let's say
15 and uh let's see if I want to give
anything else after running this code
yeah I also change this to bold right
the weight of this text to
bold weight is equal to
bold maybe I can also try to increase
the font size if I want okay I guess
this is looking pretty much cool maybe I
can try to decrease this 15 to 12 maybe
that can be giving us a better
visualization so yeah this is this is
much more better right so yeah this is
the kind of output that we have received
this is the kind of pattern that we are
having line by line for the temperature
Luminosity radius and absolute magnitude
now it's job of machine learning
engineers and data analysts that like
you know they find something useful from
this and get something done for any kind
of application they're trying to build
right now in this program we are trying
to focus how to develop this kind of
visualizations and yeah that's about
this particular thing but now let's say
I want to convert this whole thing into
what I want to convert this thing into a
function now how can I do this how can I
convert this in the format of functions
I can simply cut this
thing come up over here let's say I'm
defining a function called line
subplot it's going to take some kind of
inputs and I'm going to paste everything
over
there okay see first of all I am giving
this I so I'm going to give I at the
same time I'm also giving my star DF
right so I'm going to give Star DF also
to as an input I'm also giving uh colors
as input so let's say that I'm giving
colors over here as input I guess all of
this is going to work fine so I've
defined a function that's going to give
me a subplot it's going to give me a
plot for different values of I from the
iog also give me a title and I guess
everything is going to look good
so over here I'm going to Simply call
line
subplot and give the input of star DF
then what was it colors and I the value
of I right and hopefully we are getting
the same output I guess there is some
kind of a yeah spelling mistake
subplot yeah now if I'm running this I
hope everything is working the way we
had got in the previous step yes it's
just the same right let's if you want to
have some kind of a gap between this of
things how you can do it you can do that
with the help of let's say a new line
character over
here
okay and yeah see now you're having a
good amount of gap between that so this
is the kind of thing that you have done
in this video now I'll see you in the
next video and we'll be creating some
kind of pair
plots hi guys welcome to this video of
module 2 where I'm going to teach you
the concept of pair plot and how you can
easily create that with the help of
cbond Library so let's get into
it all right guys now what we are going
to do is we are going to learn about one
more visualization and understand what
kind of information we can fetch out of
that kind of visualization and again
save it like what we have been doing for
the above
plots I guess I again forgotten to save
this anyway I'll be doing it very
quickly I'll be giving Bas directory and
the name let's call it as line
subplot
PNG okay and it's always our duty guys
that we go ahead and always cross check
the output over
here okay if I just open
this at times it might be that like you
know it's looking very good over here
but it's not looking good over here so
you need to cross check before uh
extracting all this kind of information
all right so this looks good and again
once again if I'm just trying to open
this see it
properly
actually this is looking just incredible
okay to be very honest this is the kind
of power of python by writing only this
few lines of code okay this few lines of
code you have created some beautiful
things right with the help of this few
lines of code and now one more thing
that I want you guys to pay attention to
is that I am not giving any kind of
comments as of now because I am
explaining you these things while coding
along right so what I want you to do is
different person will be able to comment
a particular code in a different way so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
provide a code that is this whole
notebook with the proper comments but I
want you to go ahead and comment it by
yourself on the basis of your
understanding what do you understand by
this particular line what was the
purpose of creating uh this kind of
function one person can simply go ahead
and write that it's improving the
readability of the code so it's better
that we convert this whole kind of step
into a function like we did not do this
for the previous step over here we did
not change it like this right now you
can also go ahead and try to convert
this into a function right it's going to
improve the readability of this code but
all of that things is up to you and even
for this function you can give a very
good description with the help of
multi-line comments give the information
about what this kind of function is
doing then give the information with
respect to the input arguments and what
is it going to return at the end so all
these kind of things you can mention in
this uh multiple line comments right so
yeah that's how how we are using all the
kind of things that we have learned in
our first module and implementing it
over here isn't it just
amazing yeah anyway coming now back to
pair plot let's try to understand what
is it all about okay so what is the main
purpose of creating a par plot or was it
it what it's going to do let's say that
I'm going to take temperature for
example what it's going to do par plot
it's going to take a temperature column
and it's going to compare with all all
the respective other AES that with
respect to temperature how Luminosity is
weing with respect to temperature how
radius is weing and all the other
columns that we are having okay for that
matter how temperature is weing with
temperature even that kind of data we'll
be getting with the help of pair plot
and by default you are going to get this
kind of relation in the form of scatter
plot you are just going to get dot dot
dot dot dot if you want you can also
create a line plot but by default pair
plot is going to be in the format of
scatter plot okay all of this
information I have written over here and
now because you are seeing that there
are a lot of kind of combinations that
we are creating right temperature with
all the kind of other columns including
itself the Luminosity with all the other
columns itself so there are multiple
subplot that we'll have to get right
multiple axis in a subplot now a good
thing about pair plot of c bond is that
it's going to get you rid of all this
kind of pain of creating subplot and all
these kind of functions and these kind
of things that's the power of using c
bond it's going to do it by default for
us and we are just going to enjoy the
output that we are getting but at the
same time it's also having some of the
drawback and the drawback is that if
there are a lot of columns just imagine
the type of like you know combinations
that you will be getting and then you
will be creating it into a subplot right
and then you'll be getting a plots it
would be a really timec consuming task
but thankfully for our data we are just
having seven columns it's still going to
take some significant amount of time but
not as compared to like you know how it
will take for let's say 30 columns 20
columns right so that's one thing you
need to keep in mind so now let's first
of all go ahead and try to visualize the
uh PA plot with the help of
cbone uh PA plot is something I want now
I just need to give the whole data frame
because it's going to take each and
every column and do everything by itself
okay let's see the output that we're
going to get and I'm also going to show
this thing let's see what kind of thing
do we get
okay as you can see itself right now
it's it's taking a lot of time to create
this plot right because still there are
seven different columns and it's taking
all these kind of possible combinations
okay so this is the kind of output that
we are getting the temperature column is
getting compared with its same
temperature thing then temperature thing
is also getting compared with Luminosity
then just like that temperature is also
getting compared with the radius
absolute magnitude and star type okay
all of this numeric column okay it won't
be taking uh this kind of categorical
column which is of the type object it's
just going to take the numeric type of
data that is either integer or float
okay it's not going to take into account
of this last two columns that we were
having in the object type okay so yeah
this is the kind of correlations that we
are able to fetch that let's say with
respect to temperature let's say what is
this particular column this is absolute
magnitude right so for this you can see
that we can clearly see that as absolute
magnitude will increase the temperature
is going to fall this is some kind of
observation that we are able to make
right so yeah this is the kind of output
that we get with the help of pair plot
now one more thing that I can do is I
can visualize this data point with
respect to let's say some kind of U what
it means this kind of parameter that I
can give over here in subplot let's say
I just need to give the name of column
over here
spectral class okay what it's going to
do there are again multiple categories
within the spectral class so where is
each and every category going to belong
to this kind of PA plot all of this kind
of things you will be able to see you
can go ahead and create this kind of PA
plot with respect to different kind of
use present in the data see now that's
that's what I was talking about there is
a Class M Class B Class A this kind of
data and see all of these kind of points
are being marked differently wherever
there is purple it's with respect to
class
wherever that you can see the dark
yellowish kind of thing that's Class B
so that's the power of U you can change
this kind of U with any kind of
different categorical data that you are
having uh okay and maybe star color is
something that you would like to go
ahead and look forward to so yeah that's
what we are seeing right in the same
data because we did not count let's say
spectral class over here we are giving
that kind of data with the help of U
parameter That's The Power of cbor Now
again what I'm trying to see over here
is I'm trying to
change I'm trying to change this whole
background lt.
style. use to
dark dark
background okay and then see how the
output is looking like and maybe I would
like to also see the previous graph if
how this would look like in a dark uh
output okay and I also change this color
to let's say some different kind of
thing but right now let's say how the
out is going to look like okay that's
the output that we are having I can
maybe run this one for one more
time because you know right while
changing the style we need to run our
code twice and what I'll do is I'll also
go ahead and run this code I don't need
to again set the background to dark
because it's already set for me right
now okay I don't need to change it again
to dark
background so yeah I guess this is the
thing that we have saved I'll again uh
cross check it by saving it okay I
haven't saved saved it so PLT do saave
fig what am I going to do I'm going to
save it in base directory and the same
thing you know right the name of this
plot will
be what it will be pairplot
PNG
right now there is a parameter over here
in par plot again called kind okay this
kind by default is set to scatter as you
can see over here it's highlighted you
can change this to the different kind of
like you know plot that you would like
to see okay scatter is fine for me so I
guess I'll just keep it as it is I won't
be changing but yeah that's something I
wanted to show you guys but now let's
just goe and save this figure and then
also look into the output if it's done
in a proper way or not all right
guys so yeah these are this kind of
beautiful visualizations that you are
creating with the help of python that's
literally something that you can go
ahead patch it out from this Google
collab and attach into your research
papers or reports that you are creating
you can mention about this kind of
details your observations and give
evidence to that with the help of this
kind of visualizations that you have
created
right so yeah we are done with this
let's look into this thing yeah P plot
is
created hopefully there are no errors
it's looking good right it's looking
beautiful yeah you can see this kind of
plots right for the same columns like
for example radius versus radius is
giving this kind of thing right
Luminosity versus Luminosity is giving
this kind of thing similarly like over
here star type and star type so yeah
that for the middle part that's the type
of output that you're getting and
everywhere else you're getting the
scatter plot this is really very
beautiful to be
honest so yeah that's that's about the
pair plot and I'll also go ahead and try
to run this once or I should say twice
not sure let's go ahead and check I
guess this is looking even more much
more better right as compared to to
previous white one and I also change the
color of this to
white or let's say t
pink let's see how it's looking
now hopefully better yes it's just
amazing just
amazing great so I'll also go ahead and
cross check this one line plot line of
plot and see if the changes have been
saved yes this is much more better man
this is just amazing so yeah now I'll be
seeing you in the next video where we
are going to create this kind of a plot
called HR diagram okay something like
this so yeah stay tuned for
that hey everyone so welcome to one of
the most lengthiest video you will see
in this entire program so in this
particular module this is the final
ultimate visualization that you are
creating with respect to this star data
that we are dealing with so this is
about creating an HR diagram what is HR
diagram I'll be talking about that in
this particular video but then how you
can create this with the data set that
you are having and compare it with the
actual HR diagrams so that you are able
to appreciate that what kind of skills
that you have learned over here indeed
the video is going to be super lengthy
but it's going to worth each and every
minute that you're going to spend on it
so let's get into it
guys all right so this is my
particularly favorite part to create the
HR diagram the reason behind that is I
personally love this kind of diagram
okay uh it's because like you know how
amazingly we are able to categorize or
like you know classify this kind of
different Stars depending on its
properties that is temperature absolute
magnitude spectral class and also the
Luminosity right now you need to
understand one thing that all the kind
of previous graphs that we have created
or the visualizations that we have
created all of them can be always
created if you're having this kind of
tabular data now we are able to create
an HR diagram because we are having the
data of star and its respective
properties that is temperature and
absolute magnitude right now we are
going to use both of this to create this
kind of a diagram so now because we are
having access to this two data only then
we are able to create the HR diagram you
won't always be able to create this
diagram unlike all the other graphs you
will always be able to create this kind
of
graphs right so that's something that
you need to know before we get started
okay so yeah keeping this kind of things
in mind that because over here we are
dealing with the star type data set and
that's the reason because it's
properties that is temperature and
absolute magnitude is available to us of
real stars that's why we'll be able to
create something like this okay so let's
get into it now because I want to plot
temperature on the x-axis and the
absolute magnitude on the y- axis we be
requiring its values from the data frame
so how we can fetch this values from the
data frame so what what I can do is I
can create a variable called as
temperature and from the start DF I can
store all the values of temperature okay
in this temperature variable how can I
do it by calling dot values on top of
this column okay so on on the left side
of this dot what are we doing from the
Star DF we are fetching this column of
temperature and now all the values that
are present in that column I'm using dot
values so what it's doing let's go and
try to
print it's going to create an array of
these values that are present in this
column as you can see over here array
what is array array is just one of the
other data structure that we have in
Python that's used to store this kind of
data like this okay just like list as
you can see right but now how do I know
if this is a list or an array I can just
go ahead
and type this type functionality on this
temperature and we can see that it's a
numpy array n dimensional array right
for now you just need to know that it's
just a kind of a list you can think of
but with more much more functionalities
okay but anyway now we have uh extracted
the values of temperature just like that
I'm also going to do it for absolute
magnitude and star
DF
absolute
magnitude dot values okay now because
I'm having access to both of these
values I can simply go ahead and create
a scatter plot now what is the reason of
the scatter plot if I show you this in
this HR diagram you are trying to plot a
specific Star by giving its x coordinate
and y coordinate for each and every Star
you just need x coordinate and y
coordinate and you simply plot it so for
that what I am doing is the
functionality is called scatter okay if
you use PLT do plot it's going to give
you a line plot okay just like what we
did over
here if you try to use this PLT dotplot
okay what is it going to do it's going
to create this kind of lines we don't
want to connect the Stars we just want
to plot the stars as it is and that's
what we are using that is scatter plot
on x-axis I'm giving
temperature and then on y- axis I'm
giving absolute
magnitude and then I'm just using PL
show to Simply get the output without
any kind of text written on top of the
figure so hopefully everything is
working the way we want and see the
output no it's not working right now
there is a specific reason behind that
okay we wanted some kind of parts to be
there on the top part as because we can
see over here the hyper Giants and the
super Giants are existing over here
right but there is nothing over here
it's completely empty the reason behind
that is look at the the temperature and
the absolute magnitude
axis this values of temperature are
starting from a higher value and going
all the way down to a lower value
similarly like that we are also seeing
in the absolute magnitude we are
starting from a higher value and then
going up by decreasing the value that's
completely opposite to what we are
seeing in our M lab output we are
starting from a smaller value going all
the way up to a higher value and just
like that in our y- axis we are starting
from a negative value going all the way
up to positive value so in order to get
this kind of nature of the graph I need
to invert my Axis okay I need to invert
my x-axis as well as the y axis and the
way that we can do it with the help of
met plot Li I can use
PLT and then GCA what is GCA it's giving
me get current AIS okay so whatever we
are doing right now is on an axis right
so we are getting this current axis and
then there is a property called
Inver and then
x-axis and then I can also copy this
line paste this for y- axis and let's
see now how it looks
like see this is what we expect this is
where the main sequence stars are then
on the bottom part we are having red wve
Brown wve over here we are having wide
barves then on the top we are having
super Giants and the hyper Giants this
is what we expect right now there is one
thing that is really very different we
are not adding any kind of colors we are
not adding any kind of sizes but now to
add this kind of functionalities in your
graph what you will need for each and
every Star there are some unique
properties right some unique values of X
some unique value of y and along with
that it's going to have some respective
color depending on what type of star it
is it's also going to have a specific
size and also a label given to that
particular Star as for example white bar
so what I'm going to do over here is I'm
going to create a whole lot of a python
Dictionary what is python dictionary
it's another data structure that exist
in Python just like list just like array
there is one more thing that is called
as python dictionary now what is the
reason like you know what's the main
reason we are using this python
dictionary you will be understanding in
a while it's going to take a lot of time
for me to like you know show you the
whole dictionary so what I'm doing is
I'm simply uh pasting that part that I
have copied and simply uh having it over
here okay I'm also going to get rid of
this values because Ive also pasted it
over over here okay so on the top this
this two lines basically temperature and
absolute magnitud you already know how
did we get this but now what is the star
type right so there is a column called
star type right in our data frame and
I'm simply converting this into the
values it means if I try to visualize
star type okay if I go ahead and print
this it's going to be the list of the
Zer 1 0 1 4 4 all these kind of things
right we know that zero stands for brown
valve one stands for red valve five
stands for hyper giant so on and so for
so now I have
also created this kind of an access to
all of the specific data points that are
present in our data frame so now our
main motive is we are going to take each
and every individual star that are from
one from the first star all the way up
to the 240th star we are going to itate
1 by one we going to get access to X and
Y coordinates at the same same time what
is the star type of that particular star
Now by getting an exess of what kind of
star it is is it of type zero type 1
type two type three type four or type
five I have created a whole python
dictionary form that so let's say if the
star type is
zero then these are its respective
properties if the star type is one then
here are its respective properties this
is what we create in Python in
dictionaries actually it is python
dictionaries are made
of key value pairs what it means this is
the key and this is the value of that
keyy so in order to get exess of the
value you need key so what I'm trying to
say is that if I want to see Star types
okay and now in this St R types if I'm
giving zero so now zero is the key right
if I run this it's going to give me its
respective value right now again the
value is in the format of dicture if you
can see there is a curly brackets right
and then there is a key and a value
Associated to that there is a key and a
value key and a value so I have created
a dictionary within a dictionary right
so the reason behind that is let's say
that the first star is of class zero
okay type zero now I'm going to call
this as the property of star zero star
type zero and now if I want to get an
idea what is the label of the star I
simply need to pass this key it's going
to give me BR bar if I want to check
what is the color that we are going to
give to this particular star class that
is brown what is the size that we are
going to use to plot this kind of
dwarves it's going to be size of 30 and
then what is the marker that we're going
to use to display on the graph what are
this markers over here you are getting
this kind of circles by default okay you
could have changed this to cross you
could have changed this to a DOT right
you could have done a lot of different
markers that are available
in M plotly currently we are choosing
only two types of markers if it's a
dwarf star we are going to use marker as
a DOT if it's a main sequence star or
any kind of giant star then we are going
to use a marker as o that's the kind of
idea that we are having by default
marker is O as you can see okay but now
the whole idea that I want you to
understand is that let's say in the it
region out of all the 240 Stars we are
on let's say index
two so what are what is the star
type on index 2 let's check that it's
zero but now let's see if I'm on index
100 let's see over there the star type
is four so now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to change this zero to the
star type of 100 that is 4 in short
right and now if I take a look into its
property of marker it's going to be o
right and if I take a look into its
label it's going to be super Giants see
just like that if I want to get an exess
of the color I can just do this by
passing in the color and that's more
than enough I guess you might have
understood what I'm trying to say I'm
trying to come up with a logic that if
I'm trying to create a scatter plot and
for each and every individual point that
I'll be plotting I want to give this
color label size and marker how can I do
it with the help of this python
dictionary that we have created for Star
types that's exactly how we are going to
do that okay
so again if I want to show you what is
the length of the star
type it must be 240 right so in this
star type there are 240 different values
right starting from zero star type let's
just visualize it for one more time see
0 0 0 1 1 1 so all of these things are
for 240 times so I'm going to itate from
the first index all the way up to last
index and then whatever is the value of
star type I'm going to get its
respective properties with the help of
this
syntax so that's the idea that I'm going
to implement with the help of a for Loop
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
create a for Loop in the range
of this 240 values okay so l of star
type because we know that length of star
type is what 40 right 240 I mean right
so now let's say in future if someone is
updating this CSV file if we are having
a lot more data as compared to 240 Stars
it will be very Dynamic for us to write
this length of star type instead of 240
right so that's the reason that I have
written this length of star so now
what's going to happen the value of I is
going to start from zero and go all all
the way up to 239 right and now I'm
going to plot this scatter diagram for
each and every Star so the temperature
on the index zero and its respective
value of absolute magnitude on index Z
is the first St that I'm going to plot
then when the value of I will change to
one it will be temperature one comma
absolute magnitude one so H and every
Star that I'm going to extract from the
temperature and the absolute magnitude I
creating this XY coordinate and then I'm
simply going to plot it in the scatter
plot but now at the same time I'm also
giving the properties of the
size
color
marker and the
label okay now I can extract this
properties just like how I have
explained over here so I'm going to copy
this
part and store it into a variable called
as
properties okay but now I need to change
this to I because I don't want Star type
that is present on index 100 I want to
automatically change if the value of I
is changing so when the value of I is
zero it means on the first row what is
the star type with respect to that give
me the
properties right and then when the value
of I is 100 at that particular Point
what is the star type get me its
respective properties right so that's
the kind of idea that we have done and
after that if you want to call its
respective properties of size color
marker and label how you can do it I I'm
going to give
properties and I'm going to write size
over
here right size color marker label right
I'm just going to copy this
code paste it for color change this size
to color and for marker again I'm going
to paste this change this to marker and
for the label again paste it and change
this to label
so our idea is done hopefully everything
is going to work fine let's go ahead and
try to test
this okay I'm just going to get rid of
this extra things because we don't
require it anymore and if I go ahead and
look into this output I don't need any
kind of Extra
Spaces I'll get rid of this right so see
this is the kind of output that we're
getting right all the hyper giant super
Giants are getting colored then this are
the kind of mean sequence Stars these
are the red veres these are Brown dves
These are white dves all of them are
what we expect in the HR diagram it's in
the same exact way right that's what we
expect
right but now there is one thing that we
are not able to give any kind of label
right we are not able to see any kind of
label that this is a white bar this is a
main sequence star right we are not able
to see these kind of things the reason
behind that is because we haven't given
Legend in met. Li you give this Legend
in order to display this label so if I
run this
code just stick around with me because
there are quite some more things we are
doing in this specific video because
there is a problem associated with this
command okay I'll be explaining that to
you see that's the problem I was talking
about now for each and every Star that
is for 240 Stars whatever is the star
type it's going to give a label to it
and assign in the graph itself now
that's not something that I'm looking
forward to if my brown dwarf has
appeared once I don't want to label it
again because I know that this kind of
stars are going to be brown W then this
type of stars are my red valves right if
it has appeared once I don't want to
appear it for more than one time so now
I am going to come up with a very good
logic that's going to help me solve this
issue okay now the reason that I'm able
to explain all of these things very
fluently it's not that because I'm a
very good programmer everything comes to
me in just a second it's not like that
it's years of practice at the same time
I have already done this kind of I have
already solved this problem okay took me
some time it's not that on the spot I
got this things okay so it's completely
fine it's not that everyone is going to
get it on the spot if you are especially
a beginner it will take some time right
so try to digest the things that I'm
going to explain right now okay so so
see what I'm going to do is I'm trying
to create two
things this requires some kind of an
idea of how Legend works okay so let me
explain you that first Legends basically
take one input called as
handles what are these handles these
handles are nothing but each and every
plot that you're trying to give okay so
let's just call this thing as X's okay
and I'm just also going to press tabs to
shift it to the right and I guess one
space back should do right this is
looking
good uh yeah this is looking better yeah
now what I'm going to do is in place of
this
handles I'm going to write labels now
what is this labels I again not created
any kind of labels so I'm going to
create a set called labels labels is
equal to set at the same time I'm going
to create exess empty
list so what what I have done I have
created two empty data structures one
that is a list and one that is a set the
unique concept about the set is that if
there are more than one thing that is
repeated okay there is a one thing that
is repeated for more than one time it's
going to consider it for only one time
so what I'm trying to say is let's say
I'm having set of 1 comma 1 comma 1 see
what is the output going to be okay it's
going getting this kind of an error
because we we have done a syntax problem
I'm going to come out of this and then
I'm going to give this see the output is
only one output is only one no matter
how many times one is repeated it will
always give the output of one so that's
the kind of logic that we are having
over here okay we will be keeping on
adding the labels over here and make
sure that labels are appearing only once
okay and then for which plot I want to
give this AIS label okay for whichever
plot I want to give this label I'll be
adding that data point to this
particular AIS and labels it might be
getting a bit overwhelming so let me go
ahead and show you what I'm trying to
say okay what I have done till now I
have created this kind of a scatter plot
and that's what you are seeing but now
this kind of Legends are looking very
ugly right so we are trying to sort that
problem okay by calling these two things
now I'm going to give an if statement
now what is this if statement all about
if the label that we are getting for the
star type okay so from this
properties if the label value if the
label
value is not present in
labels okay only then you are going to
give this x ax is equal to this kind of
graph and then after that what you are
going to do is this is really important
you are going to add this AIS to this
AIS and then also add the label because
it was not present in this particular
set because it's not present you are
going to add it okay so what I'm doing
is I'm going to first of all add this ax
to this AIS list how can I do it I can
do it with this AIS command that get me
that list which I'm trying to add some
new Val values so in the list you can
add some new data point with the help of
this upend command okay the upend
command that you can see okay for some
reason I'm not able to click it yeah
anyway I'm successful in clicking it
anyway so now exist the in empty list I
want to append what this ax this is the
handle okay this is the not the handle
actually but the x's and the handles are
the labels labels that I want to display
so what am I appending over here I am
appending this ax okay so what's going
to happen for every
iteration if the label that is present
for the respective star type is not
already present over here then what you
do you create this
axis and that axis what you're going to
do you're going to pass it onto this
particular uh list that we have created
that's an empty list and after that what
you're going to do is you're going to
add a label to this set how am I going
to do this I'm going to achieve this
with the help
of
labels dot not append anymore it's going
to be add directly that's how this kind
of functions are built okay foret it's
add for L it's append and now I'm going
to add the label that is
properties and
label I hope the idea is getting clear
it will be clear once the output is in
in front of you okay now let's say if
this label already exists in label then
I don't want to add label to this kind
of set then I I don't want to add okay
then I don't even want to create this
kind of exis in that case what I want to
do
is I'm going to give this else block and
simply create my scatter plot without
adding any kind of x's or any kind of
that stuff okay so yeah that's the kind
of logic that we have created I'm going
to press shift tab shift tab yeah this
is looking good so now we are expecting
the output to be very
decent it's not going to be as ugly as
what we had seen okay we we have got an
error let's try to look into the error
it's saying that string object has no
attribute get underscore label let's see
where did we got this error this error
is over here right it's because the
labels right it should be labels let me
check this to AIS and see how it
works if the x is going to work then
yeah I would have done an error yeah I
would have I had done an error actually
we had to store the AIS okay what is
happening so this axis is giving you
this kind of an command that okay for
this particular point that you have
plotted you want to display this label
right and that Legend is automatically
having this kind of labels right that's
the kind of mistake that I was making
Legend is already having access to all
the labels that's the reason why we were
seeing Brown WF multiple times red WF
multiple times right so that's not a
problem the problem is that if the AIS
is present over here if I show you the
AIS list let's go ahead and see
it see now all of this is a path
collection for each and every point
there might be six 1 2 3 3 4 5 six what
is the reason of this six because we are
having six different categories
right so for each and every point we are
having this kind of AIS now what I'm
trying to do is I want to show the label
of
Legend only for those respective AES or
else I don't want to show it so that's
the kind of thing that we have done over
here and hopefully now it's making sense
and now obviously you can beautify this
plot by customizing by like you know
adding
uh xais y axis and all that kind of
stuff and uh I can simply go ahead and
copy paste this thing because I've
already done this for a lot of times I
copied that data and I'm simply going to
paste it over
here okay and let's see now how the
output looks
like and now let's see if you're also
interested to add the data of sun okay
in this whole thing I guess the diagram
is pretty much small I'll also increase
the Fig figure size over
here figure size how I can do this with
the help of PLT right figure and then
fix
size I'm giving my figure size as let's
say 10 comma 6 I guess this is going to
be
fine okay now I just want you to realize
that even after having a lot of
experience in Python this kind of
problems happen okay you need to go to
the documentation and make things fine
as a python developer it's our duty to
go Ahad and make things right depending
because we having access to all the kind
of documents okay but right now I was
able to solve this error because of the
like you know the output of the error
that we had got anyway the important
part that I want to convey is that you
should not be ever be frightened if
you're getting errors okay if you're
getting errors it's okay you should know
how to solve those errors that's it if
you are good at that you are good to
like you know encounter any kind of
problems in your
life specific to uh at least the Python
Programming questions okay but anyway uh
if we are talking about
this I'll just ignore this thing it's
quite yeah disturbing yeah anyway this
is the kind of output that we have got
right for the HR
diagram now one last thing is let's try
to add the data for the Sun and see that
where exactly on this HR diagram that
Sun is going to be looking like okay so
for that what I'll be doing is I'll be
copying this data that I'm having for
the Sun and simply add it into our
code so I'm coming back to our code I'm
going to give this kind of a title I
mean the comment
adding data for
sun now what is
this I'm creating one more xes
specifically for sun because I also want
to append this kind of thing and
visualize in my output this is the
temperature value I've gone to Google
and got this kind of values this is
temperature this is uh absolute
magnitude this is the size that I'm
keeping color is yellow marker is O and
label is sun right and I'm simply also
adding this AIS that we have created for
the Sun and I'm also appending this
labels as Sun okay now that's the whole
point you will be automatically seeing
that somewhere over here in the main
sequence we know that sun is a mean
sequence star so somewhere along this
part our sun should be added just like
this whatever kind of star you are
interested to know about right you go
and find its property on Star and try to
plot it and see where it's going to be
in the graph for us sun is over here
right that's where the sun is and even
in the legend you are able to see that
sun has been added separately apart from
all of this we are also adding a data
point of sun isn't it just amazing how
we have created this kind of whole thing
by getting ideas of python that we have
learned in our first module and then
again some few things that I have taught
in this particular video about how you
can create an empty list and empty set
and then how you can add data to it the
whole idea over here was this thing okay
if you don't know how this kind of
things work then you will need some kind
of experience of how set and this kind
of list works but the only thing that
you need to know over here is that we
have created this kind of empty list and
empty set to store the exis that is with
respect to the plot that we are making
over here we are trying to store it over
here so that with respect to that plot
I'm able to show the label that is
present in the legend command in this
Legend Command right so yeah that's the
end of this particular video I hope you
have enjoyed creating your own uh HR
diagram right for the 240 Stars if you
can see I have also given this kind of a
dynamic way of writing this so that in
future if star type is uh changing its
length let's say we are adding more data
to this existing CSU file then you will
be able to create for let's say 500
Stars if there are more addition to the
data right so yeah these are all the
kind of plots that we have generated but
I have not saved it right my common not
common common so my common mistake is I
always forget to save the figure size I
mean the figure right that we have
generated so save figure how am I saving
it I'm giving my base
directory and the name HR
diagram yeah finally running this and
I'll be also checking this before we end
this video if this has been done fine or
not coming over here looking into the
star plots this is HR
diagram close
this see the beautiful plot right in
front of you right the reason I haven't
shown you how to do the title X label
and Y label because you have been doing
this for a couple of above plots right
in the Y label I have added the absolute
magnitude on the X label temperature
given respective font size and the color
as you know my favorite one is stab pink
so that's the color that I given for
them and for the title I'm giving the HR
diagram title and a dynamic way of
writing the title by giving the F string
font size is 15 and the color is royal
blue another my favorite color okay so
yeah that's about this particular video
guys I hope you have enjoyed this
one hey guys so welcome to the last
video of this particular module where
you are going to understand that how you
can download this visualizations that
you have created in module 2 and saved
it into a particular directory so now
how you can save that directory into
your system from Google collab notebook
so all of these things we'll be learning
in this particular video so let's get
into it
all right guys so now let's understand
that how we can go ahead and download
this star plots all the kind of
visualizations that we have created over
here from very Basics to very advanced
level of visualizations you can do this
with the help of because we are using
see Google collab there are some
specific ways in Google collab through
which you can do this the one that we
are going to do is I'm going to follow
this method that you can see it right
now on the screen okay the whole idea is
that from this google. cab I I'm going
to import files what are these files
these are the same files that you can
see over here everything that is over
here we are going to get access to this
with the help of this
files right now what I'm doing over here
the logic that has been implemented is
that I'm going to create a zip file out
of this folder okay if I just click on
this option there is no option to
directly download this folder right
there is no option like that so what I'm
going to do instead is to create a zip
file off it because zip files are
downloadable in Google collab so what
I'm doing I'm creating this ZIP
command and then I'm giving two
things which folder I want to zip I'm
just taking that particular folder
pasting that same thing over here and
just passing zip on top of that that
hey in this particular path this is
called content path in which the star
plots exist so in this particular
path I want to create a zip file that's
it and once the zip file will be created
it will automatically be downloaded by
giving this kind of input to this
download command Okay so this download
functionality exists in this file okay
so whatever is the file if you give the
path to download that file it will be
downloaded if I show it to you what's
going to happen so if I run this code
you will be able to see that a zip file
will be generated and now you are giving
this path in the download and
automatically you are seeing that this
kind of files have been zipped for us
and also downloaded into my system I
simply need to click on
this and if I show this to you this is
the content folder right inside which we
are having the star plots folder and see
here are everything that we need to know
okay ignore this particular thing for
example this is the star colors
visualization that we had generated
right if you want you can also obviously
increase the size and everything right
and then here is the HR diagram my
favorite diagram right it took the most
amount of time in the whole video
program overall program not just one
video right but yeah that's the that's
the kind of output that we have
generated so yeah now you can simply
attach this kind of thing in any kind of
research work that they're doing that
was the whole point that with the help
of a tabular data how you can create
this kind of visualizations in Python
with the help of Google colab and also
extract it into into your
system all right guys so it's time to
buid a farewell to our module 2 so over
here we used a tabular data set on Stars
data and created some amazing
visualizations with the help of mat lli
and seone Library we looked into some of
the different types of visualizations
like bar graph box plot line plot pair
plot and then eventually created a HR
diagram with respect to the scatter plot
and then how can we save this outputs
that we are creating and download it
into our particular system so all of
these things we have done so far and I
hope that you are enjoying each and
every bit of this particular program now
in the next module we going to jump into
some image visualizations and do some
amazing stuff over there so stay tuned
for that I'll see you in that next
module hey guys I welcome you all to the
third module of this program here you're
going to take one step forward where in
the second module you had performed the
visualizations on the tabular data
now we going to create visualizations on
the image data and therefore to start
with in this module we are going to
explain you what is the concept of an
image then what is fits file because
this is the file type through which you
are going to access the astronomical
images which you're going to perform
some kind of visualizations on top of
that then what is Sky View form how you
can fetch the data of Andromeda Galaxy
from astronomical surveys like sdss gmen
and DSS2 blue then how you can Implement
some of the pixel scaling methods on
this anoma galaxy visualize the pixel
distribution and lastly what is the
concept of Z scale interval in a library
called as astropy and why are we
specifically using it for this
particular program all of this is
covered in this particular module guys
so let's get into this module and I'll
see you in the next video where we are
going to talk about
image hey guys welcome to the second
video of module 3 where I'm going to
explain you the concept of digital
images in the format of pixels what are
grayscale images colorful images and a
lot more so let's get into
it all right guys so let us go ahead and
try to understand this concept about an
image so what is an image I'll be first
talking about how this kind of images
are formed and then what are some kind
of different things you need to
understand about it so talking about how
these kind of images are formed it's
kind of a puzzle if you think about it
okay let's say that you you are having
different kind of pieces of puzzles
which you are going to combine together
to form this kind of an image that's the
same kind of logic that we are going to
use in order to understand how this kind
of images are formed so this kind of
puzzle pieces which are like you know
coming together and forming this kind of
one final image this puzzle pieces are
nothing but the pixels this pixels are
combined together to form what we see as
an image over here so now what is this
kind of pixels right we know about the
puzzle pieces that there are some kind
of pieces which are joining together to
form this image but how do we know what
is a pixel so for that what I have done
is I just zoomed into this particular
image as much as possible but not over
here because Google cab is not allowing
me to zoom any further than this okay so
what I have done I have captured this
image I have pasted it into the paint
and on the paint I was able to zoom in
much further as compared to what Google
cab is allowing me so I got some kind of
information like this okay so this
particular part is being representing
the top left part of the image okay so
I'm zooming into it as much as possible
and this kind of small small squares you
are seeing right this is a small square
this is a small square this is a small
square so all of the small squares are
nothing but the pixels and see how these
kind of different pixels are there and
all of these pixels which are coming
together let's say you're just talking
about the first row of the small squares
all of these pixels are coming together
to define the width of this image just
like that there are also pixels over
here which are stacked up together in
this kind of a vertical line which is
giving us the information about the
height of this image at the same time
they are having some kind of different
shades of colors which are stored within
it some kind of bluish color is over
here some kind of very darker shade of
blue as compared to what are there in
the nearby pixels and similarly over
here it's talking about the brownish
colors over here it's talking about the
dark green kind of color right so all of
the small squares are hiding the
information about what kind of shade of
color is represented on that particular
location of an image so I hope a very
basic idea about how this kind of images
are formed is clear this kind of images
are the combination of this kind of
pixels and each of these pixels are
having some kind of information about
what is the shade of color represented
over here to show it into the output of
the image right so let's say this is a
piece of puzzle which is storing this
kind of detail this is a piece of
puzzles which is storing this kind of
color of that particular detail all of
these pieces of puzles are nothing but
the square shape but now based on this
kind of information of the shades of
color you're are going to create an
image that is something like
this right now they can combine together
to get the width and the height of the
image at the same time how do we know
about this kind of intensities of colors
now for that we need to understand how
these kind of images are form but I hope
the part of the pixel is clear that how
these kind of pixels come up together to
like you know what we see right now in
this particular image right now if we
talk about how this kind of intensities
of colors are coming into the picture
how do we know that what kind of shade
will be represented by what kind of part
in the image so to understand that
particular part
we need to talk about the sensor that
sensor is nothing but the camera that I
was talking about when I started this
particular video so let's say we are
having this camera and in this camera we
are having three different filters one
to capture the red light coming from
whatever is the source which sensor is
trying to capture similarly whatever is
the greenish kind of part that is being
captured will be done with the help of
green band filter and similarly for a
blue color whatever is the bluish part
over here you can see there's some kind
of a blue part there is a blue part over
here and also a blue part over here so
all of the light hitting to the sensors
coming from this kind of bluish part
will be filtered out with the help of
the green sorry the blue band filter
right so now what's going to happen we
know that typically all of these colors
that we see different kind of shades of
colors that we see are the formation of
like you know different kind of mixes of
red green and blue we know these things
from our very primary classes in school
right or in the art school art classes
right so now this kind of different
combinations of red green and blue will
be captured from this particular image
with the help of the S set that is
camera and how with the help of this
kind of green band filter Red Band
filter and the blue band filter now the
whole logic over here is the way that it
is being captured is with the help of
what kind of wavelength of light is
contributing to the red part of the
visible spectrum now I'm going into much
more technical terms let's not go into
that particular direction and talk about
in a very simple terms whatever light
that you are seeing over here is being
coming to the Sor if it's falling into
the red kind of region then that will be
filtered out with the help of Red Band
filter similarly for the green light and
the blue light and the output of this is
representated always into this kind of a
grayscale image
okay now if we talk about the image that
we are going to deal with throughout
this whole module is an 8bit integer
image now different kind of bit of
pixels uh stores different amount of
information okay so let's say I'm having
a comparison of an 8bit pixel to a 16bit
pixel more this kind of 8 Bit And 16bit
pixels more the combination of shades of
colors it can represent that's a very
simple idea about like you know 8bit
image and a 16bit image in 16bit images
you'll be able to represent a particular
color with a more amount of Shades okay
more amount of depth basically you'll be
able to get from an image right so if I
talk about the image that is an 8bit
image that we are going to deal with in
this whole module let's talk about that
so in that 8bit image all these pixel
values are going to range in between 0
to 255 to represent any kind of
information let's about the Redlight
coming from this particular image I mean
from this particular part and hitting on
the C answer if it's coming from the red
uh sources red light sources it's going
to be representated into different 256
sides and the values are going to be in
between 0 to 255 that's the whole
concept so 255 being the lighter part of
the whole image and the part which is
represented darker are closer towards
the zero side so what does this kind of
number 0 to 255 indicate so 8bit integer
image is going to give you 256 different
shades of a color maybe red green or
blue right so now if you going to
combine them red green and blue so 256
into 256 into 256 these are the possible
Shades you can get and form a whole
colorful image that you can see over
here okay if you increase this bits
let's say 16 bits per pixel then you are
having 2 to ^ of 16 multiplied by three
times to basically get even more shades
of colors as compared to an 8bit image
okay so that's that's an idea with
respect to this but now let's try to
observe that if I talk about this kind
of bluish part this is a blue part of an
image this is another blue part of an
image and now if I talk about blue band
filter it should be able to filter all
of this things and give a very high
value to it that is 255 the lighter part
of the blue band filter should be
representing the blue part so I'm having
this kind of uh blue part that is like
you know surrounded by potatoes over
here then on top of this kind of apples
we are having this right so if I try to
show you the output of the blue band you
can see that this part is light this
part is light right this whole part is
light as compared to the above images in
green band this part is darker this part
is darker in the Red Band see even this
part is darker and this part is darker
right so that's what I I was trying to
show you that because with the help of
blue band filter that is stored in the
sensor that is
camera it is able to get this kind of
blue light and give a high value to it
that is 255 closer to 255 similarly if I
talk about let's say greenish part in
this images which are this kind of
grapes right this kind of melons right
if I show you them over here you can see
that they are again expressed in the
lighter pixels that are values closer to
255 as compared to this one see how
darker they are closer to the zero right
the darker pixels are closer to zero so
how these kind of things are
representated by a darker
color right similarly if you talk about
this kind of red Parts in the images you
can see these are kind of apples which
are red these are tomatoes that are red
right if I try to show them over here
see how dark it is in the green band
filter but if I talk about the Red Band
filter see how lighter these kind of
things are all of this information are
represented by the pixels which are
closer towards like you know 200 255
kind of side right so that's the whole
idea now you might be wondering that
potatoes that are given over here are
yellow in color right then why in the
green band and the Red Band we are
having the lighter pixels so if you
think about a yellow color It's a
combination of the red color and the
green color now that's the reason by
even in the green part and the red part
you are able to see this lighter part in
the image
now what is the exact shade of red what
is the exact shade of green out of the
possible 256 combinations they're going
to come together and finally form this
kind of a yellowish image in the final
output if I show you that potato in the
blue part you will see it's a darker
color as compared to the green and the
red you are seeing that this part is
darker right anyway there are again some
kind of blue pixels that are also there
some kind of shades of blue let it be a
darker part right all these kind of
things are coming up together and give
you this exact color that you are seeing
over here so to just summarize the whole
concept of an image we first understood
the idea about what are the pixels
because with with the help of this kind
of small small squares that you are able
to see these small small squares are
coming up together and giving you this
kind of the like you know this kind of
how what is the width of the image what
is the height of the image and if we
talk about the intensities of the colors
that are represented by this kind of
small small squares is dependent on how
much amount of uh shade of red is
present what is the shade of green is
present what is the shade of blue is
present at the time of capturing that
particular image and depending on that
based on this red band green band and
blue band filter we are getting some
kind of respective outputs and all of
these values are stored in the range of
0 to 255 255 being the lighter part zero
being the darker part of that specific
output of the filter then you combine
all of these three images with
respective shades of green red blue and
finally whatever are the shades that you
can create is the final output of this
image so wherever there was a bluish
part right all of these pixels came
together join are combined together
stacked on top of each other
and this part where the blue is present
this kind of color will be there on this
specific location what is the output of
the blue filter what is the output of
the green band filter what is the out of
the Red Band filter combination of all
of this three because the bluish part is
higher in color that's why this kind of
pixel is given some shade of blue by
combining this RGB possible combination
that we are getting from the sensor this
is the color that we are able to fetch
so I hope I'm able to convey the ideas
with respect to like you know what are
this images how are they formed because
this are the building blocks that we are
talking about about this module as we go
ahead we are going to actually represent
all of these images into the format of
pixel how are you going to do do this
you will you will be seeing this in the
upcoming vide so stay tuned for
that hey everyone welcome to the third
video of module 3 and now that we are
going to deal with the astronomical
images they are typically saved in the
format of fits file so it's essential
for us that we understand what exactly
is this fits file and what kind of
things it typically contains so let's
get into it and understand about all of
this
information so now let's try to have a
very quick idea about what are Fitz
files so in the Astronomical Society
this is one of the very popular way in
order to store the data that we are
getting from these telescopes in order
to load it into our system and let's say
we are uh doing some kind of image
processing on top of that and doing some
amazing research analysis of what kind
of information is stored in this kind of
images captured by the telescopes now
that's exactly what we'll be doing in
the upcoming few videos and that's the
reason why I am explaining you over here
about the Fitz file because you are
going to fetch the data from one of the
astronomical surveys that is the
Andromeda galaxy it's not going to look
like this at all it's a very raw image
that you'll be getting from the
telescope and then how you able to get
that image it's stored in the format of
Fitz file so what are the components of
the Fitz file let's try to understand
that so Fitz file is having multiple
different header units at the same time
all of these header units are also
coming up with some kind of a data now
this data could be in the form of images
it could be in the format of uh
different tables Etc right so right now
because we're going to focus on the
image data let's just understand what
are these kind of two main components
you need to know about the Fitz file the
first thing is the header unit and all
of the Fitz file will come with the
primary header unit for sure and then
some kind of extension header units that
are going to reveal about some more
information about that specific image
that we are trying to talk about so
typically this kind of header units are
storing some kind of metadata which is
revealing the information about let's
say for example what was the telescope
used to capture that specific uh
astronomical object what is the location
of that astronomical object out there in
space for example what is the uh right
Ascension what is the declination these
are nothing but the space Celestial
coordinates that we are having to get an
exact precise location of the
astronomical body out there in space
right so we are able to get all of this
kind of information with respect to the
header unit I'm going to show this kind
of live demonstration for this kind of
uh Andromeda galaxy by the way this is
the closest galaxy to the Earth if you
don't know right it's going to be really
very amazing thing we are going to do in
the few upcoming videos for this module
right so we're going to study about this
kind of header units and all of these
header units might have some kind of
data we're going to also extract this
data and do some image processing on top
of that to reveal some of the amazing
Beauties about this androma galaxy right
now obviously you are seeing a very
highly detailed processed image we not
going to get anything very close to this
but yet do some kind of research work in
terms of doing some kind of image
processing and get some kind of of
analysis as in like you know you can see
there is some kind of a small Galaxy
over here right on top of that huge
Galaxy right we'll be able to get all of
this information by doing some kind of
image processing right so all of these
things you'll be seeing in the upcoming
few videos so stay tuned for
that hey everyone welcome to the fourth
video of module 3 so far we have just
covered this kind of theoretical
understanding of what is an image and
because we are going to deal with the
astronomic iCal data and typically it's
going to be in the format of fits file
so we have also covered that so far but
now it's time to start the coding
process and as usual you know we going
to import the libraries and if it's not
pre-installed in Google collab we are
going to first install it and then
import it so let's get into the video
now as we are going to perform some of
the image processing tasks throughout
this module on this astronomical data
called as anoma Galaxy uh so how we can
collect this data from lot of
astronomical surveys and call it into
our Google collab notebook we can do
this with the help of a library called
as asro query so now like matplot Li
this is not pre-installed in the Google
collab environment so you will have to
manually install it by using this
command called as pip
install and the name of the library that
is Astro
query and you simply run this code and
it's going to take some seconds and
simply install it for us in this Google
collab environment now the moment this
is done you will require one more
Library through which you will be
performing the visualizations and as you
might have guessed it is M plot so I'm
also going to import matplot lib along
with that pip
plot as
PLT now it's not that we are just going
to use m. Li okay as I also installed
this kind of Astro query you're are also
going to use some of the functionalities
of this particular library in order to
call that image as I mentioned about the
androm Galaxy and along with that
there's one more Library called as
astropy even that is the one that you're
going to use in upcoming videos but for
now there were only two basic steps that
I really wanted to show you that with
the help of what library you will be
calling this image of entoma Galaxy into
your Google collab notebook and then
obviously in order to visualize it what
is the library that we are going to use
that is met plot now in the next video
you are going to see some of the amazing
things uh through which you are just
going to be completely shocked like you
know these kind of things we can do in
Python so stay tuned for
that hey guys welcome to the fifth video
of module 3 and here we are going to
take a look onto the internet's virtual
telescope with the help of Sky View form
so what exactly is this form and how we
can get the image of the anoma Galaxy
out of this let's look into that in this
particular
video so let me introduce you all to
this interesting form called as Sky View
query form now with the help of this
form you're going to get this access of
this Andromeda galaxy so if I just click
on this particular link it's going to
redirect me to that particular site
where I can access the sky view query
form so what is this form all about as
you can see it is the internet's virtual
telescope so with the help of this
particular query form you can query
about any kind of image that you're
looking forward to that is M3 31 in our
case that is Andromeda galaxy so for the
Andromeda Galaxy from all the possible
available surveys over here we just need
to give some of the selections that we
want to visualize our M31 in so the
telescope that we are going to use is
the sdss and DSs and both of them are in
the optical range and uh with the help
of sdss I'm going to perform some of the
uh image processing task and with the
help of DSs I'm going to show you the
whole output of how this kind of Galaxy
looks like in Python okay we're going to
do all these kind of things in the
upcoming videos but for now let's see if
I want to visualize this data in this
form itself without using python how can
I do it so for example if I'm clicking
on this SD SSG and click on enter
because I have already pre-selected this
particular object as or source as M31
that's the entoma Galaxy and I'm using
this particular survey called sdss of
gband is going to give us this
particular output now what is this this
is the extreme center of the Andromeda
galaxy or I should say the core of the
Andromeda galaxy so if I just have to
show you over here the extreme core over
here this kind of like you know this
kind of bright part you are seeing this
bright part so that bright part if you
are trying to just dim that thing and
look exactly into the center that Center
is nothing but what is visualized over
here just in case if I really want to
show you what this means this is very
zoomed in version of what's going on in
the center of this particular core of
Andromeda galaxy and we are going to
perform our all the kind of image
processing on top of this particular
output but now what if I want to like
you know just zoom zoom out a bit and
show you with respect to some other uh
survey that is the S DSS and let let let
me select this DSS2
blue and uh I'll just what I'll do one
thing I'll clear every survey sections
and then again select this blue and this
time I'll just change the setting of
image size pixels from 300 to 600 and
now if I submit this
request see this is the kind of output
that we are seeing I have zoomed out
only by a bit I have doubled the pixel
size so I'm getting much more output as
compared to what we were seeing for a
much larger output but now it's still
like you know if I just compare it with
the original image over here it's this
kind of part that you are able to
visualize if I just zoom
in say I'm not able to zoom in any
further than this but now this is the
power of the telescope images that we
are having this is visualizing at the
extreme center now over here in this
specific image you are not able to look
into that extreme core because we are we
have zoomed out a bit however you are
able to see some of this kind of bands
or of this particular Galaxy and this
bands are nothing but the bands that you
are seeing over here so this is a very
zoomed in image now what I'm going to
perform over here for you guys in the
upcoming videos is that with the help of
this uh DSS2 blue we are going to try to
visualize this whole Li uh not library
but the image the whole image of this uh
Andromeda galaxy I'm going to try to
visualize this kind of thing for you uh
with the help of a DSS2 blue and then
with the help of sdss G that 300 by 300
pixels that we had seen we are going to
perform image processing over there and
try to decode what all kind of
structures we are able to find out of
that simple looking thing that we had
seen earlier this
thing okay I guess oh I selected two
surveys this is the first survey and
this is the second survey right this was
the first DSS2 blue and this is the
second one that was the main reason why
I primarily went away over here and
clicked on uh clear survey selections
because I could I don't want to see both
the things I just wanted to see one but
anyway these are both the surveys over
here uh on with respect to DSS2 the
zoomed out version 600 by 600 and over
here this is
300x300 focusing extremely on the core
of this particular Galaxy so now in the
upcoming video we are going to call this
data of Sky View query form with the
help of Astro query Library into python
so it will be really interesting to see
how we can do this so stay tuned for
that hey guys welcome to the sixth video
of module 3 and here we are going to use
the Astro query library in order to get
the access of the sky view that we had
seen in our previous video and from
there we are going to fetch this data of
Andromeda Galaxy from a particular
survey that is sdss specifically gband
okay all these things you will be
understanding in this video but the
output of this will be of Fitz file and
now that you are also aware about the
Fitz file it will have two types of
information header and data so header
will consist of metadata and data will
have some kind of image present over
there so we going to take that image
data and visualize the output of the
anoma Galaxy and just compare it with
the actual view that we had for the
anoma Galaxy using the sky view
form so now that you are aware about
what is this Sky View query form where
you can give in the information about
the source that you want to visualize
with respect to any of this available
survey options right now we have already
visualized with respect to Optical sdss
and DSs but now specifically if I let's
say want to visualize this sdss G in my
python so basically what I'm trying to
do is I'm trying to I hope this is yeah
this is sdss gband so I'm trying to
visualize this particular information
with respect to python so how we can do
this with the help of Astro query
Library let's try to look into that so
for that what I have to do is first of
all I need to get this Sky View
functionality in Python and I can do
this with the help of estro query
library with this command EST from estro
query. Sky
View I need to import Sky View
class so with the help of this Sky View
class we are going to use one of the
method of this Sky View class through
which we can fetch this data of M31 of
this particular server and I can do this
with this command sky
view the moment I press this dot it's
going to give me all the possible
methods associated with this Sky View
class and now because we are interested
to get this images I'm going to click on
that and now let's see what kind of
inputs we can give to this particular
method so I'm just pressing the
parenthesis and I'm just waiting for a
while and now this is the kind of popup
that I'm able to see automatically on
Google collab and the first input is
going to expect is the position which is
nothing but the M31 in our case the
second input that is expecting is the
survey which is going to be SD SSG in
our particular attempt that we are
trying to visualize something all the
kind of other information you can keep
it as of whatever it is I'm not going to
change anything and we are going to do a
lot of different stuff on top of that
that's why I'm not changing any kind of
things as of now and uh so yeah let me
give the input of M31 as the position
and the survey as SD SSG and the moment
I run
this I am getting a list within a list
right I'm getting this kind of square
brackets which is called as a list and
inside that I'm having one more list and
inside that inner list I having this
kind of a file now what is this file
this is a file which is called as a fits
file that we had talked about ear
earlier in this particular module we had
talked about how this kind of fits file
is created it is having some information
about a primary header for sure and some
of the metadata associated with that now
along with that it might or it might not
have this kind of extension uh headers
and the data associated with that so in
our case as we are seeing only one
primary header it's basically indicating
that we are having information about the
primary header and with respect to that
what is the metadata with it and any
kind of extension information is not
given to us and that's the reason why we
are having only one information within
this kind of main
list now that's exactly what we are
going to fetch out of this list and get
this hdu file from it how we can do this
first of all I'm having this kind of the
original list the main list inside which
there is one list so let's get access to
that inner list I can do this with the
help of this index zero because I know
that this particular list is present on
the zeroth index now if I run this code
and show you the output let's see what
do we
get so as expected we are now into the
inner list now inside this inner list we
also again see that this hdu file is
present in the zeroth element on the
first position basically so I again need
to pass this zero and now we are
successfully going to get this hdu file
that we are looking forward to and now
this is is nothing but the primary hdu
so I'm just going to store it in a
variable called as
hdu now always remember HD is coming
with two different type of information
one is the metadata which is going to
give us all the kind of details with
respect to the Fitz file who has created
it when was it created the information
about the telescope and the survey that
was used to fetch this particular data
every kind of information will be stored
as a metadata in the format called as
header now along with header there is
one more kind of thing we call as data
now that data as I explained earlier
could be in the format of an image could
be a tabular data right all this kind of
information could be there so now let's
try to understand first of all the
metadata that is associated with this
primary hdu now I can do this with this
function called as header of this hdu so
hdu do header this is the only command
that I'm typing to get all the metadata
information associated with
it now as you can see that this is the
file written by the sky view Thursday
December 14 uh with this particular uh
time and everything the information when
this particular file was written after
that we are also having this particular
idea that it is containing a twood
dimensional image as well what is the
width of the image 300 what is the
height of the image 300 if you remember
in the sky view form itself by default
it was having 300 pixels if I don't
write this if I just refresh this by
default it was giving us this 300 and
that's the exact reason why we are
having this 300 by 300 I can surely go
ahead and manually change this to 600 if
I want but I'll be doing this for the
other Optical survey that is the DSs
survey right uh this particular survey
DSS 2 I'll be showing that in the
upcoming videos but let's now focus on
this particular part see by default the
pixel size is set to 300 so that's the
reason why we are again saying this kind
of 300 by 300 so all of this information
with respect to this see again there's a
comment with respect to Sky View survey
metadata right then all the respective
information the copyright information
survey information uh projection
information coordinates information uh
Epoch information all of this particular
thing is given over here in the sdss
there are multiple data releases this is
part of data release 9 dr9 again this
kind of information is there so
obviously it will take a lot of time for
me to explain each and every part of
this metadata you get used to it once
you're having more and more practice
with respect to like you know dealing
with the fits file specifically the
astronomical data but right now the key
takeaway for you is that in this Header
information of the hdu file you get this
kind of basic information right you can
just keep on scrolling and get any kind
of respective useful information for for
you so that was about with respect to
metadata now what about because we know
that it's also containing some kind of
image how can I fetch that image out of
this particular HDO file so for that
I'll just scroll
down and see here I also written the
comment that get the pixel data that is
present from this hdu now I simply need
to do
hdu do
data how I did hd. header for the
metadata just like that I need to to do
hd. data in order to get this pixel
information and as we had seen it's in
the format of float 32 where we had seen
this uh if I just scroll up this is
where we had seen this now it's like you
know it's also including some kind of
negative numbers and it could have
positive numbers and it's of a float 32
type it's a floating Point numbers of
array and is a float 32 type again in
the beginning of this particular module
i x explained about this images all of
this kind of pixels so this pixels are
in the range of 0 to 255 or a uh uint 8
image but right now we are dealing with
the float 32 Type image and it's a like
you know the sign is also playing an
important role it means it might have
some kind of negative data some kind of
positive data okay don't worry about all
these kind of things I'm not going to go
into any kind of uh further technical
details but see now we are having this
kind of a data and it's of a type float
32 even this kind of information was
present in the metadata so over here
this is nothing but the
M31 pixels data I'm going to sh store
this particular thing as the M31 pixels
data because this is a format of an
array so this array is nothing but in
the format of an image and now check the
type of uh this particular M31 pixels
that we have created now I have already
told you that it's a array now how do
you know it's a nump array you can use
this functionality of type and just pass
in this
M31
pixels if I run
this it is a numpy array numpy array and
dimensional array basically okay now
what is the shape it must be 300 by 300
by 300 as we had checked in the metadata
so let's even try to check that M31
pixels dot shape it must be 300 by 300
if not then we are doing some kind of
mistake see it's 300 by
300 the exact same thing that we had
seen in the metadata right now the next
thing that we are going to do is to
visualize this particular image now how
we can do this I can do this with the
help of pl. IMO in order to visualize
any kind of numpy array any kind of
array data associated with num Pi ARR if
you want to visualize it you use this
PLT and then I am sure now with respect
to that you given the information of the
array that you are trying to
visualize and you just hit uh run this
particular code cell and let's see what
kind of output you
get this is the kind of output you are
getting currently right by default the
color map that we are able to see this
is VAR it is okay if I show you C map is
equal to vus so by default mat plot lab
is going to get this color map of vus
see you can see there is no change
because by default color map that was
used for this 2D image 2D image means a
gray scale image okay so I can also
convert this into a gray color if I want
even that is
fine because this is the kind of some
kind of similar output that we had seen
over here now let me tell you that there
is some kind of pixel scaling that has
been done on top of this image that's
why you are seeing much more information
as compared to this raw data we are
seeing over here and that's exactly what
we are going to do in some of the
upcoming videos so stay tuned for that
but for now what I'm really uh
interested to show you over here is that
our data is starting from 0 to 300 but
on the y axis it's going in the opposite
way zero is on the top so we need to
bring down this particular origin over
here so how we can do that I can can
simply pass in the command of origin is
equal to lower inside this IM show
itself so now if I run
this you will be seeing that now the
origin is uh over here and now this is
the kind of the center that we are
seeing over here and how we can reveal a
lot more other information as you can
see over here of course I can give some
of the uh input parameters like you know
I can just change some of the input
parameters while calling this uh image
get image but I'm not going to do all
that kind of stuff I'm going to show you
manually how you can try a lot of
different ways of pixel scaling in some
of the upcoming videos okay right now in
this video I just wanted to show you
that out of these two survey that we are
going to use how I can show you at least
one of the survey so that you are able
to appreciate that yes with the help of
this Astro query
Library we have imported this class
called sky view from this sky I there
was an method called as get images now
this is going to give us the fits file
that is written with the help of estrop
Library not estr query but estrop Pi
okay again estrop is one of the library
in Python which is associated with this
estro query also so with the help of
that estrop Pi we are writing that fits
file so because it was in the format of
a list we are extracting this kind of
list data and getting h from that and
once we got that hdu out of it we are
looking into the metadata and any kind
of data Associated along with that
metadata and for us it was image uh in
this particular case it's not always
image just remember that over here we
were having the image data we took we
took a look onto the what type of that
uh D array was it's a numpy array
basically and we can check this kind of
shape on top of that that is 300 by 300
and also we have visualized this by
Shifting the origin to the lower so that
this kind of z0 is matched now in some
of the upcoming videos you will be
seeing that with the help of the pixel
scaling techniques how we can convert
this kind of raw data into something
like this okay and along with that I'm
also going to show you in some of the
upcoming videos in this module that how
you can visualize this kind of overview
I'm not going to add any kind of color
information okay I'm not going to do any
kind of that kind of uh color processing
I am just going to show you that with
the help of this Sky View how you can
look into this kind of bigger output
also a zoomed out version also okay so
I'm going to give you all of this
information in the upcoming few videos
so again just stay tuned for
that hey guys welcome to the 7th video
of module 3 and here I'm going to show
you one another survey with respect to
which again we are going to fetch the
data of Andromeda galaxy but this time
we are also going to tweak in some of
the parameters so that we are able to
not just see the core of the Andromeda
galaxy rather the overall Galaxy that
you must be seeing on the internet all
over whenever you are searching for the
Andromeda galaxy so that's the kind of
output that I'm looking for not in terms
of colors but at least the image which
is clearly showing you that yes this is
the Andromeda galaxy so that's something
that we're going to do in this video so
let's get
started so now that we were able to
fetch this information of the Andromeda
Galaxy from the uh s dssg Optical survey
that we were having now we are going to
go ahead and call this DSS2 blue and
visualize the output in a much more
zoomed out fashion as compared to what
you are seeing over here okay how can I
do this with in Python let's try to
understand that so again what I'm going
to do is first of all I'm going to copy
this this part of the
code and come down over
here and uh call this but now at the
same time I'm going to change this to
DSS to
Blue right now along with that now
because I want to see the zoomed out
version of this I need to pass in
further more arguments over here in the
get images so one thing that I can give
apart from the position and this survey
is the
pixels now inside this pixels
information what all kind of things I
can give I can give by default it is 300
by 300 I can let's say give 600 but now
at the same time I'm also going to
increase the radius of it so that we are
able to see much more wider view of what
we are seeing over here okay over here
also 600 by 600 is still giving us a
little bit zoomed out version but I want
to expand the radius of this particular
image so that we are able to see a lot
more information in this 600x 600 so for
that I need to say let's say for example
150 now I need to convert this into arc
minutes okay I need to convert this into
arc minutes how can I do this I can do
this with this Library called astropy
that I talked about in the previous
video so from
astropy dot or I should say import
estrop do units as U and this U that is
the units will help us convert this 150
into the arc minutes how I'm going to
multiply
this uh into U do AR mean that is Arc BS
and now if I try to just run this
particular
cell okay it's giving me some kind of an
error the spelling of pixels is
incorrect no
problem now if I run this I'm going to
sort that
out it's going to take a little bit more
time as compared to what we had seen in
our previous video to fetch the hdu file
because it's taking a lot more pixels
and also the radius is very uh like you
know we have increased the radius and
therefore now if I go ahead and try to
get only the pixels data from this hdu
data okay and this is nothing but the
like you know
M31 with respect to DSS2 blue
pixels and now if I try to just run this
code and look into the shape of this M31
DSS 2 blue
pixels do
shape it's going to be 600 by 600 but
now just look into the magic the moment
I'm doing PLT do IMO of the same
thing giving the color map as gray and
at the same time I'm also uh doing
origin is equal to
lower I run this
now see this is the kind of image that
we are seeing the same image that we are
having over here very similar to this we
are able to see that there is one more
Galaxy near the Andromeda galaxy this is
the satellite galaxy of the Andromeda
this messia 32 is one more satellite
Galaxy to this Andromeda and this
galaxies are going to like you know come
and collide with the Earth right in some
billion years ahead and form a
combination of Andromeda and Milky Way
We also call it like you know as
milkomeda there is this kind of name
that we have given to this like you know
when this kind of collision will happen
between the Andromeda galaxy and the
Milky Way galaxy we will call it as mil
omeda and milk droma something like that
okay there are some weird names we have
given that is the combination of both of
these galaxies but anyway see now we
have exactly got this data that we were
looking into I'm not going to add any
kind of color
information just look into the moment I
have changed this kind of uh
particular survey we are able to get
this kind of output the whole anoma
galaxy you are able to see over here
this is M Messier 110 this is year 32
all of this information we are able to
see even over here there is a star
cluster even that information is
visible so we have done all of this with
just one line of code over
here but now this is not what I really
want to do obviously we've got all of
this things this is really very cool
right but now let's do some of the image
processing with respect to this score of
this Andromeda Galaxy now that's
something that we'll be doing in some
later part of the uh module before that
let me show you because we are having a
lot of information with respect to a
Header information even this kind of
image information if you want to create
your own fits
file just like how these guys are
creating this fits file if you want to
create your own fits file like this how
you can create it after that we'll be
jumping onto all the kind of image
processing and interesting stuff before
that this one part that I really want to
show to the people who are really
interested to know how this kind of fits
file are made so for that just watch the
upcoming video and you're going to get a
good idea about how you can create your
own particular fits
file hey everyone I welcome you to this
eighth video of module 3 where I'm going
to teach you how you can create your own
fits file so obviously we don't have our
own telescope like you know that's going
to capture all of these kind of things
and get our metadata and also get the
the image so what we are going to do is
we are going to use the same header and
the image that we have obtained in one
of our previous videos of the Andromeda
galexy use that as the dummy data and
create our dummy fits file okay so how
exactly we can create it is what I'm
going to show you in this video and once
it is created we are also going to test
it and see if it's working just fine as
we expect it to work right so let's get
into
it so let's try to understand that if
you're having this kind of metadata
information
and this kind of image data information
with you then how you can create your
own fits file just like how we had seen
Above So for that I'm going to use this
Library called as astropy just like what
I had shown you in the upcoming uh I
mean in the previous videos that over
here the hdu file is in the like you
know format of astropy do. fits so to
create your fits file you need to import
this particular thing in Python first of
all so that's exactly what I'm going to
to do in the first step over here I'm
going to say that from
astropy
import I should say from astropy
doio import
fits so now it's going to give me the
liberty of creating the fits file and
you had seen that it was in the format
of a list right within a list there was
the hdu file that we were having the
primary hdu file so we are going to take
the same exact metadata dat that we had
seen over here right and I'm going to
store this metadata over here as let's
say M31 Header
information okay and at the same time we
are also having the information about
the pixels so I'm going to add the same
data into my separate hdu file that I'm
creating because obviously I'm not
having any kind of existing metadata or
the image data so I'm going to use the
same information to create uh complete
fits file from scratch so for this what
I have to do first of all I'm going to
initiate this kind of empty list that
I'll be creating with the help of fits
and I can do this with this command
fits. hdu
list it's going to help us store
different hdus within that list and I'm
going to call this as the hdu list okay
like this now the second thing is to
create the primary hdu the moment you
are creating this empty list you need to
pass in some kind of hdu information so
the one that I'm going to create is the
primary hdu okay uh it's not dhu it's
hdu and how we can do this again I'm
going to use this fits but on top of
that I'm going to use
primary
HD now what this is okay first of all
let me show you what this is this will
be an empty list and in this empty list
I'm going to pass in this hdu file that
I'm going to create
I'm going to copy this also I'm going to
paste that over
here so see this is again an astropy i.
fits file it's going to give us the
primary hdu but now what if I'm trying
to let's say give this uh as some kind
of a name called HD1 for
example okay and now if I'm trying to
look into HD1 do data if I'm just doing
this it's it's not having any kind of
information as of now in the primary hdu
it's completely empty even for the
header it will have some of the basic
information that like you know it's uh
conforming uh to fit standard then it's
a array data type it's not currently
having anything number of Dimension is
zero right so we are going to fill all
of this kind of information over here
with respect to M31 metadata that is the
M31 header and in place of data we are
going to pass in the pixel values that
we were having so let's try to do that
first of all we are going to add the
pixel data how we can do this we can say
that hdu one that we had
created because now it's a primary hdu
it's coming in uh with this
functionality of data and what is this
data this is the M31 pixels that we had
created earlier similarly that like that
I can also add HD1 do header what is
this M31 header that we just created a
few seconds back so now what I'm doing I
had created a primary hdu in that
primary hdu I adding some kind of data
information I'm assigning this M31
pixels to this HD1 data which was
initially empty when I had showed you
over here
right and after that I'm also filling in
the information about the header
assigning this M31 header that we had
gone above now once this uh hdu file is
ready once this hdu one file is ready if
I run this code now and I show this hdu
one. data
now now it will have this kind of
information see even the Header
information it will
have because I assigned this kind of uh
data to the HD1 that's why now it is
having the data now our duty is to pass
this uh primary hdu into the list that
we had created that is going to finally
create one fits file for us right it is
having some list within this list we are
having this hdu so how you can do this
we know that we can add any kind of data
to the list with the help of append
function so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to call hdu list. append and what
kind of information I want to add it's
the hdu one
information which is nothing but the
primary hdu that we had created over
here that's it so our fits file is ready
now in order to download this fits file
or to write this write this fits file
what I'm going to do there is a
functionality called as right two right
two is going to help us finally save
this fits file so what I can say let's
say
hdu list that's the main fits file right
a list within that list we are having
the primary hdu so hdu list I want to
write to this particular list as the
fits file we can call it as a
dummy dummy fits
file Dain
fits file and that is in the format of
fits so do fits right so HD list. WR to
and giving it a name this if I run this
code and if I look into this file
storage you can see that this fits file
has been created for
us the same fits file that we were
importing from the sky view uh query you
are now able to save the same
information into the fits file and now
you can like you know also do a lot of
different things with this but right now
that's something that I really wanted to
show you that if you want to create your
own fits file how you can do this with
the help of astropy
library now that we are uh creating this
particular hdu file for the primary
header I mean primary hdu like this you
can create extend uh extension headers
also if you're having the information
you just do a fit. extension header and
you give some kind of data to it give
some header to it and append that
particular hdus that you are creating in
the HD list and then again do this right
to for that list that you have created
and you will be having even the
extension headers if if you are having
okay so yeah it's something that you
really want to experiment by yourself uh
if you're having multiple header and its
respective data information so you can
create multiple extension uh to the hdu
file or the fits file okay so now let's
try to open this fits file that we have
have generated how we can do this I can
do this with the help of
fits. open if you are having access to
the fits
file you copy this path you give this
path as an input to this where it went
it's over here you give it in the format
of a string let's say I'm calling this
as some kind of like you know again
let's say my bit something like that
okay my bits is equal to this if I'm
running
this okay let's uh look at into this
particular let's say what is my
fits so it will be a list and within a
list there is this kind of hdu primary
hdu that we had created right so now
what is present inside the first index
of this bits obviously this thing so my
fits of zero is having what it's having
this kind
of primary hdu file that you had created
with the help of estrop py. i. fits now
if you want to check this header
information so you do my fits of zero.
header you could have also saved it into
some kind of a variable called uh dummy
hdu and then you can take dumy hd.
header even that is fine so you can see
now there is a header you can also do uh
this for the data part the pixels part
my
fits 0. data
right again now you can store it as a
variable let's say this is uh
dummy data variable and I'm saving uh
this data over here and then I'm taking
checking the shape of
this Dy data variable.
shape so because M31 was the
sdss from that particular sub we had got
that data it's by default 300 by 300 so
that's why we getting that particular
shape and if you want to get the type of
the variable you do type of the that
dummy uh data
variable check this it will be a numpy
array right so as you can see I've also
cross checked this particular thing the
moment we were creating it and even
after creating it once we are saving it
I am also importing it back with the
help of fits. open command and checking
all of this if it's working in a proper
way or not and yes that's how you can
create your own fits file if you're
having access to the Header information
uh as well as the data information so
that's what that was about how you can
create your own fits file now in the
upcoming video we are going to talk
about the pixel scaling that we were
mentioning about before this particular
video and that's where the fun begins
guys hey everyone I welcome you all to
this ninth video of module 3 where I'm
going to show you the distribution of
pixels with the help of an histogram but
before that I'll also be showing you the
summary statistics of the pixels that we
are having of the Andromeda galaxy and
after that I'll be showing you the
visualization so let's get into this
video so first of all what I'm trying to
do over here is to get the summary
statistics of the numpy array that we
had created for the M31 pixels what is
this M31 pixels if I just give you a
very quick summary of this so M31 pixels
was the uh value of the image data that
we had captured from the fits file that
we had seen for the uh slow digit Sky
survey gband so from this we had fetched
this particular information of the numpy
array which is nothing but the array of
pixels which is eventually
forming this kind of output I'm going to
set the color map is equal to Gray and
also set origin is equal to lower for
the same reasons that you had seen in
the previous
videos and the output that you'll be
seeing over here is like this a plane
output which is just highlighting the
center part of the Andro Roma Galaxy
like this but everything else is just
black as compared to what you are seeing
over here this is a much more detailed
output that we can see as compared to at
least what we are having over here so
how we can get this kind of outputs by
doing what changes on the pixels we can
get this kind of output that's something
that we going to look ahead to but now
for that we need to understand what's
wrong with this particular image so for
that we need to do some kind of basic
study on the pixel values which is able
to give us this kind of an output so for
that we need to check the summary
statistics of this particular pixels so
how we can do this I'm going to Simply
use numpy that's the reason I have
imported the numpy over here which I
haven't as of now so import nump as
NP so yeah now let's go ahead and try to
uh
print summary
statistics of M31 pixels and excuse me
me if my uh spellings are incorrect
because I'm not good with them but now
the first thing that I'm trying to print
over here with the help of F string is
the minimum value that is present in
this whole array of pixels out of all of
this 300 by 300 image that we are having
where we are having or I should not say
where but what is the minimum value of
the pixel that we are having so let's
say minimum is uh NP do mean of the
pixel that I'm trying to find I mean of
the array that we are trying to find if
I just run this
code you can see that the minimum pixel
value is 5.35 something right and just
like this because I want to find the
maximum value also what is the average
value of the pixel what is the spread of
the pixel I'll also be needing the
maximum mean and the standard deviation
values of this particular array so after
minimum I'm going to look for maximum
I'm going to look for average value that
is the mean and the spread basically
basically uh over here is referring to
the standard deviation okay so don't
worry if you're uh looking into this
kind of uh terms for the first time it's
completely
fine
STD now let's look into the overall
summary Statistics over here the minimum
value is 5359 of the pixel the maximum
value of the pixel in this array of M31
pixels is
178 now if you talk about on and a
average on an average in this M31 pixels
array what is that value of pixel it is
13. 329 something so on an average the
pixel values that you will be seeing
will be more towards the minimum side
it's not exactly in the center it's very
much skewed towards the left hand side
uh of the pixels that is towards the
minimum side so if you want to get more
sense of this particular data we can
also visualize this and look into the
reason of like you know why we are
having this kind of 178 because minimum
is 5.35 and the average is about 13
something then how come maximum is 178
over here so it could be there is some
kind of noise that is present uh over
here in this image I can also prove you
this with the help of what is the pixel
value that is at the brightest spot that
we can see over here that is exactly at
the center because remember that this
kind of uh images that we are having is
directly from the telescope who is
focusing or I should say which is
focusing at the extreme Center of that
Andromeda galaxy and with the help of uh
the metadata I can literally show you
what is that reference pixel okay so if
I just scroll up so over here now we can
see over here see X reference pixel is 1
15.5 and the Y reference pixel is again
15.5 so it basically means that this is
the center
which was focused by the telescope in
order to generate this particular image
so that's where we expect the maximum
value of the pixel to be there so again
if you want to just cross check that
part you can do this with the help of um
M31
pixels located at 150 comma 150 because
we cannot give any kind of uh float
values over here to get the location of
the pixel so it is 148.5 what what about
150 1 and
151 oops yeah let's check this value
it's 126.5 so both of these values are
again far away from
178 so it basically means there is some
kind of noise that we are having in this
particular data and again we can go
ahead and visualize this I can also
first of all give this particular thing
as a comment as uh visual or
printing the value of pixel at the
center of androma
Galaxy right so yeah that's something
that we are having over here and now
let's try to visualize the distribution
of these pixels with the help of
histogram now you can again create a
histogram with the help of M plot Li so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
PLT do hist for histogram I'm going to
give the M31 pixels to get the
distribution of the pixels of this thing
so for example let's say we are having
300 by 300 pixel values uh over there
whatever is the pixel that is present
how many times you were able to see this
in the array so that kind of
distribution you will be seeing with the
help of this uh histogram okay now I
guess there is some kind of an indent
problem so I'm just going to delete that
part yes and now after this I'm going to
uh also give one information called as
bins what is this bins you will
understand it in a while okay I'm for
I'm just giving a value as 50 but now if
you remember this is a 2d array it's a
2D image now in order to quickly
visualize this particular thing I'm just
going to convert it into a 1D kind of
format using this flat operation so this
flat on top of this numpy array is going
to convert this into a one it's going to
treat it as an Itor as a one dimension
so it's quickly going to help us
visualize this histogram basically okay
if I don't use this flat command it's
going to take a lot of time to get us an
output so that's why I'm using this flat
and quickly we are having this kind of
an output now if you look into this kind
of steps that we are having right you
can play around with the steps by
increasing or decreasing this beans
value let's so what happens if I'm just
using
one so this is the kind of output that
we are having in between 5 to 178 we are
having just this kind of one bar so if
you want to have a lot of proper
visualization just increase the value of
Bin to let's say for example
100 it's going to give you much more
better distribution as compared to what
you were seeing and if you still want to
get a refined version of this you can
still increase the ban values let's say
for example
300 and now look into the output see
again output is pretty much similar so I
guess we are fine with this one and now
clearly we can see that this is that the
pixel distribution is completely skewed
to the left hand side so clearly we can
see that there were some kind of pixel
values in the array which is not
appearing for a lot of time so it might
it must be some kind of noise that's
something that we are expecting right so
this is the kind of observation that we
were able to get over here now in the
upcoming videos you will be seeing what
are some kind of different pixel scaling
techniques through which we can
transform our this kind of pixels to
some new type of pixels such that in a
hope we get a lot more better
information from this particular output
as compared to what you are seeing
currently so yes that's exactly what
we'll be doing in the upcoming few
videos hi everyone welcome to this video
of module 3 where we're going to start
our journey of pixel scaling with the
first method that we have over here is
minmax scaling so to start with this
video I'm going to show you some of the
helper functions that we'll be creating
that will be eventually helping us to
generate some visualizations for the
comparison or just a normal image with
some of the functionalities added to
that particular function after that
we're going to again create one more
function that's actually going to
implement the minmax scaling on the
given input pixel array and once this
kind of output we are able to generate
from this function we are going to
compare the visualization of the
original image and the scaled image so
that's the whole idea that we're going
to cover in this video so let's get
started so the first pixel scaling that
we are going to look into is the
intensity normal normalization or also
called as minmax scaling or linear
scaling the idea over here is that we
take the whole array of pixels we do a
subtraction with the minimum value that
is present in that array the minimum
pixel value in that array and then
divide it with the range or you can also
call it as the difference between the
maximum pixel value and the minimum
pixel value in that are and the output
you get the output of the array will be
same shape but now the values will be
scaled
that's the whole concept of this
intensity normalization or whatever kind
of thing you want to call it and let's
see how we can achieve this so I'm going
to create a function for that over here
I'm going to Define it as uh let's say
mean Max
scaling and what input it takes it takes
only one thing the main array of pixel
let me just call it as pixel area
something like
this now it is divided into two parts
numerator and the denominator so let me
call it as over here uh numerator is
equal to the pixel array pixel array
minus the minimum value of this pixel
array and then denominator let me just
call this
DN what is this it is the maximum
value of this pixel
array minus the minimum value np.
minimum of the pixel array that's
it now the output of this should be what
again an array but how it's the division
of this numerator and
denominator simple as that so our
function is ready if we are going to
pass in the data of M31 pixels it's
going to give us the output in the
format of minmax scaling and we are
going to hope to see some better
information uh as compared to what we
are are seeing over here we are not sure
it will be better we are just hoping
that we get a better output so coming
back to this what I'm going to do is
first of all I'm going to uh create Min
minmax scaled array or I can just say
minmax array right and I can do this
with the help of minmax scaling that I
have created on top of M31
pixels and now before I go ahead and
visualize this what I'm going to do is
I'm going to create a common function
that will help us visualize this kind of
output because it's going to have some
kind of common things the title of it
then once we are showing this kind of
array this kind of cmap equal to gray
origin equal to lower all of this kind
of code will be repetitive so for that
what I'm doing is I'm just uh converting
this into a function so that in just one
line of code we can do all of this task
so let's say I'm defining again one more
function and calling it as let's say
plot
underscore pixels something like this
right so the first thing that I'm going
to give is the pixel data or pixel
array after that what kind of title I
want to give what kind of color I want
to set for the title some kind of this
information the first thing would be to
display the array that is pixel
array and keep the same color map that
is gray
always for now and uh after that I'm
also going to set the origin to
lower and then I'm also going to do PLT
do um title going to set title to the
title that is given as an input and also
set a color to it color is equal to the
color given by the user of this function
and uh also I'm going to use PLT doxis
and turn it off so that the output is
not giving us this kind of exis okay we
are just getting the output in the
format of the image without the exis
okay it's going to look much more better
I guess so yeah that's something that
I'm trying to do and also after this I'm
trying to get PLT do
Sho to avoid any kind of external text
information that it may display on top
of the image like this okay over here we
did not use pl. Sho so it is showing me
this kind of output I'm not really
looking forward to this kind of things
so that's why I have given this kind of
pl. show and that's it our function is
ready so not every time after converting
uh I mean after scaling down our pixels
to some values we don't have to plot
this multiple lines of code I'm just
going to use this plot pixels give the
array of the pixel change the title
change the color and get the output
that's it again I can do some more
interesting thing I can give the weight
uh of this pixel as
bold and uh yeah that's it I guess this
is fine I'm just going to rerun this
code and because we have have already
created this kind of a minmax scaler
right what I'm going to do I'm going to
plot
pixels for minmax
areay now the title I'm going to set is
um minmax
scaling color that I want to give to
this is royal
blue and yeah that's it so let's see
what kind of output do we get by just
okay I guess we are having some kind of
an error the error says that the text.
set got an unexpected keyword called
weight the spelling of weight is
incorrect again don't mind my spelling
guys I'm really poor at
spellings run this going to run this
again yeah it's giving us this kind of
an
output now um again what I'm trying to
do is I'm trying to do I'm trying to
compare this with the original uh image
over here right so what I'll do is I'll
also create a comparision over here okay
I'll be Crea
creating one more function to compare
the scaling so
compare
pixels it's going to take two data
original M31 data
original array at the same time I'm
going to give scaled
array okay and I'm going to create a
subplot over here PLT do
subplot so the first uh subplot that I'm
going to give is one two one one row two
columns on the first position I'm going
to plot the original array and I can do
this with the help of the above function
that we have created plot pixels I'm
just going to remove this pl. show as of
now I'm going to have uh plot
pixels and I'm going to first of all
pass in the original array right and
after doing this I'm going
to have multiple titles uh over here so
the for the first one I'm going to give
the title as TI as
original
image and I'm going to give color is
equal to
Black okay and after this I'm also going
to use
subplot at 1 comma 2 comma 2 plot pixels
I'm just going to copy this whole thing
and paste it over here
and it will be the scaled array scaled
array the title will be
um let's
say let's just skip it a title over here
as title only okay I'll be passing the
title whatever is the title that I'm
trying to
give and uh again the color will be just
a
color I'm just going to give this as a
input and let me create this kind of
thing and now let me try to compare
these things so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to scrap this part and instead
I'm going to uh do I'm also going to do
pl. show at the end pl. show okay now if
I come over here and do compare what was
the name of the function compare
pixels the original data is nothing but
the M31 pixels the output is minmax
array then the title of this plot that I
want to set on the second one is the Min
minmax
scaled and the color that I want to give
to that is Royal let's
say or I can also fix this color over
here as Royal view because that's the
only one that I want as an output so
I'll also remove this part over here and
uh now I can just give this as this
only and hopefully it gives us the
output the way we
want yes so this is the kind of output
put that we want in terms of comparision
now because we are having some kind of
gapping in between I can improve this
kind of gaps I hope you know the command
the command is nothing but PLT do tight
layout and I can also adjust the figure
size if you want to have a larger size
of this image and any kind of that kind
of thing but I guess I am satisfied with
the output that I'm getting on the left
we are having the original image on the
right we are having the minmax scaled
image right so over here I don't see
that major difference over here it's
pretty much similar so we didn't get any
kind of useful information with the help
of minmax scaled output now in the next
video I'm going to show you one more
type of scaling call is standardization
or Zed scaling and it has been done with
the help of this formula so I'll explain
you this whole concept in the upcoming
video hey guys I welcome you all to this
video of module 3 where I am going to
show you some other pixel scaling
methods apart from the minmax scaling
namely standard scaling log and square
root
normalization so once we are done
getting the outputs of this scaled
version of the M31 data we are going to
visualize them by utilizing the
functions that we had created in our
previous video and then just compare out
of all of the scaling methods which one
is performing best in terms of visual
appearance which is revealing most
information about the core of the
Andromeda galaxy and then we are simply
going to take that output which is
revealing the most information and get
its pixel distribution with the help of
the histogram just like how we did in
one of our previous videos right so yes
let's get started and look into all of
this kind of things
guys so let us understand this
particular formula what is this about so
this is the actual array we are
subtracting it from the mean of the
array and dividing it with the the
standard deviation so now you already
know how we can take this mean and
standard deviation that's what we had
seen in some part of codes earlier
somewhere over here see so we're going
to use this kind of numpy functionality
in order to get a standardized output
okay the kind of Technique we call to
this particular formula that you are
seeing is either standardization or Zed
scaling whatever you want to call so if
you have studied normal distribution you
will be understanding the actual meaning
of what this is but let me not go into
the very technical concept and talk
about Z
skill Z
skill array or Z
scale only just Z scale let's just say
that this is Z scale again I'm going to
give pixel array as an
input and uh the way that I'm going to
code again I'm going to have a numerator
that is the pixel array the whole array
I'm going to subtract the mean of this
pixel
array and the denominator part is just
the standard deviation so again I'm just
going to have this kind of denominator
as np. STD standard deviation of that
pixel simple as that and written
numerator by denominator as an
output so our function is ready for the
scaling and the output that we are going
to visualize now will be straightforward
so
scaled array or I should also call this
the Z scaled array Zed scaled
array is equal to Z scale on top of M31
pixels and now if I just go ahead and
call compare pixels on M31
pixels okay again now see because this
M31 is common I don't want to give this
input again and again so I'm just going
to give in the scaled array only as an
input I'm going to keep this as m 31
pixels by
default okay I'm not going to change
this one it is always the same so I'm
going to run this
code and even in this image I'm just
going to take this part
out run this
part yes and now I'm going to do the
exactly same thing over here I don't
need to pass M31 pixels over here now
anymore I just need to pass in The Zed
scaled array and the title
title will be um let's say Zed scaled
image let's see the kind of output that
we get I guess we have created an error
the error is uh num. Den okay yeah it's
because of this particular thing no
problem let's fix that up hopefully no
errors this time
yes again not a lot difference that we
are expecting over here even with with
the help of Z scale output it's pretty
much similar to what we see in the
original image don't worry it's not that
we aren't doing anything perfectly or
there is some kind of a problem with the
Skilling techniques this is pretty much
obvious okay at times you won't be able
to see a lot of difference but now the
next thing that we are looking into is
the log normalization what is this uh
whole concept of the log normalization
you take the log of all the pixel values
that you are having in your data simple
as that so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a function for that def
log normalization or normal log scaling
whatever you want to
give input is a pixel array and it's
going to Simply return the log np. log
of this input pixel array simple as that
so this is the array that we have
created and if you want to visualize
this so log Norm array is equal to log
normalization of M31
pixels and compare
pixels of log Norm
array title is equal to log
normalized image now you will be able to
see some of the visual difference as
compared to what we were having in the
initial image now see how we are getting
this particular output they seeing a lot
more details some kind of see uh some
kind of part that we see in the around
the core of the Andromeda galaxy all of
these things are now visible this is the
center part this is this is what we see
which is not visible over here see
that's the power of like you know
scaling uh your particular pixel values
to some different scale right right now
we have implemented log on all the pixel
values with the help of np. log now if I
just compare this with this output
see how how well it is able to give us
this kind of outputs of all this kind of
if I show you the Stars over here right
all this kind of information see even
over here I can see that the output is
revealing much more information but yes
we are having this kind of output so far
that we have achieved now on top of this
there are again some more uh
normalization and scaling techniques
that you can do for sure but now before
that what I'm going to do is I'm because
we got a slightly better output over
here I'm going to create a histogram
distribution of the pixels of this
particular output okay how can I do this
I'm going to do PLT
doist of this log Norm array do flat
going to let's say set bins to 300 and
look at the output with the help of pl.
show
okay so see now this is the kind of
output the spread in the data is much
more as compared to what we were having
initially and this is the kind of output
that we have achieved so far okay and I
can also show you the shape over
here uh that is uh
log Norm array. shape it must be the
same okay that's something that I wanted
to show you that the shape is just the
same right so over here we got the
uh I guess uh the log normalization was
already done so I just got the image of
the log distribution of the log
normalization over here and that's what
we had to do over here so I just scrap
this part but at the same time I'm
trying to show you one more type of um
normalization let me just call this as
the fifth
part of this scaling technique square
root okay so what I'm going to do over
here is I'm going to create a code two
code cells one to define the square root
function again I can do it with the help
of numpy So Def let's say square root
scaling giving the pixel
arrays and uh it's going to return
return this thing NP do sqrt of pixel
that's
it going to run this uh I'm going to
create uh square root
scaled or square root are just like that
and I'm going to call sqrt scaling on
top of this M31
pixels and uh compare
pixels and I'm going to compare this
with square root
array title will be square
root
scaling let's see what kind of output do
we
get so this is the kind of output this
is one more way you can see that there
are some more information that has been
revealed over here right as compared to
what we see on the left so just like
this there are a lot of different
scaling techniques that you can use so
far we had seen that a lot more
information we were uh able to get with
respect to the log normalization so we
stick with that and said that like you
know let's create a histogram out of it
a histogram distribution of it and
that's that's how we can see how the
pixel values are distributed now right
so yeah that's something that I really
wanted to show you that with the help of
this pixel scaling how you can reveal a
lot more information like this now in
the upcoming video what you will be
seeing is one more technique which is
called as a z skill interval okay now
with the help of this again I'll be
showing you some more information and
then we are going to use any of the
scaled output and perform some of the
image processing techniques as we go
ahead in this particular moduel so stay
tuned for all of these kind of
interesting things coming up for you
guys so welcome to this last video of
module 3 where I'm going to talk about
the Z scale interval class that is
present in the astropy library okay so
what is it all about and why are we
using it all of these things you'll be
seeing in this particular video so let's
get right into
it so now let us discuss about the Z
scale interval I'm not going to go into
the logic behind like you know how this
is coming up with I'm just going to tell
you what it is going to do and how it
can be useful for us okay so for the
demonstration purpose let us try to
create a demo array 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 and 10 okay now the whole idea of
the Z scale interval is to give you an
interval that means give one minimum
value and one maximum value so let's say
mean and
Max now this mean and Max are not 1 and
10 there are some different values that
you'll be getting for example let's say
minimum we got as three and the maximum
we got as let's say eight right now the
whole idea over here is to take this
original array and clip it according to
this particular interval any values in
this array that is less than three
should be converted to three and any
values that is greater than eight
beyond8 should be converted to eight
that's what we call it as a clipping of
an array between a particular values so
now because we know that the minimum
value this array can take is three so
wherever you see any value less than
three convert that to three convert this
to three similarly if you seeing a value
greater than eight convert that to eight
convert that to eight and that's it once
we are done with this kind of conversion
we are having a whole new way of
visualizing the respective image that
we'll be creating so we are going to
follow the same exit process and the way
through which we can do this in Python
is with the help of estrop Library so
what I'm going to do is from
astropy there is a module called as
visualization so I'm going to call
visualization visualization yeah UT Zed
scale
interval going to run this code and now
okay I guess there's a spelling oh no
not a spelling mistake there is a
problem with the space over
here yes it's working fine so now we are
going to create the object of this
particular class CL Z scale
interval and what is the whole idea of
creating this object because this is the
object through which you will be able to
fetch out the limits on the any of the
image that you want okay in our case you
can choose let's say for example square
root scaling original image for that
matter I can also choose this kind of uh
log normalized image because this was
performing the best I'll be simply uh
copying this part and go down and I'll
be simply calling this kind of limits
with the help of Z scale interval on top
of this particular array right now how
we can do do this particular thing you
call this Zed you press that dot it's
going to give you this particular method
called as get limits so it is because of
this object that you have created of Z
scale interval you are getting access to
this method now this method takes the
array whose minimum and maximum value
you want uh that you have got with the
help of Z scale interval technique so if
I'm having this over here and if I know
that it's going to written two things
minimum and maximum so let's call Z1 as
minimum Z2 as
maximum so we're going to get some kind
of outputs and let's just check it with
the help of print command F string let
me just say that uh
minimum is Z1 and like that
print F maximum is equal to Z2
I run this
code so the output that we are having
over here the minimum value after
clipping uh we should have is 1.688 9
okay we haven't clipped as of now but
the minimum value after uh applying the
clipping should have 1.6 8889 nothing
less than this so if I show you in the
original array of log Norm array what is
the minimum value np. minimum of that
array if I'm just uh running
this okay it's saying that oh yeah
because we haven't defined y not array
it's
array anyways so yeah the minimum value
that we are having in the log Norm array
is 1.
6788 and after implementing this G
limits uh on the Z scale interval we got
that the minimum value should be
1.688 so obviously we can see that there
are some values which are less than this
so all the values in this array that we
we are having for the log Norm array all
of these values including this will be
converted to 1. 6889 any values less
than this will be converted to that and
just like that if I try to see the
maximum value and if I run this
code it is 5.18
17837 and over here after implementing
the get limits of Zed interval on the
log Norm array the maximum value that we
are getting is 44 4.44 79 so any values
Beyond this as we can see clearly that
yes there is at least one value that is
beyond this so any such values present
in this log Norm array we want to
convert it into all 1.5 5.18 17 all
these kind of values that has been
written right so yeah I was trying to
print this to show you that this minimum
and maximum is not equal to the minimum
and maximum pixel of this particular
array it's different right so now that
we are having this kind of an idea let's
try to visualize this data by clipping
this array of log Norm array how we can
do this I can use PLT do
IMO and now over here I'm trying to call
this log Norm array but now I'm going to
use two different parameters which is
going to help me clip the values between
these values so V mean is the minimum
value that is Z1 and Vmax is the maximum
value which is Z2 and cmap as you know
is our
gray and the origin is equal to lower we
know this kind of settings we have been
using this since the start of this
notebook and now I can simply do PLT do
show hopefully the code Works without
any kind of
error and now the output that you will
be seeing will be significantly
different than what you have seen over
here okay you can see this it's kind of
a bit a blurry kind of thing B paint
kind of thing the stars are not that
highlighted even this kind of uh the
center part of the androma Galaxy is
like this now just look into the output
that we get over here after applying the
Z scale interval see it's a bit more
highlighted right you are having a much
more brightness in that part as compared
to the smaller part so now this is the
kind of output that we are having okay
it's not that you need to specifically
apply this method it's just that I'm
trying to implement one more method so
that you guys know that this kind of
techniques also exist okay what have I
done I just got two values the limits
now from the help of this limits I have
clipped my array I haven't done any kind
of transformation as such just clipped
the array such that any values less than
that particular value and any value
Beyond this value are converted to its
respective values that's something that
I have done and this is the kind of
output that I have
achieved now according to your research
according to your whatever is the
objective the problem statement that
you're working with you come up with a
specific technique and you carry for
forward your any kind of image
processing or any kind of information
that you want to with respect to
whatever you're comfortable with it
could be the square root scaling image
it could be original image it could be
this log normalized image and not this
one specifically right it's completely
your choice according to the problem
statement now because I want to
demonstrate something in the uh upcoming
videos so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take any one of this image
let's say this particular image that we
got over here but now is this an image
yes it's an image but what is the pixel
representation of this if I am trying to
uh clip this particular values I haven't
clipped log Norm array over here right
I'm using this IM am show in order to
clip this values with the help of this
arguments so now how can I convert this
into numpy array or any kind of array so
for that I'll have to store this whole
image as a variable first of
all and now let's try to visualize what
kind of output it is giving us
okay it is the matplot libs image it's
not a pixel representation it's an met
plot Libs image so it's not giving us
any kind of array over
here so how we can convert this image
into a its pixel
representation I can do this with the
help of a command called as make
image okay now one input that it takes
is called as renderer r n d e r e r now
I am going to choose by default whatever
they are having in the back end of M
plot Li by simply giving the command of
none okay now I'm going to run this it's
going to give us the 8bit integer form
of IM image so from this kind of float
32 we are converting this into uh
unsigned integer 8bit image basically
right so this is the kind of output that
we have got but now along with this
output it's throwing some other things
also out but we are just carrying for
the first part of the output that is the
image array so I'm going to extract this
first part that is present on zero index
and now this is the array that I'm
looking forward to and you can see that
it's a d type equal to U in8 unsigned
integer 8 right so that's something that
we were looking forward to and now uh
let me just store this into an array
image array let's say
and now let me go ahead and try to check
the shape of this so image aray do
shape it is 370 370 and 4 original shape
was 300 300 that's it so we need to
think about this we need to convert this
into 300 by 300 not this shape so first
of all how did we get this
370 so so over here I just need to pass
in one more argument called as unsampled
is equal to
true now by using this particular
command or argument unsampled is equal
to true it's going to keep the
dimensions as it is if I run this again
and uh again run this particular code
you will be seeing that 300 by 300 has
been achieved right so we have decreased
our shape back to 300 by 300 that's
something that we wanted now what about
this four channels what it means so four
channels basically mean let me just
write a note over
here so the four Channel basically is
indicating to us that it is uh having
red green blue and Alpha
channels uh makes up a four Channel
image
typically if it's in the format of RGB
so the first three channels will be RGB
and the last one will be Alpha Channel
now what is Alpha Channel it is with
respect to the opacity of the image okay
the values again are in between 0 to 255
0 means completely opaque and 255 means
the opposite of that so yeah that's the
idea with respect to the four Channel
output now how we can convert this four
Channel output into only one channel
that is gray scale now that's something
that we going to look into into with the
help of CV2 Library which is nothing but
the open CV Library I can import it with
the help of import CV2 command and by
default it is already present in the
Google collab so you don't need to pre I
mean again install it over here so I'm
simply using this command of UT CV2 and
importing my open CV Library over here
now how we can remove the fourth channel
of the
opacity and basically just convert this
into and convert
it
into gray scale okay I should have
written remove four channels or
just
um convert four scale uh four Channel
image to gray
scale image now how we can achieve this
with the help of CV2 so in open CV
Library there is some a method called as
CVT color right now the input that is uh
it's going to take is the image array
whose uh channels are four so I'm going
to pass it over here and along with that
it's going to take a flag what is this
flag the flag that is going to convert
this four Channel image into a gray
scale Now by default in CV2 that is open
CV it's not going to read as uh the
first channel as red second as green
third as blue it's going to be the
opposite of that on the first channel we
will be having blue on the second it
will be green and on the third it will
be red and then on the fourth it will be
Alpha so it's BG this four Channel if
you're are using
CV2 right so if you're using CV2 the
four CH will be in the format of BG a
and now that BG needs to be converted to
gray I can do this with the help of CV2
do color underscore BG a to Gray that's
it and let me just St store it as gray
image gray
array and now let me just go ahead and
cross check if the shape is
correct hopefully it
is yes it's correct and now just to
visualize if we have lost some
information or it's uh just like what we
are seeing over here let me just again
plot this thing so I'm going to plot it
with the help of the uh plot pixels
function that we had created above right
it's going to take in the input of the
array that is the gray array then I
guess it was taking the title also title
would be let's
say Zed scale
interval gray scale let's something like
this and color let's say is royal
blue hopefully this is not giving any
errors I hope that the these are the
parameters okay we got an error so error
is TIY oh never mind t t l is the
spelling yeah so this is the output that
we have got and it's just the same image
that we were having over here exactly
the
same right you can also try to like you
know plot it side by side with the help
of that comparison function that we had
created but anyways I am happy that yes
the output is just the same and we are
going going to carry forward with this
particular thing right uh the gray area
right that's the kind of conclusion that
we have made so far now let's also look
into the histogram visualization of this
so PLT doist going to pass in the gray
array and flat use flat to convert it
into an 1D Itor and then passing the
bins is equal to usual as usual 300 and
look into the
output as you can see that we getting
some kind of a display of array I'm just
going to use pl. show and it's going to
just uh show me the output of the image
nothing
else so now this is the kind of output
that we are able to
achieve and the pixels are ranging from
somewhere from zero all the way up to
255 why what is the reason behind that
the logic is that because we have
converted our float image into 8bit
image and in 8bit image as I I explained
earlier the values are in between 0 to
255 so that's the reason why we are
having this particular range right so
yeah this is the histogram visualization
that we are
having and uh now in order to apply any
kind of image processing on this
particular image uh what I'm going to do
is I'm also going to convert this gray
scale uh array into some good name so
that we can use it further let's say I'm
giving some unique name to it as
um gray
scale or gray scale Z
interval Z int array is equal to gray
array so I'm just giving a meaningful
name to this because we were just doing
some kind of experimentation over here
and because everything is working fine
so I'm just saving it in a very good
name so that we can use it in the uh
upcoming videos right so the whole whole
idea that we have seen over here is that
with the help of Z scale interval we got
two values for the interval and we use
this IM show in order to clip the value
between these two values that we had got
Z1 and Z2 so from this we St we stored
it into this image variable which was
nothing but the M plot lip image type so
from that we converted it into its pixel
representation with using this
particular function we give this to
inputs we fetch the array part of it and
the output will be 8bit integer image
and but the output now was having four
channels so whenever you're trying to
perform the image processing and because
see the output is just the same over
here and over here so why take four
different channels and perform image
processing on that it's going to take
much more time as compared to what it
will take in only one channel output is
just the same so that was the whole
concept why we took this four channels
and converted it into single Channel or
gr Channel image right and we did it
with the help of computer vision or I
should say open CV Library CV2 library
in the CV2 we are having this option of
CV2 color CVT color which is helpful to
take the image array and with the help
of this flag BG a to gray we can convert
it into gray scale image if you want to
let's say convert it into three Channel
image you you use BG to BGR even that is
fine but now that will be three scaled
image I mean three Channel image because
eventually we wanted a gray scale image
I directly converted that four scale
into uh four channel into one channel
and here is the proof of that it has
been converted successfully and uh yeah
here is the final output that we have
got and here is the pixel distribution
of this in between 0 to
255 right so yes with all this being
said we are done with this uh whole idea
of pixel scaling and looking into some
different ways through which you can
come up with an array and finalize
something that we are going to use for
the upcoming sessions on or I should say
upcoming videos on image processing
after doing some kind of pixel scaling
on this right so stay tuned for that
guys hey guys I welcome you all to this
last module of this program where our
Focus will be to understand how we can
Implement some different type of filters
on the existing image and get some kind
of features extracted out from that
particular image so starting with we'll
be understanding the concept of the
convolution operation then we going to
take an image from our previous module
and apply the Gan denoising technique
with the help of Gan kernel to remove
some of the noise in the data after that
we are going to implement measuring and
setof filter in order to enhance the
features in the image and lastly we are
going to use some of the features of the
SK image Library where we are going to
take corner fener and multi- basic
featur features to extract this kind of
features with respect to this algorithms
how this kind of uh techniques are
working everything will be covered in
this particular module guys so yes
without any further Ado let's get into
this
module hey everyone welcome to the
second video of module 4 and here we're
going to learn about the convolution
operations so what exactly are these
convolutions why do we need it over here
and then what is some kind of practical
demonstration in terms of visualizations
so that you are able
understand okay yeah that's exactly what
is convolution so that's something that
we're going to cover in this video so
let's get right into so now that we are
aware about that we are going to use
this particular image in order to get
some kind of features out of this image
and uh do some cool stuff uh in the
upcoming videos one thing that we need
to do is to remove any kind of noises
present in this image before we actually
go ahead and get those kind of features
out of this image so so we can do this
with a technique called as Gan smoothing
which is nothing but denoising the image
with the help of gajan smoothing
technique how it works it is simply
working on the principle of
convolution so how this convolution
works so it will require one kernel you
can also call it as a filter in our case
it will be a Goan filter right now this
is just a demo filter just to explain
how the convolution works and it will
also require one image now this image in
our case will be this one image so on
this image we are going to place our
gajen kernel and do some convolution
operation then slide that filter one
unit to the right do convolution
operation again slide it to the right do
that convolution operation until you are
sliding across every pixels uh step by
step now that's the whole idea of the
convolution that you are going to
perform with the help of a gan kernel on
the full image so let us try to
understand with this uh GF that I'm
having over here this light blue part
that you are seeing is the image it's a
5x5 image as you can
see now on top of which we are going to
pass this kernel size
3x3 okay so now what is the
convolution so wherever you are seeing
Zero I'm going to pass this zero of this
kernel on top of that now whatever this
is a second zero I'm going to multiply
that with minus one then this 0 will be
multiplied with this zero then this 0
will be multiplied with minus1 60 will
be multiplied with 5 113 will be
multiplied with ne1 0 will be multiplied
with this zero 73 will be done uh
multiplied with minus1 and 121 finally
will be multiplied with the zero after
multiplying all these numbers I'm going
to sum them up together and that
summation output is nothing but the
thing that you are seeing over here as
an output right so if you want to
visualize what I'm trying to say I have
already WR WR this particular thing for
you that you do 0 into 0 then 0 into 0
like 0 into minus one
just map this values of the kernel on
top of this first 3x3 part of the image
multiply it respective uh Elements which
are coming on top of each other and
after multiplying simply add them up
together you will be ending up with the
value called as 144 for the first place
just like that you slide your kernel by
one unit to the right and now it will be
on this 00 6113 56 73 121 154 again to
the same process the output will be 328
so one time if you're doing this that is
one convolution like that you are going
to do multiple convolutions with this
kernel on top of this image and you're
going to finally get the convoluted or
convolved image with the help of Goen
gel right now as I mentioned this is a
dumy kernel to give you this explanation
of how these things work but yeah that's
that's the whole idea of convolution
operation in our case this light blue
kind of thing that you are seeing is
nothing but the original image that we
had uh stored over here this will be the
image on top of which we are going to
create a Goen kernel how we can create
it what are some what are its properties
we are going to discuss about that in
the upcoming video but yeah that's the
whole logic but now you might be
wondering that what is this kind of z0
on top of this right so whenever you
will be implementing the convolution
operation you will always decrease the
size of the output now to keep the same
size that is like you know 5x5 over here
as an input uh we also want the output
as 5x5 so for that specific reason I am
adding a layer of padding and this
padding is nothing but a zero layer
padding it means all the values over
here are 0 0 0 0 0 now there are other
ways through which you can fill up this
values you can also use this kind of a
reflect kind of padding which which
means that this 85 will be reflected
over here 128 will be reflected over
here let's say this 131 will be
reflected over here so even that kind of
thing is possible so in short there is
one padding layer so if we are having a
padding layer this image size will be
what now it will be 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so
it's a 7 by S thing so from that 7 by S
thing after the convolution is over you
are getting this
5x5 however the original image was 5x5
So eventually what we are getting is
that input was a 5x5 image output is a
5x5 image so for that particular reason
we are having a padding layer so I hope
the concept of padding is clear at the
same time what you are seeing over here
that the sliding of this kind of Kernel
on top of the image different different
part this sliding is called as a stride
this is called as a stride St r i d e so
over here we are having the stride value
of one that's why it is moving one one
unit to the right and then one unit to
the down if the stride value was two it
will skip two columns and then start
from this
particular then again skip two columns
and start from the next particular
available part so that's how it's going
to work all right so yeah that's the
concept of padding and strides uh that
is associated with the concept of
convolution now in the next video you
will be seeing that how we can create a
kernel for Goan smoothning and apply it
with respect to the image that we are
having over here and then Denise this
image and after that later on how we can
Implement some of the filters or some of
the feature extraction techniques to get
something out of this particular image
so stay tuned for that
guys hey everyone welcome to this third
video of fourth module and now we are
going to discuss this concept of Goan
denoising as in terms of implementation
I'm going to take one of the image from
the output of module 3 implement the Gan
kernel on top of that and see how the
output looks like after doing this kind
of formulation operation so for this you
will also need to understand what are
the properties of this Gan kernel only
then you'll be able to appreciate this
whole idea so this is exactly what we'll
be discussing in this video so let's get
into
it so basically this convolution
operation with a gsen kernel applies a
weighted average to the neighboring
pixels with the higher values at the
center which are gradually decreasing
towards the edges of the filter so the
filter that you are seeing over here
won't be like this it's a very special
type of filter where the values in the
center are high and at the edges the
values are going to be low okay so this
process is effective in reducing the
high frequency noise and preserving
important image details so how we can
create this kind of a filter and then
how we can do this kind of convolution
operation on that image that we are
having over here so let's try to
understand that part so we will require
the convolution 2D filter from the CPI
signal module how we can do this I'm
going to say that from scipi scipi is
again a library that is pre-installed
over here in the Google collab so you
don't need to uh install it so from
scipi do
signal I'm going to import conall
2D and uh after this I'm am going to
generate my own filter that is not at
all Associated to the cion filter and
the way that I'm going to create this is
with the help of np. ons now what is the
whole purpose of the np. ons so let me
first of all explain that to you so np.
On's if I'm let's say doing it 5 by five
okay I'm passing it in inside a
tuple uh so what is this going to be so
it's a 5x five of 1es now I am just
going to divide all of these values by
four okay
or I should say 25 not
four Why by 25 so that the summation of
all of this values is equal to one now
by doing this particular thing it's
going to preserve the range of the
pixels in a way that it's going to be a
better output basically whenever you are
having this kind of summation equal to
one right so that's the reason why am I
dividing this with 25 so because I'm
having five five cross 5 of one ones so
total in short the summation is 25 right
there are 25 * 1 in the array so that's
why I'm dividing this with 25 so that
now if I take the summation of all of
this the output will simply be one right
so that's for that specific purpose I
have done this thing and now let me just
store it into Kel k r NL is equal to
this okay now uh let's go ahead and uh
actually we have already looked into
that but still I'll just paste it over
here so that yeah you are having the
output now we are going to create a gan
kernel so let me just give a name to it
Gan
Kern I'm going to create it with this
np. array method now what I'm going to
pass over here I'm going to pass this
kind of values 1 by
16 1X 8 1X
16 then come to the second row and now
in the second dra I'm having 1X 8 then
1x4 again by
8 try to look into the pattern that I'm
trying to create over here okay and the
last L again will be very similar to the
first line or I should say exactly the
same 1X 16 1X 8 and 1 by
16 now as you can see that in the center
part we are having the maximum value
present over there and as we are going
to the edges you are seeing that the
values are even smaller so now this is
going to follow the property of the Gan
kernel and even the summation will be
equal to zero if you are going to go
ahead and check it okay and even you can
check it with respect to the graph that
we are having over here that in the
center we are having 1x4 and at the
edges we are having the values of 1x 8
and 1X 16 right as you can see so this
is a 3X3 kernel that we have created
over here I have created 5x5 again over
here if you want to create a 3 by3
kernel you can create it by simply doing
this 3x3 over here also and uh now
because 3x3 in total there are nine
values so I need to divide this by nine
in that case so even this is fine okay
there is one kernel that we have created
like this uh where it is 3x3 so the
output of this will be a total of nine
ones so the summation of that will be
nine so I just divide that with nine so
that overall summation of all of this
values will simply be adding up to one
so I have created two different kernels
one that is a simple kernel and one that
is the Gant kernel now I am going to
show you how we can convolve this with
the help of a con Tod uh thing that we
have imported from ci. signal and show
how the output looks like with respect
to this kernel and the Gant kernel and
again we are going to see it in two
images one that is the M31 pixels by
default and the second one is this
particular image so let's try to go
ahead and visualize
it so get the convolution done with our
normal kernel now how we can can do this
we can simply call Con convolve 2D now
what kind of input it takes it takes the
original image on top of that it takes
the filter and after filter it takes
some kind of padding right so I'm going
to say that uh M31 pixels is the first
thing that I want to choose and then the
normal kernel I want to give as an input
and the padding I can give with the help
of the command mode now this mode I'm
going to keep same keep same padding
means the shape of the output should be
same as the input that's what this means
okay and this will be the output of the
convolution so let's we call it as
convolved convolved
image and we are storing in
this right and we are running this now
and the same thing we are also going to
implement with respect to the Gan
kernel so Gan
G EX the same steps have been repeated
there are no changes at all and now I'm
simply going to visualize both of this
output one with the convol image and one
with the uh let's say because I have
given the same name over here let me
just call this as Goin conal image but I
guess there is a problem okay let me
check what is the Cal that I have
selected over let me just run this code
I'll copy this come over here paste it
again just in case to check if the
spelling is correct and now I'll run
this
so yeah we are having two images and now
we are going to first of all visualize
the first con uh convolution output so
I'm going to do PLT do
IMO of the same thing right so I'll be
using
the blot
pixels and what kind of input I want to
give this is the input title
is
normal colal
convolution and color should be let's
say
maroon so this is the kind of output
that we are able to see right now in the
normal uh kernel convolution right now
what I can do is I can also go ahead and
visualize the Gan G I'm going to copy
this
code see how useful that kind of
function is that we had created in only
one line of code we are able to get all
these things
done
and now this is
Gan kernel
convolution so now again as such we are
not able to see that level of uh output
you can see there's some kind of like
you know some kind of circle circles you
are able to see over here and similarly
over here also you able to see a similar
kind of output right over here because
we are having some
information uh maybe it's done in this
particular way what about this image
yeah over here it's done in that same
fashion so as such we are not able to
see any kind of uh such difference now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
the same thing on the gray scale uh
output that we had created over
here this one I'm just going to copy
this come
down using gray scale to convol and this
gray scale Z int going to convol 2D
going to pass Goan
kernel keep the mode is equal to
C and I'm going to store this into some
kind of output what kind of output we
can give just try to think about that
let's just say uh
convolved gray scale gray scale right
let's this I hope the spelling is
correct over here Co n v l v it seems
correct let me just run
this Con Tod never mind you know my
spellings
ah con 2D going to copy this going to
paste it over
here
okay now let's see how it looks like um
again I'm going to copy
this paste
it and now I'm going to copy this name
paste it over here
and give it as Gan kernel
convolution gajan kernel on Zed
scale
interval let's see how the output looks
like
now so this is the kind of output that
we are having as compared to the
original
image okay as compared to this image
this is the kind of output that we are
having so if it is having some kind of
noises it has simply removed it by
adding some kind of a blurring effect
right so yeah this is what we have done
so far now we are also going to fetch
out the histogram before we go ahead and
Implement any kind of image processing
techniques uh in terms of fil applying
filters and feature extraction
techniques so PLT doist on this
particular output that is the
convol gray
scale I'm going to pass. scale and uh
bins is equal to uh not
scale do flat and bins is equal to 300
pl.
show let's see now the distribution of
the pixels that we are able to fetch
after doing this kind of like you know
convolution with the Gan
K now this is the kind of output see
this is the kind of output that we have
got from
this from this you can see there was
some kind of gaps in between now we are
having this kind
of uh continuous kind of output that we
are seeing over here right all the web
to 255 so yes I guess this is a better
output and now we are going to get all
the kind of features apply different
kind of filters in the upcoming videos
with respect to this convol grayscale
output hi guys I welcome you all to this
fourth video of module 4 and here we are
going to take the image output that we
had got from our previous video that is
the convol denoised image basically and
enhance the features present in it by
implementing two different type of
filters measuring and Sato now both of
this we are going to import it with the
help of SK image so let's get into the
video so now that we have decided that
we are going to use this convol gray
scale output that we have got by uh
doing the gajan blurring uh we going to
come over here and enhance the linear
features on this M31 data and I'm going
to visualize this in multiple different
color maps and therefore I'm defining
this particular list over here called as
spectral list and all of these are
nothing but the color map that in which
we are going to see the output after
implementing two different type of
filters which is going to enhance this
kind of linear features that is
measuring and setof filter and I'm going
to import them from SK image itself so
from SK image.
filters import I don't know the
spellings properly to be honest I'm just
going to copy
this and paste it over here remove the
end part and just give a
comma that's it so this filters have
been imported and now we simply have to
go ahead and do the convolution I mean
uh implement the measuring filter and
the set set of filter on this grayscale
output so what is this gray scale output
I'm just going to copy
that this
one copy this array come
back and let's say this is
a
majoring
filter is equal to this oh not this
actually it should be
maing of
this and for CTO filter CTO output I
should say right measuring output in the
the set output so let me change this to
Output as
well and set this to Seto and paste this
part so after running this particular
code what I should be getting is the
array with the uh filter that we have
implemented on this particular
image now what we are going to do for
every color map that we are seeing over
here we are going to uh create the
output for the measuring filter first
and then for the Seto filter and try to
see that which of this color map is
combined with this measuring filter
giving us the best result so that's the
kind of thing that we are trying to do
over here and now we can achieve this
with the help of
PLT do IM Sho of what I'm trying to show
measuring output May I'm just going to
copy
this and paste it over
here I want to show this with what color
map I want to show the color map I'm
going to create a for Loop over here so
for color map in spectral list I'm again
going to copy this you know the
reason yeah so this I'm going to give an
indentation over here so that we are not
having any kind of errors and now
instead of C map I'll be giving color
map that I am fetching from the spectral
list and after doing this I'm also going
to do this kind of origin is equal to
lower and give a title to this PLT title
TI tle e and with the F string what I'm
going to do is I'm going to give the
name of the color
map and I also tell that this is a
majoring plus this particular thing
right so this is something that I'm
trying to give and let's say measuring
M31 plus this color map I guess this is
good and I'm also going to hide the
exis
okay and now after this I'm also going
to do PLT do show and now I'm going to
run this hopefully it is working the way
I expect if not we'll be modifying this
code okay again we got a name error
spectral list is not defined oh because
we haven't run this code no problem no
problem no problem run this again
hopefully no errors fingers
crossed yes we are getting the outputs
now see how we are getting this outputs
over here we can clearly see this kind
of objects are present over here 1 2 3
here over here also some kind of dull
objects we can we are able to see over
here also some kind of object is being
formed and here is the core of the
androma right now I can just scroll down
and try to see some kind of different
features that we are able to extract
over
here if you're able to find something
different over
here and whatever kind of color map that
you are liking that is giving you the
lot of information you simply use it for
any kind of further analysis Okay the
reason I have printed a lot of uh color
Maps over here is just for your
understanding that we can do this kind
of things now according to your problem
statement whatever it is you choose the
best image that you think According to
which is giving the best result
according to me it's the nip spectral
color map which is giving most of the
information about the
image right now according to whatever is
the hypothesis that you must create and
to prove that hypothesis you can do this
kind of image processing by implementing
different kind of filters and get this
kind of outputs and test your hypothesis
right for example you might have said
that there are some kind of stars at the
uh edge of this kind of image uh near
the galaxies there are this kind of uh
formation of this kind of uh shapes that
we can see near the core of the Galaxy
by default we were not able to see this
kind of information if I just show you
over here we were not able to spot that
well this information as well as this
information but now after implementing
this kind of filters we are clearly able
to uh see this kind of things and trust
me guys this kind of uh thing if you're
able to create a subplot out of it you
can literally extract the subplot
download it and use it in your research
paper the outputs like this how you are
able to describe it it all depends on
your skills of like you know explaining
a visual appearance in front of you
right so I hope you have now understood
that how we are able to get this
particular thing done for the measuring
filter now I can simply go ahead
and look into the Seto filter and look
into the output over here with respect
to that so this is my set output uh this
is my Seto M31 plus color Maps again
same color Maps I'm using and see the
output over here
now
see this one is I guess much better
compared to what we got with respect to
measuring again we are able to highlight
all this kind of information near the
core of the Galaxy even this side part
but this is much visually it's more
appealing as compared to the previous
output that we had got right so yes
according to this kind of outputs
according to your problem statement
according to your understanding whatever
kind of image you can describe the best
you choose that and use it in your
research work right so I hope this kind
of idea with respect to how you can
Implement different filters I have just
shown two examples like this there are
bunch of filters you can uh get with
respect to SK image. filters I can show
you the documentation over here SK
image. filters
documentation okay and I'm also going to
add this part in
your uh notebook also so that you can
just uh take a look into different kind
of filters that are
available
uh take a
look take a look onto
different
available filters in SK image okay I'm
giving this link over here
guys all right so yeah you can explore
any kind of filter that you want to see
how it is working with respect to the
astronomical data that you're dealing
with you just need to know how this kind
of for example this is the filter how it
works what kind of input it's it's
taking and based on this input you try
to get some kind of outputs like this
right so yes guys that's it for this
particular video and now in the next
video I'll be telling you that how you
can extract some kind of features with
uh SK image itself so stay tuned for
that hi guys welcome to this fifth video
of module 4 and here I'm going to show
you that how you can take SK image and
go to its any kind of feature available
in their documentation and Implement to
get some of the outputs on top of the
input image so the one that I'm going to
show you first is the corner fer so what
exactly this is and how we can use it in
Python with the help of the SK image
documentation of the features that's
exactly what I'm going to explain in
this video so let's get into
it so now let's take a look into the
feature detection and extraction with
the help of SK image feature so just
like how we are having SK image. filters
like this we can also have feature if I
just look into that so here is the
documentation again I'll copy this link
and paste it into our particular file
okay I'll also just create this SK image
different
features you can use any one of them by
understanding how to implement that now
that's exactly what I'm going to show
you that how you can use one of the uh
feature that is corner for how we can
use it so what you do is you go to their
official documentation and search for
for that the one that I'm looking
forward to is over here so if I click on
this it's telling me that it's going to
take one input of image and sigma and
the output will be two things okay this
is output will be two things image is an
input shape of M comma n row comma
column and sigma is nothing but the
standard deviation used for the Gan C by
default we'll keep it as one only for
our case as of now but surely you can
play around with this particular value
but the output that we are going to get
over here is w and Q the first output
basically that we are going to get is
the error ellip sizes and the second
output that you're going to get is the
roundness of error lips so if you're not
understanding this kind of technical
terms no problem let's try to go ahead
and try to implement uh how this kind of
uh SK image. feature of uh corner forner
is working okay I'm just going to copy
this
name come over here and first of all UT
this so import okay I should say from SK
image. feature import this going to run
this now you can pass this on any kind
of image that we had created above I'm
again going to use the same image that
we had used over here right you can also
use on top of this set output also if
you want okay but for now I'm just going
to implement it on that uh this
one convolved gray scale okay so let's
go over here
and implement this corner forer on what
gray
scale oh I should say
convolved gray SC right yeah now if I
just run
this and if I check the length of this I
should get two different outputs right I
should have two outputs let me
check yes I am indeed having two
different outputs so now what I'm going
to do is let me just store it as only
one output as of now let's say I'm
calling this as
a feature
output and this feature output is
actually having two different things so
check the output of the feature image
so
feature
output zero the first output that we are
having over here is with respect to
actually uh the error the error ellipse
sizes and the second output is roundness
of error elips okay so this is the first
uh this is the second
right now what exactly it's going to dip
it we are only going to understand once
we are going to visualize them right and
if you want to check the type of this
output that we are
getting uh the type of this actually it
will be in the format of a tle because
it's throwing two different values right
so type of this let's
check and again length we have already
checked that it will be
two now we are going to Define two we
are going to split this kind of thing
into two parts Parts one is for the
error ellipse and one is for the
roundness of error ellipse so you can
just give any kind of variable name that
you are okay with right whatever kind of
name you're okay with but what I'm going
to do is I'm not really going to Define
this as of now I'm just going to delete
this part and color list we have also
already defined as the spectral list
just let me see
spectral yeah let me see if it's still
working yeah we are having all of this
we are just going to use the same uh
color maps and now we are going to
create the visualization
so what how I'm going to do I'm going to
Simply say that
for color map in
spectral
list now what I'm going to do U on the
left hand side I want to visualize the
first output of the feature output and
on the right hand side I'm trying to
visualize the output of the roundness of
error okay one is error and one is
roundness of error so how I can do this
I can achieve this with the help of pl.
subplot now I want to give 1 comma 2
comma 1 now on the first what I want to
show PLT do IM show of feature
output of zero right now any kind of
color map I can give but because I'm
using a for Loop I'm going to give this
color map and origin is equal to
lower yes
I guess this much is fine I can give a
PLT do title as what what kind of title
we can give we can say that this is
error
image plus the respective color
map and I just need to pass this in the
F string and also turn off the AIS PLT
XIs off now I'm just going to copy this
code over
here and repeat the
steps for 1 2 2 but now this will be
feature output one this is roundness of
error
roundness right and I guess we are good
to go and I'll just have PLT do tight
layout because we are plotting the
subplot and then PLT do show hopefully
this is going to work in the way that we
expect let's see how it's going to
work yes first of all we are having the
gray see on the left we are having
nothing thing on the right we are able
to see this kind of circular or ellipse
kind of shapes that is it's being
detecting so yeah this is the kind of
features that you are extracting over
here in the format of an array and this
arrays is what you are visualizing over
here right so you extracted this kind of
features and now you are visualizing
them in different color Maps
right so error image plus prism
roundness of error plus prism then error
image with respect to nipp spectral and
this is with respect to the roundness of
error image with nippy Spectrum so yeah
that's it with respect to what we are
doing uh with Corner Foster I hope this
is making sense that this is one of the
example that we have fetched from this
SK image. feature like this you can go
and check any kind of different feature
like this in the next video you will see
that we are going to try one more
feature extractor actually and that is
multiscale basic features the local
features so I'll talk about that in the
next video and over here you can surely
go ahead and try to check out some
different feature by yourself try to
implement it and just note that you need
to know how it is working by looking
into its documentation if you are able
to look into that if you're able to do
your research properly you can use any
kind of feature for a specific task that
you're looking forward
to all right guys I'll see you in the
next
video hi everyone welcome to this last
video of this particular particular
module and here we are going to go ahead
and understand how we can implement this
skmh feature called as multiscale basic
feature by following its documentation
and just like what we did in our
previous video the same stuff we'll be
implementing over here and see what type
of outputs we are able to achieve so
let's get
started so now let's try to look into
one more feature that is present in the
SK image that is uh known as multiscale
basic features so I'm going to press
contr F to search this multiscale I had
already searched for that but I'm yeah
that's where it is so over here it's
going to take all of these kind of
different parameters you can read its
respective information for now I'm just
going to pass the image and keep
everything as default I'm not going to
change anything obviously it's up to you
how you want to change it and get the
outputs the way you want and the output
will be uh an array of the shape of
whatever is the row and column plus some
nend features so as you can clearly see
that it's trying to detate multiscale
basic features it's going to give us the
uh local features for a single or multi-
Channel end dimensional image right and
it's going to be actually the intensity
gradient intensity and local structure
are computed at different scales thanks
to gajan bluring so all of this kind of
information is what we are having and
what we are able to understand from this
is that from a given image it it can
give us multi Channel output and in each
of the channel that we are going to get
each channel will have one kind of
feature that has been extracted so if
I'm trying to implement
this first of all I need to import this
particular thing so I'm going to say
that import this
feature so from SK image do
multiscale basic
features oh I should say do feature
import this name I'm just going to copy
this very
quickly and paste it over here and going
to run
this and now I'm going to create a
featured let's say a
feature
image I'm going to call this with the
help of
this and I'm going to pass in the
conval gray scale okay
so this is the kind of input that I'm
passing in and now I'm going to run this
now let's say what is the type of this
thing that we have got previously we had
got tle right now let's see what do we
get now it's a nump AR because that's
what we expect over here as an output
it's going to return an array so that's
why we are seeing an array type in the
return of this now let's look into the
shape that's something important so this
do shape is
what so we got 300 by 300 and there are
24 local features that has been
extracted and each of the channel is
having some different types of
extraction of this features and has been
stored over with the respective channels
over here now what we are going to do is
we are going to extract each and every
channel out of this and uh create a list
out of it basically how we can do this
I'm going to use CV2 functionality of
split
and I'm going to pass this featured
image
spit featured image I'll be creating a
list of all the outputs that we get if
I'm running this it's going to give us a
total of uh if I check the length of
this output it must be
24 the split means what it's going to
split all the channels and it's going to
give us as an output each and every
channel and all the channels will be of
the shape 300 by 300 so that's the kind
of output that we are going to get so
first of all I'm just going to like you
know store it in P1 P2 P3 P4 and
everything that's exactly what I'm going
to do so I'm not going to write
everything and make you guys bored what
I'm going to do is I'm copy that part
paste it over here say that this is
equal to that if you notice because I
was having 24 different outputs I'm
having P1 all the way up to p24 if I
want to check this
P1 and also looking into the shape of
that it must be 300 by 300 right just
like that I can also check
p24 do
shape and yes because everything looks
fine I'm going to go ahead and create a
list out of
this okay I'm simply going to go ahead
and create a list out of this and call
it as
pixels different pixels that I have
created right and my goal is to
visualize all of this uh features that
we have
extracted uh in a particular color map
any kind of of color map that you like
I'll be choosing a color map called U I
guess if I'm not wrong I'm going to
choose pixel
prism okay I hope it is present over
here somewhere yeah this prism right so
I'm just going to copy
that where it is where it is where it is
it's over here so I'm going to copy
this come
back where we
were yeah and now finally visualize this
kind of pixels in only one color map and
uh there will be 24 different outputs so
what I'm going to do is
for
feature in
pixels what I want to do PLT do
IMO of uh
feature right I want to use color map
only one color map that is this one
prism color map and uh origin
is equal to
lower and PLT do
title I can say that um this
is feature one feature two like that I
can give this kind of things I can also
use enumerate over here
enumerate so what is this enumerate
going to do it's going to give me two
things index
values as well as the feature that is
like what is present inside this pixels
so with this I I'm going to so what is
feature that is it feature one feature
two right so it is Feature
Feature then i+ one because index will
start from zero so feature one all the
way to feature 24 that's the kind of
title that I'm giving and then PLT doxis
I'm going to turn it off as usual and
PLT do show so if I run this hopefully
it's going to be running the way that I
am expecting yes it is indeed feature
four like this you will just see that
the output we are getting over here we
got feature 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 see how
in all this image we are getting
different kind of features that has been
extracted right see all these kind of
things all these kind of different
features that are associated to this 24
outputs that we have got all of this we
are able to visualize that and now we
are able to visualize that in one color
map that is called as prism right you
can also do this with the help of DP SP
also gray scale whatever you are
comfortable right so yes these are the
kind of outputs that we have got we can
see this kind of uh all these kind of
different features right and currently
because we haven't defined any specific
hypothesis that what exactly we are
trying to look forward to so that we
cannot prove anything over here it's
just that I'm trying to show you that
how with the help of this kind of
feature extraction techniques that is
present in SK image you are able to
fetch this kind of information
now any image that you are seeing over
here any
output whichever you think is describing
the thing that you're looking for you
look for that specific image and then
write about that particular part in your
thesis research work internship report
whatever it is whatever you are working
on right so yes guys that's the whole
process let me just try to visualize
this in nippy
spectral
I'm assuming that is going to look much
better yeah this is my personal favorite
guys okay nipp
spect yes indeed it's giving us a good
result right wherever there are this
kind of spots the Stars we can clearly
see that here is the nucleus of our
particular anoma Galaxy over here also
we are able to see something right so
all this kind of information over here
we also able to spot this kind of stars
in the background right even this kind
of feature over here this feature over
here all of them are
highlighted so yeah that's the beauty
about this kind of feature extractors
and obviously I'm not going into the
details of what all kind of things you
can extract let's say if your image is
having some kind of jets coming out from
the center of the uh Galaxy it might be
indicating that it's coming from some
kind of a like you know x-ray sources
and that x-ray sources are nothing but
indicating a presence of black hole or
something that is ejecting this kind of
high energy uh x-ray beams right so with
respect to that whatever kind of
particles you can associate with you can
create your hypothesis and uh work on
that so yes guys that was about how you
can use different image processing
techniques once you are importing the
image I have shown you how you can apply
different type of image uh processing
techniques by implementing two different
filters and also two different feature
extractors so yes guys that was about
this particular
video all right guys so with this being
said over here we are finally done
completing each and every module of this
program now I'll be creating one more
video after this to conclude everything
in just one video from the start till
the end and what are some kind of
further steps that you can take in order
to continue your journey in terms of
astronomical image processing or some of
the other stuff that can help you from
the programs that we have uploaded on
udm itself so stay tuned for that hi
everyone I welcome you all for one final
time in this program on astronomic
research data analysis first of all I
congratulate each and every one of you
to successfully complete all the four
modules of the program now let's go
ahead and conclude this whole program
that we had conducted so to start with
in the module one we looked into the
very basics of python that you need in
order to create cre some amazing
visualizations that you have created by
the end of module 4 in each of these
modules you were creating some kind of
different types of visualization so yeah
for those things we uh understood some
basic uh of the Python after that we
moved on to module two where we took the
tabul boring kind of data of stars and
converted some amazing visualizations on
top of that we created the bar plot we
created the line chart we created a lot
of different visualizations including
the HR diagram then we moved on on to
module 3 over there we took the data
from the astronomical surveys like sdss
DSS and then did some pixel scaling on
the image that we have got in order to
find some interesting things that you
can see in that particular image then in
module 4 we use the output from module 3
in order to enhance the features that
were present in that image which we
couldn't see till module 3 but in module
4 we saw a lot of things depending on
some kind of feature extraction
techniques that we had seen from the SK
image so by now you must be having this
kind of an idea that whatever type of
visualization you want to create in
Python you are now eligible to do that
you can save this visualizations and use
this in any kind of your research work
that you are doing uh or maybe
internship report or even the thesis
work all of these kind of things you can
surely go ahead and use this so with all
these things being said I'll Bid
Farewell to all of you guys and I hope
to see you anytime soon in future thank
you guys